the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
expected results at the super bet chess
classic in Romania uncharacteristic
blunders made for exciting outcomes with
three decisive games Frenchman Maxine
vashir lagrav took advantage of a huge
slip-up defeating Richard Rapport to get
within Striking Distance of the
co-leaders after struggling throughout
chakra mama diarov and alaresa borugia
finally tasted victory scoring their
first wins of the event the Americans
are in the lead but NBL is in Hot
Pursuit day eight of Sensational chess
coming up next
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
of the 2022 Superbad chess Classic held
here in Bucharest Romania today we have
a very exciting day and we start a day
in the playing Hall as we are waiting
for the players to arrive and start the
action who's going to take the lead and
take another step towards the title only
time will tell let's go to the studio
and start the action with Yasser Peter
and Alejandro
identic pictures of the beautiful
Romanian capital as we welcome you to
our coverage of the Superbad chess
classic in Bucharest our first stop on
the 2022 grandchester
morning I'm Peter swindler and with me
is yasa serial Peter as always a
pleasure to be calling all the action
with you and Alejandro hello everyone
round seven will go down as the round of
howlers as we head three really really
really bad one move blunders in two of
the games it was fatal in one of the
games clemency was granted let's take a
look at all the standings as we start
these Championship rounds Peter rounds
eight and nine coming up with only two
rounds to go the station at the top
actually tightened up a little bit
Wesley and levonne are still leading
still having exemplary tournaments both
of them but mvl with his victory
yesterday over Richard Rapport who is
really not having a good time over here
is has made the tournament a lot more
open and MBL is also wide today against
the local boy I'm slightly preempting
the show here which could make the
situation for round nine even more
interesting potentially exactly and our
format either the format is a temple
play around Robin with 90 minutes for
the first 40 moves 13 minutes for the
rest of the game with a half a minute
increment starting from one draw for his
nope and you have the classical scoring
for a system in place with one point for
a win and half a point for a drop our
schedule sure shrank a bit Yeah the
schedule the schedule here yeah today
Friday uh the 13th we have around eight
and tomorrow uh we get the ninth round
and the coverage begins uh one hour
earlier which is uh just fantastic
fantastic brutal news and also tomorrow
we will have playoffs if necessary which
does look extremely possible right now
and these are the scenarios the rules
for the playoffs uh if only two players
are tied they play a two-game rapid
match of uh 15 plus 10 kind of classical
rapid time control if it's more than two
if it's more than two players uh there
is a round drop in uh played with uh ten
plus five because obviously time
constraints will become a thing even if
there's still a type of first uh there
will be a single Armageddon game played
uh five minutes for the Y for white four
minutes for black and black gets uh
drawns and the important thing here is
the uh the unmentioned thing that uh
grandchester is no longer using any kind
of mathematical tie breaks but first
which I think is a very very correct
solution there should be things need to
need to be settled over the board and
this is what we're seeing here wonderful
wonderful and Alejandro good morning St
Louis good morning to you my friends
pleasure to be here in spooky Friday the
13th but we have some great games coming
up Championship rounds upon us let's
take a look at what happened so far in
the tournament starting with the
decisive results in the event 12 out of
35 in my opinion does not do it justice
this is not an unusual amount of
decisive games but I felt that we had
the potential for so much more in so
many different games we had so much
action but 12 out of 35 certainly not
bad six of those games were won by white
and six of those games we won by black
50 50 split so far between the players
certainly aronian fighting there for the
black side Wesley for the white side as
they both have two wins a piece with uh
different colors nine out of 10 players
have won at least one game the only
player that hasn't won a game so far is
Ricard report the candidate going into
Madrid but don't worry if you're a fan
of him he will have plenty of
tournaments to get his form back before
that starts and the tournament leaders
neither Wesley nor Levon have lost the
game in this tournament so far okay
let's see how they got here we got Levon
aronian who had a tumultuous tournament
he had certainly a tough round against
furuja in round three he somehow managed
to survive and then he came back beat
Lanier Dominguez in round four and then
took advantage of his opponent's
mistakes as well in round six winning
with the black pieces against Maxima
Sherlock quite easily and now sits
pretty on plus two and his countryman
Wesley so complete a different
tournament but also on plus two he
started off by defeating shock maradiara
from a solid position as opponent
cracked Under Pressure same thing
happened to yam nepomyachi in round four
Wesley also with the white pieces in a
technically drawn position as well as
they called it but still tons of
pressure in that one to continue and
nepo was unable to sustain and suddenly
we see two players at the top but a
certain Mech seems still saying hey I'm
still in the event I still have my ice
on first place well let's see how they
shape up today let's take a look at our
key pairings with our friends in
Bucharest Anastasia and Christian
thank you Alejandro and welcome back
everybody to day 8 of the 2022 super
best chess classic from location here in
Bucharest Romania to call all the action
and give you all the updates of this
important Championship rounds I am your
host Grandmaster Christian kirila
alongside my brilliant co-host one
Grandmaster Anastasia karlovich
Anastasia welcome back to the studio
before we get into the games tell us a
bit about your morning what did you do
this morning actually I was doing
literally nothing you know I was just
relaxing because today it's Friday 13th
so you better don't do that much what
about you Kristen well actually one of
my favorite things to do whenever I come
here in a Bucharest is go visit with my
Jiu-Jitsu coach so I went there I had a
private lesson I got my uh butt kicked
and now I'm ready to watch the games
speaking of the games what games do you
have your eyes set on yeah actually I'm
looking forward to to follow the game
between Padano Carano and Richie Robert
yesterday Richard had such a crazy
blunder and I'm sure his mood is not so
great his self-confidence went down and
as someone who blundered more pieces
than anyone else in the studio I really
know what he feels and I really hope he
will still be able to come back and have
a good game today against one of the
most I would say serious players in this
tournament Pagano carvana you know you
don't have really breaks in this
tournament you lost the game and next
game you have to play against another
strong opponent so I hope this game will
be very interesting also knowing that
Fabiano is looking forward to still keep
fighting for the first places in this
tournament actually that's going to be
an incredible matchup indeed as you are
mentioning Anastasia but I do have my
eyes on what I do think is going to be
the game of the round that is the one
between one of the co-leaders Wesley so
the American sensation who will be
facing Ali Reza firuja one of the
candidates in this event and definitely
the player that after yesterday's
Victory got a boost of confidence this
one is a very interesting matchup as we
can see only one time these players met
over the chessboard and that one went in
Wesley's favor will alireza be able to
bounce back well let's go to the studio
and start this exciting Round Guys what
games do you have your eyes set on well
thank you Anastasia thank you Christian
of course we're here Christian to help
pump you up don't worry don't worry your
Jiu Jitsu coaches I want to say that
this casual name drop of his Jiu Jitsu
coach is very much inspired by the fact
that our viewers correctly pointed out
that I would win in a fisticuff yes the
cops fight among the all the all the
casters here and money was nothing
nothing will will change that that is
now in history books Christian please
don't don't fight it no question those
are two you guys picked two of the great
games but let's take a look at all the
pairings all the pairings for this champ
Championship rounding yeah up top there
we see a shot from Madera who finally
won a game yesterday a very uh a swingy
game I would say but still a win as a
win and he is today uh playing the with
the white pieces against linear uh the
game against Wesleyan Fury is definitely
also my Peak for the central game of the
round going to be extremely interesting
to watch because I'm pretty sure if at
all possible would prefer not to make a
quiet draw with black but to have a
full-blown fight MBL is uh White against
Bogdan there a very important game for
his tournament because uh he pretty much
needs to win it feels like to be in
contention for uh for first agree
because of how solidly both Wesley and
the one are playing and there's
arriving at the board
very nice and uh as Alejandro has been
saying Peter uh the Fighting Chess
throughout I was gonna say uh
we're not a Fighting Chance Peter what
are they fighting for yeah the the price
fund which we haven't touched upon yet
is a very very nice price one today as
is always the case in GCT events the
first figure yeah and a very nice round
figure up top there hundred thousand
dollars first and the GCT points which
is something this is only the first
event of the tour but this will become
more and more relevant because there is
also an additional purse for for the gc2
tour standings uh overall uh you get 13
points if you win the tournament
outright and well with you in the tie
break if you win the tie breaker first
and the prices go all the way down to
10.5 for the last and winning the grand
chest work not only comes with a very
nice title and trophy but also some
serious bonus money to be first in the
grand chess tourists they get started
for round eight we have a special guest
who will be doing the opening first
moves
yeah as you can see on the screen every
day we had very very illustrious guests
uh
making the the honorary first move and
today uh we think but well without
information this is a bit risky but we
think this is Sebastian borduja uh
minister of digitalization and the
founding father of uh packed political
movement for freedom and there
potentially will be one more first move
made but we'll wait for for the pictures
from Bucharest before convention yeah
venturing that opinion yeah there we
have it uh and this is
once again apologies for any potential
mispronunciations there who's a a famous
kickboxer and boxer uh two-time Glory
heavy weight champion
uh I take it all back my money's on
Benny yeah Benny probably starts six
starts
exactly with our panel is Christian
included you get the feeling that he
probably got the Feeling somewhat ahead
yeah yeah
and continuing uh uh
to uh the tradition of very very
prominent Sports people making first
moves during this tournament and uh here
it comes yeah that is that is very cute
now what are we looking at D4
a move that belies her youth yeah
oh I think she wrote to Richard and I
know who fit her favorite is yeah
and again just
oh we're gonna have even a fourth uh I'm
gonna run out of sports
okay I think that was a false alarm
about a fourth uh guest of honor and
yeah because of my long-windedness we
failed to announce a couple of a couple
of uh bearings yeah so yeah the game
between 5B and Richard is very important
as well because yeah Rickard is really
having a nightmare feeling yeah yeah
yesterday's blunder must have really
shaken me as you can see there he
and I think without prior to yesterday I
would have been very very interested in
this but I think yes yeah yesterday's
game with uh with Jan First missing a
number of very strong options and at one
point anything missing just a very
clear-cut win which really he should
have been able to find because the move
that that one in that position is one of
the very first that comes to mind and
then you just continue calculation you
just don't stop you continue calculating
and none of the moves are that difficult
there right and yeah he he does get into
kind of spirals he it's we've seen him
uh
react to losses like this
with the
a certain amount of tilt that's what I
wanted to say I think at the very very
top especially Magnus I mean you don't
see the Tilt but where nepo is concerned
and he gets on these streaks whether
they're up or down and he has a very
hard time yeah when things are not
breaking his way yeah we also we hear
some sort of behind behind the doors
stories about Magnus also tilting but he
like the evening after a very bad game
he probably dispends uh you know doing
whatever the chess standard of like
trashing trashing your hotel room you
know routine is but right you don't see
it the next day as much he he is a lot
better than many of his colleagues at
sort of limiting limiting it to sort of
exactly the same evening and waking up
in a much better frame of mind Peter a
question for you what was your worst bad
streak I.E losing streak ever I lost
four in a row twice in my career twice
twice oh my word I I'd lost one time
three in a row and I thought the world
of physics had just turned itself upside
down and nothing made sense anymore I
was really shaken yeah
the first one you can sort of explain
but the second one really did kind of
hurt because that was the European Club
cop 2018
and yeah and uh I had I think three
whites out of four oh and uh and I was
playing against strong Grandmasters but
feel like I was I was like a hundred
points ahead higher rate every every
game and I just kept on sort of losing
my mind and doing stupid things and also
getting outplayed like one of the games
I lost there was against uh Roman eduard
who is uh our Grandmaster in Residence
here right now yeah he outplayed me but
I also blundered something really stupid
in one movement now it wasn't a very
pleasant experience the first time it
happened was the Linares 199 I believe
where I lost like in a row to kramnik
Kasparov evanchuk and uh and one more
game and this can happen to you this
this you can definitely understand how
this happens like you lose one and
wishing that that game where I
specifically asked him over the board
that he plays Castle's check and not
look of one check the famous game well I
mean quote unquote famous but yeah it's
a famous game in my mind uh it was like
move 27 I wanted the game to end with
Castle's check uh
since we're both having a confessional
Alejandro join right in what was your
worst losing streak and how did it
impact you
uh I don't think I have such a bad
streak I mean I've lost three in a row
but I think everybody has at some point
but I think my worst tournament I win
minus seven and somehow only two of
those losses were in a row I don't know
how I managed that it was in Vikings I
had I mean I was playing some strong
players I was playing Magnus Sergey
shock was there but I ended up scoring
like terribly minor seven and uh I quit
and went to college
and there is that as an alternative uh
theater
I tried that for a semester yeah
um it seems to me like uh the king's
Indian yeah
a full uh throttled game uh the king's
Indian and Knight F3 uh the main stuff
not not the very nice Bishop E2 Customs
H4 you know castles H4 that Daniel yeah
offered against Ali eraser but instead
Knight F3 very traditional we keep an
eye on that let's continue uh Lavon whoa
where I noticed that nepo had played his
first two moves got up from the board
hasn't played another move since yeah
I'm waiting for his return he needed
needed a refreshing break yeah
okay everybody's favorite Petrov going
on here that's a sharper picture
potentially that might be that might be
a an interesting game and this is the
first occurrence in this Tournament of
the most fashionable Petrov currently
which is the bishop Bishop D6 line right
yeah so far we've had mainly the bishop
596 constructions which are extremely
solid and have done well for black in
this tournament in general but uh are a
lot more quiet this could be very very
sharp this is a very interesting
position to discuss actually okay we'll
keep our eye on that and more of that
yeah of the game between Fabi and
Richard Richard played this earlier in
the tournament I'm always down for this
variation this is such a weird line so
many different ideas can be put forward
even Knight takes D5 has been seen
recently I love this line I think it's
D5 yeah 1985 C4 is like not so stupid
really followed by C4 oh no sorry sorry
C4 later and I didn't mean C4 right now
I've had like C4 at some point yeah okay
it
sure does look funny but 94 was very
quickly played I noticed by by uh Fabi
yeah and uh Richard
goes Bishop B7 here which is a much uh
quieter option compared to the craziness
that he played against others I believe
right yes yeah
and Bishop B7 is Richard yes this is uh
this is going to be a we all assume we
know what what happens from here and
yeah those positions are a lot quieter
uh uh if you misplay them with black you
don't entirely equalize I've had a
reasonably recent game in the the last
uh Super Final I played in 2020 I had
this against uh
Artemis I think and I came very close to
winning that game because he misplayed
it somewhere after the opening the line
goes here if we could sure for foretell
the future a little bit you play
bishpitsu Black plays C5 first because
you need the C6 Square for the queen as
you will see in a moment castles
uh 93 exists but it's not very good so
they play Queen C7
uh 96 check take Stakes taking is of
course impossible because c2c4 will win
the piece and C4 is just a major major
tactical threat so they play Queen C6
creating an idea of 93 uh and white
white goes F3
C4 needs to be stopped so black policy
for themselves Queen D4 castles
uh Bishop takes C4 Queen takes uh Queen
takes D6
or Rook FCA at first but that end game
actually I think is supposed to be much
better for white so they take 26 first
and you start from here it looks very
pleasant for why because I mean couple
of Bishops no weaknesses and it does
become very very nice for white if black
as I mentioned doesn't play very
precisely but I think the tendency here
is
with precise play Black should come very
close to or perhaps just straight up
equalize wow this seems after Bishop B7
this seems very very heavily favored to
be on the board in a
a few in a few minutes who in your mind
Peter or this for our Audience by the
way none of that will happen
for our audience uh who are interested
in playing either the white side or the
black side who are the guides that you
think of as Specialists of this line for
white or for black that specifically the
Four Knights or this position yeah or
both this this I think hasn't really
been seen often enough to have uh to
have a like a mentor a mentor a
specialist you you want to name
hmm
yeah I wouldn't people people dabbled in
this and obviously this has not happened
already right before night before on the
board so yeah this entire speech was
yeah but it was I'm very well rehearsed
yeah I gotta tell you I mean I I mean I
I felt I felt moved
but go on so you don't you say you don't
really have you wouldn't but a single
name doesn't immediately come to mind I
think it's not a popular enough line to
have I have a person associated with
this c49 before already on the board I'm
actually very happy I wasted everybody's
time there because this looks like it's
much sharper than the position this
could be a lot more fun yeah I was
actually surprised about your evaluation
of that end game I did some work on it
recently and came to the exact opposite
conclusion that you can actually go Rook
FC Bishop D5 Queen D5 and hold yeah no
you can't go Bishop D5 because Queen D6
you have to go B3 anyway
that's a different topic yeah
okay uh night before uh at first blush
it really looks like uh black species
are kind of being pushed to and fro and
uh at a certain moment Knight D6 might
just be Splat yeah I mean ideally we
want to play A3 and yeah we need to we
need to explain why A3 doesn't doesn't
please sort of win the game on the spot
and there are actually there are two
options for of uh for why but I think
yeah I think C5 is the reply I think
Queen A5 is maybe a little bit too
adventurous it's Adventures but if
you've engineed it up it actually works
out probably okay if you engine it up I
like that is that that new Chesapeake
yeah why that gets plenty of
compensation for his Pawnee eventually
loses on E5 or for the exchange she
gives up right but uh I think it's
quite playable for black
yeah this is just I'm trying to remember
what the theory is in the current
position and kind of failing I think C5
is yeah C5 I think is no I mean not here
uh in in the one they have on the board
right now yeah instead of A3
uh just instead of A3 I think A3 is
nowhere near the the main movie you go
C5 so they play Bishop A6 here or
Bishop Ace remember yeah
you know it's one of the I can see on
the screen that it's one of the uh two
main moves in this position it looks
kind of outlandish to waste this much
time seriously uh shuffling the same
pieces but the bishop 1b7 is going to be
a huge huge problem for black if it
doesn't get traded at all yeah and this
is now the kind of the precise moment
when it can get uh traded off sobish
Basics makes perfect sense strategically
it's just very slow but by the way we
have uh none of the we do have C5 yeah
and 28 is the most uh is the most
popular move in that position actually
this I wasn't aware of at all but it's a
very straightforward idea as well yeah
we're attacking the E5 Pawn I'm assuming
Bishop A6 is still very much on the menu
but perhaps Richard wants to provoke
something like F4 first exactly and then
go for it it's a funny position because
it's not clear that the queen B8
inclusion helps black
but there are Arguments for both sides
actually playing Bishop A6 first makes
also sense because the queen can go to a
five in one move
but F4 is already defending the pawn on
the other hand you're weakening your
dark squares it's it's not a hundred
percent of them of Queen B8 it helps
black or not
yeah yeah and and uh yeah I'm expecting
which by six after four four already on
the board four on the board yeah you you
do you do want to get those Bishops and
I can only Echo uh what you've just said
uh as strongly as I possibly can this
bishop is septic it's a terrible bishop
and you better Play Bishop A6 before you
get to keep it for the rest of the game
and you will not like it so I'm
anticipating Bishop A6 and that was
quickly played as well as Richard
Richard
is kind of got that look like man I got
better things to do with my time than
just played this position uh
dangerous yeah I mean here's here's
another one of of the players in this
tournament who I think is very very
interesting no introspect like
introspective and severely severely
self-critical Bishop E2 on the board I
don't know if he even
I would suspect he maybe doesn't till
that much he just kind of
he starts looking very much inwards and
when when you have a tournament like
this perhaps looking inwards very deeply
is not not necessarily the way to go
Queen B5 and queen B5 already played
yeah quickly played by
um Richard it's very logical yeah
because yeah you you want to do this
while the king is still only one because
uh if you allow white to Castle very
very easily uh you might come under
severe attack in the center with like
five ideas happening very quickly okay
so Queen B5 looks like it might actually
be forcing the Queens off yeah this was
missed on Fire's prep
what how do you know that I'm numb I've
known my guy for a while I don't know
how do you how do you Blitz pizza and
not yeah look at Queen I I just I just
looked at my stockfish and I went all
the way up to one and then it retreated
to point three I have a feeling it's not
one of the top thousand moves okay or it
might be a Lila move and stockfish
doesn't find it I don't know but
I mean queen you have to play Queen B5
what other move do you have here right
the very the very least it's a very
logical move here you can play something
like 95 it should be seven no I mean
that's white in this position oh yeah
you have to take the screen but what
other move do you have I mean yeah 93
check allowing 93 check doesn't look
very tasty yeah yeah I mean yeah maybe
bishop is no Bishop Bishop B3 yeah
I don't like that I was thinking maybe
A4 but then again why am I letting the
light uh letting the Knight live on and
we're being informed of Bishop actually
is a novelty so Fabi sort of got the
first idea in yeah uh but yeah Queen D5
and yeah we'll trust Alejandro on this
because Alejandra has has been around
far be enough uh we'll trust him on uh
Queen B5 potentially being either missed
or severely underestimated let's put it
it could be it could have been analyzed
and he just didn't think it was their
main line trying to remember
yeah let's just get a taste of what
might happen yeah this still doesn't
look horrible at all for white but no I
I'm sidestepping then I might see two
Fork I mean you could still presumably I
don't yeah I don't think I don't think
G3 is actually that good in terms of
sort of long-term strategic ideas for
black I very much like the idea of
trying to play [ __ ] B7 and F6 to open
up at least something some sources of
contemplate open up the f file either
weakened the pawn on E5 or provoke efgf
which is also something that and then
yeah I'm pretty sure it always goes to
C6 C6 as opposed to D5 I prefer C6 here
I could you articulate why you think
that because I'm a grundfill player in
this setup like Knight on C6 in front of
the Pawn on C5 with the black Pawn on B5
is Like Home to me uh I don't know if
they like see when you're born grunfeld
player no matter everything starts to
look like a group yeah it's not really a
legitimate prison to play 96. okay I I
still feel like it's not a bad idea but
the 95 is very uh it's very logical as
well if I if I had to try to articulate
why 96 and not 95
I you know not in this position but
eventually some exchange sacrifices on
D5 might become available currently
white is very far away from even you
know attacking in 1995 with the Rook
because of the bishop
before before followed by four is
definitely a plan but right whether it's
going to bring but I mean it doesn't
actually do like if we continue here
yeah I don't even we don't live in Casa
let me try just doing it as first place
here and let's say I take it yeah efgf
you go A4 B8
king of seven rook hb8 and you're just
in time to uh yeah and this is why I won
the Knight on C6 because it kind of
connects everything it well makes
Napoleon A7 into much less or weakness
it would have been otherwise okay and I
think if we do manage to uh force or
this is provoky fgf yeah I go I go F5
here and then D5 check and I hope that
I'm okay right D5 check well I mean the
Knight has to go somewhere right yes I
assume I mean 95 check exists but I'm
not that worried right and let's say
here I go G6 or D5 check I don't know
what do you like better I got you I'm
black is completely fine maybe maybe
even more yeah because now the yeah yeah
95 check yeah it it's possible but even
if even if I don't have any active count
to play and I do have some counter play
here like how do you make progress
against the setup with the blue Rooks on
B5 NBA yeah I mean either either I crash
through on D7 or I don't and I'm just
thinking that uh after the move Queen B5
I'm more or less where where else am I
going Alejandro in this variation uh if
I'm not playing King E2 and
yeah you just played it a little slow
I'm thinking it's you you just want to
play a four next move
and I'm not necessarily uh jumping in
with Bishop D2 then just start right
away yeah makes makes perfect sense yeah
because you might not have the Tempe to
do this as black as we've just seen yeah
but I did get this I'm here yeah this
actually is much faster yeah I was going
to say just ba and 96 and Rook B8 but
this might not be fast enough now
uh 96 let's say I don't know before Oba
Bishop G2 and he played a group B1 next
move and B5 will already be a threat
uh yeah last time I was trying to get my
king up here but uh are you playing F6
or are you playing I would like to but I
don't think I have the time like efgf
rugby one I'm worried
or white uh very afraid of Knight C3
yeah now we have Knights of three so you
might be able to shift my uh because if
this blockade is not is not established
I'm in a lot of trouble clearly like
some positions like this might be
borderline lost so exactly uh yeah I'm
not happy about this outcome okay well
we'll definitely keep our eye so what
are we supposed to play again after King
YouTube because I think you you can you
can definitely spend a Tempo here with
black trying to prepare for it like you
can play Knight G6 to have a 4b4 as an
option
I didn't want to spend a Tempo on it but
maybe I have to because I think maybe
closing like having the queen side
closed is important enough to to start
burning Tempe as early as this
intriguing
and we're expecting it so King it all
looks much more logical than castles the
king is quite well placed in the center
I would say it it feels uh better in the
center yeah and in the meantime I want
to kind of uh alarm alarm
Wesley took one look at that King's
Indian oh yeah like haha King's Indian
no game for you today I traded
everything off the board the the old
queen young man do you want to play C8
yes what is that chest that you speak of
yeah oh that's too bad yeah Alejandro uh
show what's what's drawn your attention
sorry
the same day well I was looking at this
right this is a line of the king's
Indian that's very very drawish right uh
you can see that the potential for
symmetrical structure once C takes D5 is
on the board it's pretty high
um white retains like a modicum of
initiative but engines have equalized it
by force basically by this point and
even like ideas of b5a5 are not
completely
it'd be 585 is something they played B5
Bishop B7 followed by 97 or perhaps even
c65 giving away this wonderful
protective passer only five I've seen
I've seen being done just to destabilize
the position a bit Yeah and yeah the
thing about this position is that it is
very often used by uh players low rated
their their opponents trying to make a
draw with white again
and in that particular matchup with with
somebody quite good playing on somebody
not as good on the white side black wins
quite a bit actually because people have
found ways to take risks here with black
but not allow the very very easy draws
that white is clearly uh kind of asking
for but you know this is not the
situation here uh Wesley Wesley is not
that player he just wants a safe game
here but he will know what to do against
the most topical tries and you know if
he gets a bite here he will once again
become become re-energized and he will
play for a win if he if alares pushes it
a little bit too far uh speaking about
those moment months where the lower
rated player who's on White Shoes is
playing against the king's Indian I
remember a game from the Barcelona World
Cup where Jesus no guerra's a lower
rated player was up against Gary
kasparra
noguire's reach for his F Pawn he did
play F4
these four pawns attacks the the lines
are so sharp and so forcing that
oftentimes when you get to the very end
equal yeah and F4 if you want to make a
draw against the king's Indian I got to
tell you Gary was Furious because I mean
Jesus had no problems whatsoever making
a draw as white this is the alternative
of course and as you were just kind of
suggesting
sometimes the black player does outplay
uh
his lower rated opponent and
specifically I think it is connected
with this idea of
avoiding the trade of the C6 and the D5
pawn it looks kind of strange and
difficult to achieve right now because
why it seems to be in control of that
right but you can definitely prepare and
then play c65 leading to those really
strange structures where I suspect white
is under no pressure whatsoever to start
with but uh it could get double edged
and yeah the lifetime score between
those two players is is very simple yeah
they played once and Wesley won a very
very protracted uh game in uh uh hang on
a second that's not the one I wanted
yeah but Wesley Wesley is one one knee
lap uh and uh they will play plenty more
I'm sure they will the college game
where they played that one game again
where at where was it plate sorry uh
yeah the one the one I yeah it was it
wasn't like but Wesley actually said it
in an interview yesterday and and then
for some reason I mistrustedly
mistrusted his opinion yeah uh and that
was actually a a qga with uh 7b3 the
kind of a position that uh we also have
one of them today I was about to say now
the Queen's Gambit accepted it does seem
to be one of the openings of the
tournament uh I want to say sadly as
does this game between Ian and uh Lavon
we blinked and guess what uh this uh
this whole uh variation that we saw from
uh recently it was
nepo yeah versus Shaq right and that was
the Knight D7 business no he won King h8
instead of Queen takes D3 uh yes that
was what two days ago I want to say
yesterday oh yes it was actually
yesterday yeah and it's just uh this
moment where King h8
no after my B6 H3 page five Bishop B3 I
think Knight B6 Bishop B H3 Bishop H5
Bishop B3 and this is where King h8 was
played by Shaq and then it got 94.97 93
takes takes a five brings us back to the
uh
game of yesterday yeah but uh Jan
clearly is had something there yeah
probably not exactly the same as he
played against uh uh again shock because
despite the fact that he was clearly
winning at one point I don't think he
had any uh Advantage out of the opening
but yeah the daily one goes for a much
more uh
solid way of playing I think 95
surprises me a little bit but I don't
know enough about this position to be
you know very confident in my in my
opinions but I think uh uh Hikaru played
Queen C8 here against me in an online
tournament last year and queen CA it's a
logical move because you do want to play
Rook f8 here you want to you want to
prepare and play Rook f8 and it gets
kind of awkward for white and uh I
misplayed uh the opening in that game
quite badly and and lost but 95 I mean
it's a logical move you want 95 94 it's
a very understandable idea but Alejandro
if you could just jump right in and tell
us what what what's the latest and
greatest in the in this opening line
well still following a game we have this
position after the trade of Queens
between vacherala Graf playing in this
tournament with the white pieces against
Dimitri jacovenko from a couple years
ago mvl won that game as well this was
from 2019. the game followed Bishop B6
which I think is what aronian is trying
to figure out what to put this bishop
either on E7 a little bit more passive
but securing the king side or on B6
where you do have to deal with some
night jump specifically this Knight on
H4 is what the engine is saying might be
a little bit annoying because this
bishop will get caught down the line now
it is an engine move it's weird to put
the Knight out of the side of the board
when you still have other pieces to
develop the edges are saying it still
might be a little bit of a pull I'm not
sure it might also be equalized
perfectly the game between jacovenko and
mvl or rather mvl against America win
with the more natural move Bishop G5 but
unfortunately F6 is a perfectly good
answer because since the bishop has the
F7 Square in this variation it was
pushed away with the move H3 we've
talked about the subtlety of the H3 move
in many different positions uh in this
one in particular the bishop is much
more comfortable on F7 than it would be
on E6 because of all the night jumps and
here after Rook ad1 which will allow
takes and take on C6 or take on G5 you
have Rook 81 Bishop F7 and black is
doing perfectly I I don't remember that
game I was watching it with great
interest because this is uh the the
Hunty World Cup right now 2019 and I
think the the kind of a tragic thing
about this game for of what Dmitry was I
think he actually won the previous one
and that was during the rapid tie breaks
and I think I was playing the winner of
that match so I was yeah not an entirely
disinterest disinterested party there
right uh and uh
Michigan was completely fine in that
game and then at some point MBL I think
left the pawn on A2 on previews and it
could have been taken and wasn't taken
and uh Dimitri ended up losing and then
losing the entire match and then mvl of
course knocked my head in
so yeah that wasn't that wasn't very
good for me but I mean they had their
own games to play they didn't have to
concern themselves with my feelings too
much right but yeah I I remember that
game now uh after Bishop G5 F6 black is
just completely and utterly fine there
is not a single problem but uh
conversely the move Knight H4 uh
computer engine or not does leave some
issues for black still to solve on that
clearly clearly I mean probably is a
supposed improvement with the idea of G4
I wonder why it's f64 I guess right on
C5 to discover check maybe something
like that yes that would make sense I
seem to recall maybe it was actually
here at a singfield cup or something
where somebody had played this kind of
wonderful moment where C4 kicks the
night away the Knight has to move and
then C5 would win the game and it was
missed it was that was that was not here
and the position there was a bit more
intricate because this is difficult to
blunder what was one it's a very famous
game between Iranian and karakian and
bike and bike yeah but that there was a
bishop only six there and the point was
that C4 followed by C5 attacks the
bishop on E6 uh and the Knight did not
have squares to protect the I think I
can reconstruct it to a degree but we
don't we don't really need to bother but
yeah that is that's a very famous game
because Sergey actually did not play C4
which was winning a piece in two moves
and went on to win the game anyway so
you know nothing of value was lost right
at night and by the way
instead of the I say would say
prescribed Bishop E7 uh that theory has
Bishop Bishop yeah uh by Theory Bishop
E7 novel novelty according to varusian
in the truck and if novelty or not yeah
young continues playing I know this move
I know this move and what is it uh uh
Alejandro is I mean these moves are
coming liquidy split well for young they
are levonne is the one taking a little
bit of time right about the move Bishop
B7 I Rook D1 never seen before this move
Bishop E7 but clearly John knows what
he's doing the engines thinking that
well the horse is hit move the horse
Knight V6 is one but there's another
interesting idea in this position to
play the move Bishop G6 yeah and counter
asks white how are you going to defend
your knight I don't care about my knight
just yet because if you take on D5
either with the Rook well with the Rook
number division if you think with the
rook and I think on e4 uh I mean clearly
White's not better so you have to be a
little bit more clever than this you
will have to move the Knight out of E4
away from the center to G3 but it's
quite really better here you get Knight
B6 the Knight does have to move it is a
bit awkward which before the whole point
yeah this is the whole point that you go
Bishop F4 you ask
you ask a question how do you defend C7
and it seems like a very simple question
but perhaps it doesn't have like a very
comfortable answer right even if the
engine and it doesn't but the even in
variations where the engine says Rook C8
right depends upon and you're equal
sometimes it's hard to make that move
right it's just to willingly take a
passive yeah yeah because it's it's
specifically the combination of a very
passive Rook on C8 and this stupid ish
Bishop on G6 which could at some in some
cases maybe even further push back by H4
H5 ideas
um yeah it doesn't it doesn't feel like
yeah 95 95 is a very important thing I
got my own tickle I hear Peter yeah but
how happy are you about let's say H4
Knight A5 h593 HG
I think I retained some pool there
actually
I was hoping that HG Knight C5 I take on
F7 I've taken my no no no no I want I
want this position it's not much but it
feels like maybe like a knight E5 Knight
F5 if I start some jumps you you get the
feeling that the engine will equalize
equalize it eventually but it seems
precisely yeah it feels like yeah it's
not completely empty just yet for white
and uh quite the uh Donnie Brook between
these two players uh they kind of fought
themselves to an even still doesn't feel
like the correct amount of games right
every time I see you guys three three
seven yeah every time I see Jan up there
I'm like
for the first time in 2004. so I mean
some kids term I never fought open yeah
very well known kids
Juniors Juniors did you get your Norm I
got my six number there yeah wow okay
and what happened it was a it was a
night it was a fighting draw but
um I I just feel like he's been playing
forever right how do you only have 10
games against lebronian like one of the
best players of all time if you're
playing been playing at the elite for so
long for so long and to me it's always
been a mystery Jan doesn't have as many
games so for example when I say ferruges
head to heads I'm like yeah okay the
guy's a kid hasn't played any other
people yeah one zero zero one maybe two
three games at the top but Giannis be
honest what 30 years old yeah yeah he's
been around the block for a while I mean
he's been playing as you said on one of
the previous broadcasts yeah he he was
sidetracked we we all knew he was an
extremely talented talented player but
uh it feels like some kind of a
watershed moment happened maybe three
four years back where he scaled down
very significantly on his
extracurriculars and started working on
chess much more and the results
immediately flowed because as we I mean
there was never any doubt whatsoever
that he this is one of the really great
yeah greater talents of his generation
but he he was living a full life you
know he he played other game or
something I can very much relate to and
was good at them as well as opposed to
myself he was he was very good at them
but now yeah all of that I mean he you
know I I still occasionally see the
login but yeah not not nowhere near to
the extent of the the previous years and
uh yeah another six interestingly being
met by Bishop Knight takes F6 and I
assume the intention is to play Push
before here
with or without Jeeps
ah the engine already hates this I don't
know why
hates it for well obviously for a black
yeah yeah
so so we go take stakes g4bish from six
[ __ ] before and we claim a reason he
goes immediately he doesn't take on yeah
G4 is the top engine move yeah I mean
you've whether you include Rook D1 or
because I think the Rook on C8 is just
the combination of The Rook on C8 and
the Knight on C6 I think is just very
very unfortunate so I I assume the idea
is no you have to take on G1 you want to
take on D1 immediately prior to the Rook
uh the landing on the connecting yeah
okay so take Stakes you you will have to
play Bishop B6 so let's play it now yeah
before you're probably forced to play
Rook C8 here okay yeah the question is
why is this so horrible with uh sort of
the wish before coming in potentially
next move I'm it's it's it's G5
I was about to say is there something
with the directions
foreign
and yeah we get a lot of pressure in
there
so G4 will go somewhere we attack the
bishop only four next move yeah black is
being very much kind of manhandled yeah
yeah pushed around not the five coming
in yeah this is this is not going to be
fun for yeah no no no no but I got black
got pushed around pretty darn good in
that whole sequence
um
yeah the computer's line is actually
Rook takes on D1 Bishop takes D1 Bishop
G6
yeah oops sorry uh erect yes the the
line that we had originally yep
and now here the night before move that
cheese have you finite before
boss chair well boss chair yeah if
anyone will let's live on but but what a
move right yeah and and the point is you
have to assess that the same game of wp5
here or Rook C1 I don't know which one
you prefer probably Rook C1 actually
it's kind of tidier right yeah
to correctly assess that this is the
best you have now
because this is not yeah it doesn't look
fun right yeah this is not fun at all no
very anti-fun actually for black if you
give white no but we go I think the
point here at least one of the points is
that we play Rook d8 and if you play
Bishop B3 I think black is actually in
time to play [ __ ] before Bishop D5
and if if the bishop on G6 gets traded
for the bishop on B3 yeah yeah yeah I
understand what you're saying if you can
get it it becomes manageable yes it
doesn't become good but it becomes
manageable right exactly I don't know I
go Rook D6 here or something probably
you're just fine and then Bishop D5 next
move yeah and yeah you save those end
games but yeah the the amount of uh sort
of foresight and the amount like your
your autopilot needs to be kind of
switched up there because it is just so
easy to to just play Rook C8 because why
why do you even need to calculate things
like you use a symmetrical position you
know three against three on the king
side three against three on the queen
side let's just make the move that
protects the pawn and C7 and go from
there and this is a far more uh basic uh
two pieces two miners versus three and
three and three and two yeah uh your
evaluation Peter White's having the fun
I think this particular one is like very
very close to a draw very close to it I
mean it is white who will be pushing but
I don't think I don't think you lose
very many at the highest levels because
you just kind of start swapping down on
the queen side and even if it does
result in you losing your three for the
two eventually
bishop and Knight and three dogs don't
actually win against the rookie three uh
this is not the two Bishops that we're
discussing earlier and this is why it is
so crucial to get the Bushman six traded
for the bishopon D1 quite the
extraordinary move if it requires a
night before and any one of you who
would like to join our conversation
asking uh asking any person on our panel
or even in Bucharest what they think
about something you can do it yeah uh
you can tweeted us using the hashtag
grandchild store or tagging the account
at grandchester and yeah we're we're
very always very very happy to hear from
our viewers absolutely uh
checking in on the farugia game again a
game that I consider the Marquee matchup
of the round and still still obviously
all Theory though tanking here not for
very long but he's already spent like
half an hour whereas Wesley obviously is
just strolling around he doesn't have to
he's still in the board that's no great
chess culture the great game
varujanakovian against Elias mirin oh my
god oh yes that uh your your Classics
yes sorry Classics you must know your
Classics what happened of course it was
a draw what do you mean
painstakingly difficult draw yes yes yes
uh explain the position to our viewers
uh Alejandro black has this expansion on
the queen side but you see his sponsor
getting hit the bottom D5 is attacking
C6 the bottom A4 is pressuring B5 you
need a good way of solving your problems
for example say C takes D4 just blunders
everything because Bishop takes D4
starts hitting your Rook starts hitting
your Pawn it's not a good solution to
your problems if you play B4 you start
leaving a lot of squares around here
unprotected Rook C1 starts pressuring
the pawn you start feeling the fact that
you're undeveloped on the queen side and
white just gets an easy Advantage
surprise that is plus 2.5 but you can
start understanding that Black's not
doing very well there Pawn takes A4 is
uh not bad really yeah you can actually
do this wow the idea is that after Rook
takes uh you don't want to think with
the bishop because sometimes D5 will uh
you'll be forced to retake with opponent
it's not what you want to do and the
point for black is that after Rook takes
you have to move 97 or Bishop D7 and
both of them embarrass this Rook on A4
Bishop design because it attacks it semi
directly as he takes D5 as an issue and
Knight D7 is preparing the move Knight
B6 again with the pressure on this
bundle may be wondering what happens if
you take well Knight C5 is a nice
tactical idea you attack both the bishop
and the rook and remember that E4 is
also hanging the pawn on C6 is not
really going anywhere so vtext is
actually a way of solving the issues but
most people here don't choose the
actually most people take on A4 sorry
but uh Bishop B7 and Bishop D7 just
holding the structure keeping the
tension on the position is also possible
so alireza has more than one way to
equalize this position doesn't really
have a way to keep the game going that
far if Wesley decides okay it's time to
pull the plug and just go to an equal
line game
it's just not a position where Wesley
really wants to uh you know take a lot
of risks and you can see why right there
right Wesley so very important game he's
it's a very important game he's in the
lead with four and a half nobody's told
him that Levon is under pressure but I'm
sure that he's gonna walk at some point
be like all right then nepo's blitzing
out every move doesn't look so easy for
the other play with four and a half so
you know a very solid Wesley type of
approach to a tournament he gets an
early plus too and then that was the end
of his risks yeah and he goes home after
it a game we've more or less lost sight
of uh for a moment here Peter is between
mvl and um Daniel yeah this was the very
topical sharp if you will if I can use
your term uh Petrov defense when we left
it we left it at this very somewhere
around here yeah 3.7 is a very important
little position and uh there's a number
of things here that have been tried uh
very very uh E3 hp3 is uh much lesser
known move I think that we only have the
one game that Peter leko played there
against viciana so I mean very strong
players have debated it but the main
move in this position by far is the
movement Knight C3 which is which has uh
you know tons and tons of theory it has
been played in the world championship
match between Magnus uh Magnus and uh
Jan last year and plenty of theory
around around this idea and there's also
a fresher idea I think which was
ventured forth recently with the move C4
C5 which looks counter-intuitive but
leads to very very sharp positions and
uh this is what I was kind of expecting
in an end or hope hoping to see but they
did not really foreign
but very heavily incentivized in this
position to gobish B6
uh once again continuing to use tactics
to preserve the structure why it goes
let's say queen C two blood goes at five
wow and yeah and this is this decision
yeah and this is just such a sharp such
sharp and clear position to uh to look
at and yeah I was I was kind of hoping
this happens because this is a brawl
this is yeah yeah no question about it
this is exactly what we want for for a
round eight game but we didn't get it
yeah and we all went went a different
way he published B3 as I mentioned uh
kind of a rare move but not unheard of
DC4 Bishop C4 is still following the uh
leko Anand game and Knight E6 appears to
be uh a novelty or at least a deviation
from that uh important stem game it's a
move they make quite a bit in this
position of course yeah
and uh let's go I mean yeah you're
clearly not worried about Bishop takes
A6 because yeah that's an important
Bishop it also gives your Rooks the B
file with the green mb3 which is very
awkward like immediately you start maybe
liking black maybe even in this position
I do I do
and by the way even though uh it looks
to my eyes very natural Knight A6 is
apparently a novelty Bishop 3 is just a
very a very rare line so it's it's not
difficult to to deviate from the one
game and uh I we interrupt our usual
programming to show you the one around
you're just blitzing out night before in
that position
oh nice nice night before just just no
issue yeah I do not want to play Passive
positions there I am going to make the
the best wow and and young kind of Gog
yeah yeah it seems like maybe maybe
Young's file said Bishop F4 plus equals
and did not go further because he looks
a bit
it's done uh yeah
that's not the that's not the face of
Amanda tonight yeah cause like if if you
know this exists you're annoyed that
your opponent found it but I think you
look slightly different yeah I don't
think I don't think this is how you look
if you know this exists right uh he's
not going to be that that worried
because I mean he still is a bit better
but and again just uh for our audience
anybody who came in a little bit late if
you thought that white would like to
have provoked the move Rook C8 defending
the pawn because after G5 it just
happens
Knight H4 that black is getting bullied
after the move uh the upcoming move
Bishop G4 and the move Knight B5 just
kind of Pardon Me Knight B4 just crosses
up these plans by white first of all uh
Knight D5 is a nice way of defending the
pawn on C7 as well as Knight D3 you hit
the bishop and you counter attack the
pawn on B2
we had looked at this line Peter where
we where we get the two pieces yeah
white has a choice of having this bishop
on C1 or A1 as well like I don't know if
maybe having it on A1 is a bit better
I could construct an argument for why uh
it's better off on the long diagonal hp5
forces Bishop takes A1 anyway we take
and if you go Rook d8 here
I'm trying to figure out if you can
actually play Knight D4 because I would
very much like to prevent the bishop on
on B1 being challenged by the bishop on
G6 and that was a another point that you
made earlier that is
and importantly wherever the dark Square
Bishop is in this position Bishop takes
F7 just loses it right this is kind of
the Tactical underpinning of this idea
Bishop b3ps before Bishop 7 we can just
take on F7 go with the King to any
square and then go Rook debunk check and
pick up pick up the other one
um so that doesn't work at all for white
and if if you don't have that tactical
idea of the Bush before uh I get to play
Bishop D5 next move probably very likely
trade those those Bishops you got me
excited Knight D5 because that way as
you're saying white would like to
preserve the two Bishops I mean and by
cutting out this bishop E4 Bishop D5
ideas I mean it can still be placed on
D5 but if it doesn't if it doesn't trade
the bishop on D1 I am immediately a lot
more optimistic about uh potential
winning yeah some some kind of position
like this I can I can very easily see
why it actually prevailing in a long
long struggle because the bishop pair is
still on the board exactly you can play
Bishops this is just such a such a
better version for for white which all
begs the question that even if we give
Levon the the the full accounting of uh
the credit and we say that he actually
came to the game prepared to play night
before he couldn't he could find himself
in a difficult ending yeah he's still
he's still going to uh going to defend a
somewhat unpleasant ending but
yeah and you have to you have to
question uh whether you know 115 is such
an inconclusive clock showing there for
live on right right because you could
have you could have this amount of time
on your clock by move 20 in this line
because you just spend some time
remembering what the file says or he
could have he could have a reasonably
good day where he's thinking clearly and
he just goes night before because he
realizes the other position is annoying
I've got an idea for black in this
position after Rook d89 to D4 a move
that I didn't spot originally Bishop C3
is okay though right
of course it is I think A5 is
interesting I think uh after 94 it
definitely makes sense for black to try
A5 exactly A5 and if I play B5 you can
maybe go C5
um
yeah and c65 continues being an annoying
annoying little threat very much yeah
and like I can't play Bishop F3 C5 at
night somewhere but maybe you have jumps
here drop it home yeah Rook D2 here once
again like if if we end up winning the
polony too it's very likely that we
don't lose correct regardless of how
many how many of our own uh pawns we
almost regardless of how many of our own
points on the queen side right right
yeah wow okay something definitely uh to
keep in mind and just before we kind of
prepare ourselves for a break let's see
what happened in the Richie game uh
Richie is not not a died in the world
groom fell I was going to say yeah
doesn't doesn't subscribe to my grinfeld
Follies and foil he definitely needs to
get the course maybe we can expedite him
a a key yes so that he can spend uh yeah
a nice evening and or or oh no
[Laughter]
but uh let's jump over to Bucharest and
see what uh Anastasia and Christian have
to share
thank you uh Yasser actually you guys
were talking about that game between
Fabiano and Richie what striked me as
odd at the beginning of the game is
actually that Richie spent almost a
minute on his first move and some of the
organizers were actually asking me
whether that's natural or it just
happens every now and then that was a
very interesting moment now we see that
Richie actually has an hour and 33
minutes on his clock in Fabiano caruana
burning a lot of time right now under
one hour so that game is definitely one
to have our eyes on but today is Friday
the 13th and you guys were saying this
is a spooky Friday the 13th so let's
talk about superstitions and Anastasia
tell us a bit about superstitions and
how it impacts chess players yeah
actually many players they say they're
not superstitious at all but I think
they are and they're not really telling
us all the truth and I know there are
some things which we can under extended
they're superstitious for example they
don't change clothes and they use the
same you know pen for example or they
don't shave we know we know many many
small details right I think this uh the
number 13s is really favorite number of
Gary Kasparov who was the 13th Soul
champion who was born 13th of April so
some people actually can think that
Friday 13th is a great day for them so
what about you Christian are you
superstitious person or not I I try not
to be I see it as a weakness I do have
two black cats so I don't really believe
in this type of things nevertheless at
the same time when I do uh play chess I
do have a couple of superstitions one of
them actually and I've been seeing that
with live in this tournament at least
he's being late to every single round
and I generally like to be late as well
let my opponent stay there for the first
couple of minutes without an opponent so
that's quite an interesting one depends
in is always a chess player's
Superstition I have a feeling also a
route to the chess playing uh Zone how
about yourself Anastasia do you have any
big superstitions yeah just with sure
that when we're late for the game there
is no Zero Tolerance rules right that's
it can be a problem sometimes I I can
also recall one interest in the story
which happened in The Cutting Board
probably remember there was this
candidates tournament and it was divided
for two parts and after one year of
break because of covet players came back
to the same plane Wade and they had to
use the same chairs so actually what
happened is that some of them decided to
change the chairs you know they had like
seven chairs different shares and by the
way half of those people are playing
here in this event and just try to guess
who didn't change the chair after after
let's say one year
um
that is a very good question should I go
with Fabiano no it was actually Fabiano
has changed but you know those who were
leading I give you
some Nepal Nepal even when the vaccine
that didn't change your right absolutely
I mean they didn't change the chairs and
even though I asked them later if it was
because of superstitious no they said no
we just didn't pay attention but we all
know that actually it can be one of the
signs that they're also superstitious
people so I wonder what about Peter
Yasser and Alejandro are they are
superstitious the last guy is in the
studio okay well I'll just say that
Bobby Bobby was particular about his
chair but especially the lighting he
really wanted no Dark Shadows whatsoever
on the board and unfortunately I've
played in a lot of tournaments and then
featured a lot of superstitions I want
to stick up for for us chess players a
little yes and say that uh you know that
throwaway remark about not changing
clothes I understand it very much plays
into the stereotypes and over Thai or
whatever no no no
specifically that stereotype but yeah
you know some of us actually do change
color every now and then and I would
like to to you to to have it stated on
the record right you know the uh but
yeah I think uh Sports people in general
uh I don't know if they're like
full-blown full-blown superstitions but
yeah you do get slightly attached to
routines it's more a thing to do with
routines uh you feel that whatever
worked for you in the past will continue
working it's like it's your comfort zone
you don't want to uh to to change up too
many things and uh yeah for me
I I think I'm sort of as light on this
as possible but I do
like I never wear the same shirt two
days running
uh but there is so sort of a certain
ordering for shirts like I think you
know there are all these like small
stupid foibles that you you develop over
the course of your career but uh yeah
they don't really come to you know the
the full like you you hear stories about
people I don't know not stepping on
certain things on the pavement and you
get you get those extreme cases never
was the case with me but I definitely
have some some habits and some things
that I will likely be repeating during
the tournament Alejandro superstitions I
think that all chess players if you ask
them some of them will admit that
they're superstitious but they all are
some just don't admit it right uh for
example in the 2018 World Chess
Championship between Favi and Magnus uh
if you ask Fabi if he's superstitious
he'll heart say no not at all uh he just
likes routines they just happen to be
routines but let's say that he ate at
Nando's Chicken every single day of the
match in order the exact same thing
except before rapid time breaks and we
know how that went
wow it worked for for uh 14 rounds but
not for the 15th very nice black
Fernandez there yeah yeah oh I expect my
sponsorship too I did like their sauce
one one thing uh like as a commentator
wearing a dark suit or a dark jacket
I've got no problems with but when I was
playing at the board I actually like
light clothes I mean I didn't want to
feel heavy or you know pressed in kind
of thing
but otherwise no no I didn't really have
uh too many superstitions but if you
lost with a pen would you use it again
if it was a really nice pen yeah okay
yeah I wouldn't I would not touch that
like that that's gotta go yeah that like
I can sort of relate to that even though
yeah I've never really I've I've never
really been a proper pen person but then
I I got gifted a good pen and yeah that
pen stayed dependent regardless
regardless of the result yeah by the way
uh cross pens were my favorite because
they were silent like sometimes you have
these fountain pens that make a click
yeah no no no I like the the silent are
you the the well you don't you use those
those pens with uh with the covering
because like I noticed
are one of our players in this
tournament and he's constantly playing
an increment right but when you when you
play in tournaments with increment you
are supposed to continue noting down the
moves because you have your 30 seconds
between moves yeah so you're you're
obliged by by the laws of Chess yeah to
to continue writing down moves and I
noticed that even in time travel he goes
through the routine of writing down the
move and then covering the pen and then
uncovering the pen to write down the
next move which is like two seconds
exactly but but you have those like
those are the things that you do that
you do and you don't change them even
for you know extreme situations where
you know Common Sense should dictate
that you know the value of an additional
bit of time to think about you move is
more important than you know sticking to
exactly how you treat your pen for those
five minutes but no by the way and uh
the game of Lavon the one that you've
got on your screen we have seen captures
on B4 captures on the B2 yeah this is
the best way to play for white in the
engine loved white and then starts
thinking you know what this is not so
easy of course Rook C1 is playable the
engine thinking that's just an equal
ending why because after whoops not this
way Rook C1 takes takes this is the more
Awkward way to do it because after Rook
d8 it's not so easy to hide this bishop
in with the bishop on A1 we have this
move Knight D4 without the move Knight
D4 this bishop it kind of gets trapped
you can see that I can start harassing
it with the move Bishop D5 and you might
be wondering what so what this is just a
trade of Bishops not quite so this is
the pair of Bishops for white and that's
their main advantage a bishop and a
knight on an open board when The Rook
has an extra pawn it is better for the
bishop and the Knight but it's not that
much better I mean The Rook isn't an
open board and it is a very powerful
piece the Knight doesn't have a good
anchor square or anything to attack for
the moment woman so the address
evaluating it as close to equal in this
position and meanwhile in the game
between uh Wesley so and alireza we did
see a bunch of Trades uh the move Pawn
takes A4 was essay that's uh was one of
the predictions Bishop takes Bishop D7 I
was mentioned the move 97 against Rook
takes A4 but since you took with the
bishop you're not preparing yourself to
take on D5 you could have taken on you
cannot take on D5 the previous move
because of Bishop takes E8 of course so
D takes was played Bishop takes King E2
Bishop takes Rook takes this has
actually been seen before in chess twice
black
it's very very close to full equality
still has a couple of moves to make
because you know the bishop on G7 is not
in the correct Square this Rook is
coming to a one but he's getting there
the most precise move is of course
Knight D7 since it has the threat of
Knight C5 not a huge threat but it does
move your Rook away from the pressure of
the A5 Square so the best move would be
rookie C1 and we finally get our own
counter in with the move rokib8 again I
expect this game to go towards a draw
don't think that there's going to be any
major updates here and this one I'm very
curious about
because Richard is blitzed out to this
position right and I'm not entirely sure
what's going on does he I know did he
analyze the end game to full extent
because this starts to feel very
unpleasant to me he's played the move
Bishop E7 and they just are saying yeah
he's fine he's fine he's fine it's only
plus 0.4 okay so check you have to take
otherwise and then I take this way and
the whole point is that you haven't
castled so you cannot challenge me on
the C file just yet yeah I just want to
Castle okay I'll play Rook C5 and
everything I know about Chess is the
blackest on the verge of collapse right
you have the only open file you have
more space you can sacrifice on D5 if
need to this Bishop's actually already
targeting the pawns perfectly
um why is this not lost for black
well the 925 currently controls the C7
Square very importantly
and some counter play with F6 after xc5
opening up the f file is about to start
happening yeah my biggest worry here
would be some kind of a sequence
involving the sacrifice on D5 but I'm
not sure if white is uh entirely
equipped to do it just yet but yeah it
looks it looks a very move by move
position like it might be okay but if
you're okay it's because uh you play
very very precisely for the next five or
ten moves because yeah you give white
one tempo somewhere to to achieve their
objectives and you're just going to be
close to to that loss yeah the other
thing I'm worried about is it took seven
minutes on Bishop E7 which I'm hoping he
was just remembering his prep but you
said Peter right it's very Booth my move
right like one misstep by black you're
under so much pressure you're not going
to survive right so you have to make
sure that you get your F6 move in that
you get some way of countering uh even
the move before is debatable you might
have to play F6 immediately the engines
are still not sure whether B4 or F6
there's a better move against Rook C5 so
yeah
wow and uh for Fabi this game couldn't
be more crucial guys uh he's a three and
a half after seven he needs he needs a
win in getting himself I mean he's close
to the podium you you could say that you
know strong as this tournament is uh
Madrid steel is sort of at the Forefront
of all of our cabinets minds and it's
not life and death if I be here to to
you know finish finish in the top three
but of course he is a very proud proud
of all all professional chess players
are you know take pride in their work
and would like to challenge for the top
places and yeah it's always nice for
these players to wash off a bad
tournament from the previous years I
know they always carry this tournament
from the last year a little bit when
they return yeah and he had an atrocious
uh Bucharest last year right I mean he
lost his shock with the white Pieces
Just horribly he lost to Wesley with the
white pieces as well uh he had a winning
position against him VL didn't convert I
think he ended up on minus one or minus
two and he makes a move we did not
discuss at all he went 1943 there after
some thought which is geological yeah
because 95 is clearly Black's best best
piece on yeah I I also think this puts a
lot of pressure on
on Black's position right yeah so we
take with the rook and we start
challenging the Queen's side and uh yeah
none of this is easy I'm even wondering
if maybe Knight C7 is bad that's where
I'm going to that maybe uh but then we
can maybe go A4 before Knight B5 and
claim that we've improved the position
of the night you know let's say
the Knight went from E4 to B5 I was
wondering if maybe on B5 if it supports
C5 C6 better but I don't think it does I
can still take and go King G7 and not
nothing much has changed which explains
the incredibly weird uh two-step that
the computer does that's Place Knight D5
95.95
sorry it might be 5.95 yeah
and then Rook C4 waits for you to Castle
and then goes and then go C6 nice yeah
because I do like the idea of playing C6
it's a kind of a a bit of an inside joke
with me and Sasha I I that we always
chuckle about this because in these like
French type structures uh when we get
the position with the pawn and E5 and
white having a c Pawn against the G5
Pawn in every single of those positions
I immediately start preparing C4 and
Sasha analyzed them with me enough that
basically we just look at each other and
start kind of kind of giggling because I
I am incapable of not trying to open the
C file so I'm also trying to open the C
file here right but it does make some
sense because we're looking on G8 it
will be very difficult to challenge why
it's complete dominance over the one
open open file on the board and A5 might
become quite weak eventually well
especially I like that that the darks
were pardon me on the queen side the
blacks Queen side is on dark squares
which indicates to me that if I could
ever get a bishop ending you know as
white I be the one having the fun I
would Target The Pawn on A5 I like this
prop
for Richard Richard yeah I don't I feel
he's gonna have some this is not even
his type of position where it's fun it's
exciting going on yeah it just feels
like he's going to sit down and defend
the war sign game yeah for the remaining
for sometimes six hours right yeah yeah
that I mean the Silver Lining here is
that it's a feed of time control so it's
not going to be six hours but
but also maybe this is a good uh prep
for for his uh candidacy to get rid of
this variation for the candle
yeah they're done with this variations
as we prepare for a Break
um we have ours usual our daily special
it is a very nice uh nice uh item today
we're showing you a traditional Stanton
style metal chest man on a seven inch uh
wooden Alabaster board a unique uh
octagonal board features a pull out
drawer as you can see there on your
screen for for the Jasmine to go in and
it's uh handcrafted in Italy and
available as always at cubicstl.com very
very nice looking uh looking piece not
something you will be using on digital
daily to analyze your your prep for the
day but it is a
yeah and it's a very ornament manifold
yeah but it's a it's a very very nice uh
nice set piece for
uh you know to occupy pride of place in
your exactly your study
um as we go on break uh Anastasia had a
very special guest She interviewed a
grand master Florin
of Romania is a great during my time he
and I uh had a lot of battles together
all over the world and he was the first
Romanian Grandma I don't believe I've
ever met him but I've read about him at
a time and you know Legend looks through
his games a great deal when I was a kid
yeah
enjoy we'll see you on the other side of
the bridge
[Music]
here we are with Florin Georgio the
first Romanian Grandmaster the legend of
Romanian chess how are you doing here
welcome to the crunches tour
well I was looking you know some of the
games they are very interesting it's a
manner for us to organize such a
tournament in Bucharest again and we
hope that the best player will win
finally you know as always well the the
games are very interesting until now and
each day was full of surprises and we'll
see what happens in the last three
rounds but until now so is doing very
well and they're on Yan also and it's
very difficult to change something only
in two days in the last two days but
we'll see another you know you never
know who am I rooting for in this event
well
my favorite was
Fabiano before the game but right now I
I can't say that he has the best chances
to win
it depends you know luck in the sermon
and so on you know yes only one Romanian
player Bogdan deck what do you think
about him and his career so far very
well he's very young I want only 20
years and until now he was doing a very
old unfortunately he lost yesterday a
very unclear position
and it depends again what happens in the
last three games if he plays well
everything can happen as I told you
chassis like that you know it's very
even until the end we'll see in our time
was the same and this time when you know
that I uh I can tell you a little about
this because a long time ago I was three
times American champion I won three
times the American Championship the U.S
championship and this time the game was
a little bit different because the
computer was not there and it was nicer
I can say because we you could produce
something you couldn't you could show
something right now it's very difficult
the machine is doing everything and the
difference is too big you know the
machine is better right now you started
to say about your participation in many
international events you've played and
I'm sure that you have told a lot about
it in your books right can you tell
about it a little bit well these three
books are about my career and my life of
course this is the the title also you
know is Art in chess and life you know
the title of these books and it's about
the periods for 40 years starting in
1960 until 2010 it was my best period I
was in the last in the first 10 in the
world in this period and in one moment
after the third title in U.S
I reached the third place in the world
so there's a good period let's say yes
and the tournaments in the United States
were also excellent very well organized
I have very good memories from this time
I I played for about 25 years in the
United States so
you know we are good friends let's see
yes sure and looking forward to see more
to see more about those books very very
good and very interesting but we hope in
the maybe in the next two three months
they'll be translated most probably also
in English and it would be easier for
everybody like yes it's great news
actually
well we present here the best players
who know the nine world champion I have
uh I had the opportunity to to play
against nine world champions starting
with both winning until kramnik you know
all of them casparov and karpov and so
on finally we have a lot of photos here
inside with casparov and the last photo
from the third book he's with him with
uh with Gary so most probably when we
see each other again I'll give him these
books also and I hope he'll appreciate
this yeah great news and actually we
have Yasser saravan and Petersfield in
the studio maybe you would like to say
something to Yasser Jason is a very good
friend we didn't see each other for a
very long time so what can I say
Greetings yes
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to our coverage of round
eight with an ultimate round of the
Bucharest chess classic and these are
the current standings prior to the start
of the game around today with no game
with all games underway and the prize
money is such that these games can
become very valuable I mean the fight
for first and second first yeah and here
we can go more into the you know chess
players and their habits and the way
they approach things uh I always and
this is something that I think is you
know not just because this is how I'm
doing things but I think it legitimately
is the right way to go about things but
uh it always felt to me that
it's difficult not to know what the
price fund is but I think Midway round
date is not the time to ever consider
what what the game potentially will cost
you or earn you and like how much the
difference between plus one and plus two
is uh those calculations are ideally
left after the tournament is finished
altogether and I think uh
just mistakes though when people don't
know what's at stake for their uh for
their game like the world rapid Blitz
championship last year I think was a
very clear one Bobby in the last round
is playing I actually forgot who he's
playing makes a drawing like 10 moves
and says yeah that one was a weird one
yeah yeah and I asked him about it like
well why would you do that what happened
is that he tied for a certain position
and there was a playoff going to happen
uh for the winner of the tournament and
he thought he was in the playoff because
he had the same amount of points but
very clearly it stated that only the top
two by mathematical tie breaks get to
play on the playoff and he was nowhere
near on tie breaks uh and he just like
he pretty much blundered a tournament
away right he could have at least tried
so I have seen some egregious mistakes
when people don't know what's going on
and then they're like surprised like
that the tournament didn't go their way
right oops Yeah you absolutely need to
be aware of you know the the but it's
more really about what you're talking
about is not sort of the money money uh
EV value of your moves it's more sort of
knowing where you stand in uh in
tournament situations in particular in
large swisses where it's much less
clear-cut you know a Templar around
Robin will have a much more you know
stable and much more clear position uh
position to look at but specifically you
know trying trying to you know count
count money before before you the
tournament is finished I think is
counterproductive to to a very large
degree and I mean when it comes to tour
standings of course you need to be aware
like let's say we come to the singfield
cup and there is as we all know a very
nice additional purse for for the
winners of the tour and let's say it's a
close race because previous year it
didn't really seem like it was such a
close race wrestling you to the solid
thing Phil carpent uh he was having a
very solid single cup so everybody else
kind of knew that the top the top prizes
may be gone but if it's a close straight
of course before the last couple of
rounds you do need to make some
calculations along the lines of what
Alejandro just described yeah and here
you have on your screen this is the
price one for for the tour we get 350 uh
for the classical tournaments the one
we're watching right now and then the
single cup in September and 175 for the
three rapid events uh uh sandwich
between those two classical tournaments
plus the uh bonus uh bonus payments for
the tour winners there are three prizes
for the best results in the tour overall
with 100 up top 50 and 25 for second and
third so yeah those calculations
definitely come into play towards the
end of the tour but I think it's more
about let's say the the the GCT
standings because in the tournament you
just want to play every game as well as
possible
in round Robins I think the equation is
pretty much always going to be very
simple winning is better than drawing
drawing is better than losing having
more points is better than having fewer
yeah uh and and then when it all when it
all ends you you figure out what you
earned yeah uh for me it was always uh
something I was very close with Ben
Larson I had a lot of dinners with him
and he he really berated me uh very
harshly
um I was an I am
I was trying to be getting my GM norms
and stuff like that and he said oh yes
or stop with this stop with that that
that's not what chess is about I said I
beg your pardon I want to get my
Grandmaster title he says no no no stop
doing that what you should concentrated
on is winning tournaments
winning tournaments that's the most
important thing you know like you've got
to put yourself in a position that you
can win first and when you are in the
position to win first then you just
devote your entire life's being to
winning that event and that was very
very powerful it didn't stick until I
became a grand master by the way but
once I became a grand master it was all
about winning that is a very very good
mindset to have yes it's uh it's
something I perhaps have struggled a bit
over the years because yeah I've always
kind of Taken I wouldn't say I've taken
chess slightly but I have always had
this kind of a mantra that you know I
want to play better than I played
yesterday I want to you know continue
improving as a player and step by step
yeah and because this kind of a you know
gradual Improvement idea I mean I have
won some things in my life you have but
but I I don't think I've I've ever you
know articulated this to myself as
clearly as you are as you're describing
and I wish I had maybe right I mean he
really pounded it into my I want to say
a thick skull and it worked it worked
and I mean I always felt that for
example especially where U.S
championships were concerned I really
you know if I got myself into a position
that I had a a chance then I devoted
myself like not even thinking about
prize money and stuff like that but it
was but for These Guys these guys are
such a lofty level uh you know for
Richard Rapport what's he doing is is he
is he here to get a title no he's here
to win uh events win tournaments Shaq
all of these guys every one of these
players are about winning the tournament
and uh when they get him in a position
where the championship rounds and the
best they can get is third yeah it's uh
and this is why we uh we say that
perhaps it's a very important game for
Fabi because if Fabi doesn't win today
he definitely doesn't stand uh you know
a realistic chance at all and probably
not know mathematically right of winning
the tournament I'll try it and yeah for
him that would be a sad position to be
in Vegas he is he is very much about
winning tournaments exactly I just
wanted to turn our attention to the game
between Jan and Lavon this is not just a
moment because uh once again Levon
obviously tying for first coming into
today's game we got this position where
it was Bishop takes B2 and you know it's
the weirdest thing but correct me if I'm
wrong Peter I just got the feeling that
Jan's not even trying to win this I mean
it's it's harsh and a bit unfair because
I mean he played a very uh topical line
he had a a solid idea against it like he
clearly came prepared and he didn't like
this is a line where white makes a draw
like if Jan wants to draw there he makes
a draw in in any number of ways this is
the way for him but I'm a bit
disappointed that he played Rook C1 so
quickly because exactly I think you you
do come to the conclusion that you you
absolutely need to have 94 in this
position instead we are playing uh the
position that you you have on your
screen right now yeah which is just
going to be a comfortable draw for black
precisely
and I think the the remote that really
is like the dinner bell if you will A5
once black gets in once you start to
trade upon simplifying and a somewhat
curious moment was exactly here yeah no
no get get all the way down to King D3
uh King D3 uh seemingly is you know you
could maybe say that it simplifies
Black's task because it allows C5 but
and the point I was making earlier is
that even three against three on one
side will be a draw with this with this
material balance uh and the B7 Pawn is
not like black is not going to just give
up yeah yeah you've got to earn it yeah
you you you you you you you're going to
have to devote some some significant
amount of energy to actually picking it
up and black will make some progress on
the king side in the meantime but the
point is you just don't want to be
playing those spawn endings C5 I think
I'm pretty sure was would be would have
been instantly met by King C4
and whichever one structure you choose
here you are not guaranteed to hold this
because the king comes to B6 what's a
king E7 I go King C5 King B6
and then these types of positions they
are habitually lost by by black like I
go E4 here then I go King C5 King D5 E5
I trade some pawns then the king maybe
returns back to B6 and it's only white
playing for a win and maybe this one
this particular version is drawn like
the one the one with the pawn of two I'm
pretty sure is actually lost without
like if you go Rook takes D4 instead of
C takes D4 I think that one I I just
don't believe is holdable for some
reason I I at least this is what I told
myself maybe I'm wrong uh
in the same like King goes to B6 and
then we start kind of gaining gaining
space on the king side while black has
no moves and you're pressing there's no
question yeah there's also there's also
a slight issue of King a75 you might
just you know if if the Tempe workout
invites favor King A7 just wins the wins
the game on the spot here but I hear you
loud and clear uh Peter that uh King C4
is um so I just wanted to I wanted to
point this out because I think it's a
bit of an instructive position for
perhaps people who are not as familiar
with these types of Pawn endings because
it looks like nothing is happening it's
a four against four porn opponent game
where we're not winning anything
immediately but the difference in King
activity is such that no sort of no sane
person ever goes for this with black
right exactly you're it's a horrible
negative free role maybe you're not lost
but like you're not subjecting yourself
to that no not at all and I like again
this move H5 this game feels like it's
headed for a draw how about our other uh
co-leader Alejandro how is Wesley doing
in that King's Indian
uh against uh farugia 0.00 I
I mean there's a knight on D4 it's very
strong this knight from C6 came to D4 we
were looking at some other variations
for blackplay Knight D7 instead that was
also okay for black uh you could play
King F1 here you could hide the king but
the Knight is going to have to be taken
at some point you might as well do it
now yeah so you take on D4 you take on
D4 that hits that pawn on D3 it looks
like sorry on e4 the king comes to D3 to
defend it and it looks like you have a
really nice setup this bishop is now
blocked uh this bishop could come around
to D2 Target A5 sure you are now
Defending Your Pawn on e4 and it looks
quite Dandy Until you realize that for
the moment you won't have a good reply
to the move Rook AB8 that keeps your
winning chances alive plenty of replies
to draw the game no problem with that
you could take on A5 and take on B2 but
you're never winning that and if you
defend upon let's say with Rook B1 not
only is it an ugly move but after Rook
B3 check I'm expelling your king from
the very beautiful D3 Square which will
re-attack the pawn on e4 and after the
King goes back I have the option of
going back to B5 I couldn't even
reinforce The Rook with rook eb8 and try
to play for D3 in any case
0.00 I would be very surprised if this
game is decisive there are other games
that are more intriguing let's put it
this way the game mvl between and deck
are still going on and remember if
Wesley draws Alan Von dross and mvl wins
we have a three-way tie going into the
last round so this is an important game
for the standings uh we have this
position it's a Petrov we've already
talked about it a little bit Bishop
takes E4 Knight A6 95 and queen C7 was
played in the game that we were
mentioning earlier between Alaco and
Anand the move
Queen C7 was played instead of the move
Knight A6 which I believe is a was a
little bit more accurate with the idea
of Knight D7 until the engines
throughout the move Knight H4 and they
just invited craziness because you
sacrificed the power on H2 just to gain
the tempo on the bishop on F5 that might
have might have smelled there was some
kind of preparation somewhere they
didn't play them with Queen C7 his 10
went from Knight A6 which surprised nvl
it's not one of the top engine moves but
it is a natural developing move you get
the Knight out of the last part of the
board and after oops a couple
thank you leeches after a couple of
moves we get to this position where
you've forced black to commit to the
move B5 which slightly weakens your Pawn
on C6 for the moment this Knight on A6
is not really part of the game because
it's controlled by both pawns so it does
need some Precision on how to continue
here with white if you move your Bishop
all the way down to F1 it allows this
Knight on C5 to activate what am I
talking about this cool move Knight C5
actually comes on the board and because
your knight on E5 is hanging you cannot
take on C5 realistically it just ruins
your Pawn structure the queen would have
to go back the Knight can go somewhere
or just stay there because the Knight on
E5 is still hanging for a while and
black is doing okay so what's the engine
want to do instead of putting the bishop
on F1 put it on D3 if you trade you give
up the H2 Pawn with check and that might
be a very difficult decision to make as
a human because it looks like Bishop
takes Knight takes Bishop takes H2 check
why on Earth did I give up upon for free
but you know engine siren just since
they say that after King F1 or King H1
doesn't really matter Bishop D6 you have
to move A4 and because and you do want
to play Bishop D6 B4 G3 does trap your
Bishop A4 is played and surprisingly
awkward construction here for the black
side not so easy to hold on to the
entire Queen side and when you
eventually regain your Pawn the engine
regains it uh you end up being slightly
slightly better in this position so some
ideas here for the white side which I
would not find in a game I would not
really consider them of Bishop D3 yeah
it's so difficult to just think of it
yeah and I I don't want to make a formal
apology I kind of we were informed of
something by uh by the van people
via the van people yeah
told us that uh there was a significant
swing in the uh in the game we kind of
pronounced John in the game between the
publisher and and I kind of waved it
away and then I realized what they were
talking about uh after King C4 H5 King
C4 and I did like H5 as a kind of a
concept absolutely but at the king she
fall you want to think kind of
automatically played C6 uh before hghg I
think levonne thought okay I mean bcbc
even if I lose the opponent C6 three
against three is a draw two against two
is an easy draw exactly but the point is
B6 is coming
and that might be 3.95
and this position you can and sometimes
will lose no question about it the
opponent B7 is absolutely absolutely
vulnerable ux is not remotely the idea
here no the idea the idea is to play B6
and it cannot be stopped
and and this could spell this could
spell spell significant trouble for
levonne
oh you know sometimes you just fall
asleep
totally common right you see you see the
draw on the horizon you're driving
crystal clear you know you're already on
cruise control right you're half asleep
and then you realize wait a second he's
penetrating and winning the pond
and what has he played he's played King
8 which is actually the most resourceful
move yeah and it has a particular
problem because apparently B6 is like
yeah B6 is good here and after King D7
you have this Knight B3 Knight C5 manure
which is very strong but you could also
go 96 immediately
Ah that's a very visual move right you
cannot take on B5 either way
yeah and King G7 I'm assuming we just
take on six and go and that takes G7
yeah that might be winning and that
might be winning that might be winning
as well yeah so this swung very very
heavily in the last couple of months
because I'm pretty sure if black doesn't
commit the c76 it's going to be very
very difficult for white to do anything
oh he's just it's just a complete
come fell asleep yeah yeah he fell
asleep and what what's the story once
again after 96. I'll say King G7 we just
go beat xc6 we can play btx C6 here
because yeah cb7 which before will win
so you have to recapture on C6 and we
take on G7 and yeah and the game players
are new I mean no question about it uh
some drawing chances gear for black but
I think technically this has to be
winning agreed yep agreed
you know what that's very nice but just
go P6 yeah B6 King D7 might be three and
uh it does not hold it it's interesting
that it still does not hold it does not
hold it
yeah he would assume maybe it's somehow
holdable but no yeah I guess you lose
the king side somehow yeah f4f5 is
coming
F4 and once I got my knight to E6 yeah
you're just not holding this the king
side right I'm gonna go Bishop C5 Bishop
f8
yeah well I mean your pieces will be I
can sort of restructure it to put it on
light light square like I can go at five
two five G6 but the chicks will also be
extremely weak so we get this position
why why won't there be some counter play
with the Rook though
uh again is it simply F4 you also have
to watch out for some 9496 ideas like I
don't know exactly where
like I can go I can rubbish before
Bishop C7 and then start getting uh you
know getting the Knight towards the D6
Square in particular of The Rook leaves
and doesn't doesn't stay on the D file
yeah this doesn't look completely lost
to me but I will trust the engine on
this like if the engine goes all the way
up to plus three here it's an indication
that things have gone wrong yeah that
says a lot and boy for Ian What Might
Have Been I mean yesterday we know he
was the he he got gifted this howler uh
by uh Shaq if he had taken advantage
scored a win yesterday instead of
getting you know a loss
wow yeah so young clearly I mean the
poem would already have been on B6 if he
didn't spot Knight E6 I'm pretty sure
he's choosing between them if Jan's body
posture coming into today was you know
like lacks a days ago
he's plugged in as he would say you know
yeah
it's obviously
re-energized him and yeah he's very much
would like to win get back to 50 you
know ruin somebody else's tournament
truly truly I I really I enjoyed
yesterday the interview with Ali Riza
farouza he had just won his first game
and he wore a smile
that blocked out the sun I mean he looks
so happy Peter I mean uh my goodness and
uh okay so Lavon
uh very very unexpectedly is put on the
back foot uh where did it it was still
466 yeah just don't play just drop
backwards d8 for instance is a very
sensible move GH Rook h8 will be fine
h65
because H6 GH I would hate a little bit
but h65 is just instantly completely
fine that is a nice one that's in fact
that's yeah like the five King G6 it all
works out yeah I just want to make sure
for me for me it was actually around
here that was a little inaccurate okay
it started going wrong here in my
opinion because Levon played the move F6
almost automatically actually let me see
he took it took like 10 seconds to play
the move F6 10 seconds and the thing is
you want to meet Knight D4 with F5
almost always right and specifically
because you played F6 instead of a more
useful move you don't have Knight D4 C5
because of not the phone because Knight
F5 Hits 97 and hits the pawn you cannot
defend against both end of the game so
after Knight D4 he played King F7 and
this you say okay I'll play C5 next move
no problem right and then you see King
D3 and you're like wait a second you
can't play C5 anymore because the pawn
ending actually lost I don't know I was
playing around with it on the engine and
I couldn't I couldn't win it but and I
it says H4 here not King C5 King C5 is a
draw H4 is a how is it a plus one come
on give me a plus six or a zero
yeah you don't need to give it some time
which is it probably close to zero
though because it's only its own plus
one and yeah if it's not really climbing
that much I'm guessing it's I'm guessing
it's a drop but yeah nobody allows this
it's why would you right you have a
comfortable Rook versus two pieces how
can you lose this but it started getting
really uncomfortable after C6 B5 the
engine already says plus two so C6 was a
huge howler but already in this position
it was not so easy it's true that you
were looking at this line
and you thought this was completely fine
a four white the edges were so happy
Knight F3 takes H4 embarrasses you a
little bit on the king side because of
the reduced amount of material maybe you
still hold this
but but
you're not you're not super happy about
it this is not very clean yeah this is
definitely not right this is not clean
so at this point instead of C6 the
engine really wanted to play rookie five
yeah I was wondering about that it said
this is the only move wow that really
keeps
um equal well close to equality of
course the engine prefers the two pieces
but very close to equality and the point
actually being that after Bishop F4
rookie 4 Bishop takes C7 kind of
playable but H takes G4 is a little bit
easier because Bishop takes E5 F takes
E5 you can calculate to a draw HG Ed as
well yeah and if you move the Knight
then obviously uh GH you have more than
enough pawns you don't have to be
worried about that end game so this was
still quite manageable and instead we
have this position that after Knight B3
you kind of have to go Rook D1 or
something active it doesn't matter if
you throw the move King C8 uh you go
Rook D1
but why white stars maneuvering you
start putting the pawn on F4 you start
realizing that The Rook doesn't have a
good way to attack the pawns on the king
side that you have to go Rook H1 Rook H4
to do so it takes some time and it's not
easy to achieve the engines think Knight
C5 is actually a little bit of an
inaccuracy you don't have to play it
right away and it's still a long game I
still don't see exactly where white
makes progress because there are a lot
of Rook ideas hitting the pawns on the
king side but I mean this is just so bad
for black wow well thank you thank you
for those insights Alejandro and we see
the pawn on B6 and I'm thinking this is
really bad for lavon's fans but we have
some tweets yeah so let's engage with
our audience
and the first one from
99. how important is having a second
when playing at the top level in these
tournaments also who would each of you
choose as your second if you could
choose anyone from present day or from
the past
um wow for me let me just jump in and
say I love to have a second in my long
long time time second uh John Donaldson
was absolutely absolutely wonderful not
only your friend but just you know he he
had a he has a gift for saying the right
things at the right time to cheering you
up or you know bringing you down
sometimes you're a little bit too
excited and hey take it easy you still
got a game to play those types of things
the problem was was that when I was
playing professionally it was very hard
to be a professional to begin with and
to afford a second if you didn't have a
sponsorship you just didn't have it so
how do you say a luxury something
wonderful and rare for me for yourself
yeah I I personally I've been a kind of
of a lone wolfing it for the vast
majority of my career and uh it's it's
not great I think uh apart from the very
obvious benefit of having somebody to
you know look at openings for you and
they provide you with a layer of support
that just like takes some of the weight
off during you know important events
that's that's great but also just having
somebody to uh to keep you to keep you
you know uh sane and uh and and balanced
around it yeah but but I've played on a
in in a in three kind of the tournaments
in a row in the uh previous decade and
for those I I had I had teams uh teams
supporting me and that was that was very
useful and also I really liked the
people the people I worked with because
I'm like four for London and and Hunty I
had Nikita vichigov and Maxim Matlock of
helping me and they were both
very very good in terms of you know
producing ideas managing managing the
you know construction of the repertoire
and all that but plus you know together
to go with that they both are good
friends and uh the atmosphere this
created was was very very instrumental
in me enjoying it perhaps more than I
would have Alejandra Jump Right In who
has been your seconds or tell us uh
well I I haven't used seconds too often
I did play in three US championships
back to back and I had a second in a
disaster and then I went lone wolf in
the next one and I got second place so I
I'm not really sure about it but uh I
think that at the professional level not
that I'm a professional the level of
these players I think a second is really
important even if they're not analyzing
anything somebody that motivates you
keeps you company keeps you with your
routines after losing a game that
doesn't let you fall in depression that
knows you as a person yeah I remember
that when Favi lost a super important
game in 2018 against Sergey in Berlin in
the candidates yes rustom costume John
of the second at the time of Fabi he
knew what his boy needed they went to
watch a movie yeah they forgot about the
tournament yeah plug back in the next
day and uh and he won the event so
sometimes it's not just what's in the
board what's the analysis what's legal
let's say it's not just about hitting
the space bar right I think a second's
job is so much more important than that
it has so many intangible aspects to it
that it's really hard to quantify to the
audience what a second does exactly I
feel it's very important in the top
level uh some players don't like being
Tethered to another person to through so
much time but I feel like at the top
level most people do take do take a
second if I have to choose one for
myself for an important event I take
Rusty he's a he's very experienced uh he
we've worked together not
me for him or we've worked together for
Fabi but I think Asif johno would be my
yeah we kind of ignored the second part
of that question because like uh saying
saying thank you to our historic seconds
like people we have actually that's one
thing but like there was also this the
second Which
is far off in your corner yeah okay that
that sounds uh like the name I was going
to mention it will feel very kind of
disrespectful and I understand this is
not how any of these things work and
like I would be lucky to be a second to
miss chatel myself but like I deeply
regret never having spent any time with
him at all and I understand really that
this this is not how this relationship
would have looked like right but since
I'm you know all of you you've got the
the choice I'm offered hypothetical so
that probably is my my hypothetical
there really fast and it was it was the
shape of Water by the way
inspiration for the movie a second by
the way for a coach a trainer we can use
all of those words interchangeably but
the idea is that it's somebody you bring
with you that's in your corner your cut
man your your manager your your personal
yeah your wingman somebody's really just
looking out for you taking care of you
making sure that everything is going
according to plan and that you're not
forgetting things
um and it's so so nice to have again I
didn't have that luxury very much and
the person who uh again John and a big
shout out to John just simply a
wonderful wonderful human being if I had
the world as my oyster you know I mean
historians and stuff I wonder what it
like to be have Alexander alecai
with creative ideas you know like what
really like I don't know it was
historical drink yeah exactly right I
heard it was kind of grumpy oh that's
the other issue too you need that
compatibility right
it's great if I have to choose from the
past I mean Latina brother yeah Jose
Raul capablanca hello I would have loved
to hang out with him everybody said
according to historical accounts he was
a lot of fun he's such a great chess
player he was such an inspiration for me
as a young player like I loved to send
games I had his uh churn f60 Kappa
Blanca end games and I read that book
like 20 times I mean I love those end
games uh to me it would have been great
to have analyze in a jerk position with
him but let me throw you the downside of
that the downside of that is you've got
Kappa Blanca in your corner and you come
back and you go hey got this Greater
German Alejandro how can you play like
this you just you're killing me you
blundered I moved 23. you've wondered
you know
what I'm gonna take on my phone
[Laughter]
okay I got one story that's very very
rarely told very very rarely told so
here it comes for everybody this is a
this story is not really in the books I
rarely told we mean yeah it's oral
history uh to begin with
um so Bobby Fisher
had lost the first game of the 1972
world championship match and got
forfeited in the second he's down to
zero and a twelve
points for his opponent wins him uh
Boris baskey the world championship
match
so Bobby is really at a Crossroads
should he just say
you know you forfeited me uh I'm not
going to get this point back should I be
playing game three or not
and there was a lady in his life who had
kind of been like almost like a mother
to her to Bobby her name was Lena
grumette and Lena grumette raised Bobby
in his late teens in early Southern
California Bobby stated her home for
quite a quite a number of months and
Lena was at the match and they went to a
movie so it's the movie house once again
and
they're watching this movie and Lena
said she remember the the movie and uh
it's a darkened theater it's two hours
of watching the movie and Bobby's
getting more and more agitated and says
uh aren't you going to tell me that I
should play
she goes no we've already decided that
he goes what you owe me
he said what
you owe me says Elena
I mean all of those things I did for you
I I did them because I knew you were
going to become world champion so don't
disappoint me
and Bobby got his marching orders I mean
that's a second that's the second that's
why you have to you have to know your
client though that's true yes we will
work on every single person yeah if you
know enough to to to uh to be confident
in saying that that could be a very
powerful motivation I think that's it I
think it was like who wrote a book who
did tell that story in the book sorry
that's the thing about seconds right I
mean I think past a certain level so
many people can hit the space bar and
they will understand what the engine is
trying to tell them but I think the job
just goes so much further than that is
it really it really does at least from
my experience as being a second for a
world championship match fabulous
question thank you for the Tweet really
really really hit the spot and as we had
a pause there too because I welcome I
wanted to say that Shaq
we haven't looked at this at all I think
we haven't actually even had this on the
board yet that's okay this was the
Queen's Gambit accepted and it's just
like one of those things that we're
seeing in the Queen's Gambit accepted
time after time just black
reducing the number of pieces on the
board and there's still sample I would
say because of whichever light piece
ends up being on C4 it's currently the
Knight you get the feeling it probably
at some point will get traded and will
be a bishop on C4 it's a yeah before
immediately I think takes takes 95 is a
bit annoying even though I think I was
trying to calculate this and it's still
you can take on A6 though right maybe
that's the question can I yeah I mean
there is the check you can go you can
take on F3 maybe you should
yeah I'm not sure how happy I am with
any of this frankly I this apron could
be uh the important Pawn okay so well I
mean there's something to play for if
you're white you could even consider
moving into D4 and E3 E4 it's maybe
maybe there's a poll and for Lanier that
I like 97 though because it's it's a
topic we uh we come to quite a bit in
these types of positions uh normally
there's also the same issue with the
bishop on B7 but here it's only the
Knight on F6 and the topic is just how
well the pawns on F3 and E4 restrict the
black uh the blacks minor pieces and
very importantly the bishop already is
on D5 so you can you can and you will
meet the three four by capturing on C4
there's no way the bishop Retreats back
to B7 where it's just completely
completely controlled by that that
windbreaker one of three and before
exactly and the level F6 is also we're
watching uh linear moving it away from
F6 because on F6 against these two pawns
it just has no squares exactly it needs
to be somewhere else and this is an
important consideration in all of these
types of structures where we have A and
B versus A and B and all the four king
side pawns still on the board white
always wants to expand with F3 and V4
and black always has it in at the back
of their at their mind that it needs to
be countered by something the pieces
need to be repositioned otherwise you
will be in a bad place yeah in some
trouble okay I mean I would definitely
if I was in black shoes I would want to
get the pawn away from the tickle of the
bishop and not to allow them you get
into these types of positions where I
play Queen D4 I'm guessing you play 95.
I yeah yeah the bishop goes to E5 or
Knight C5 but yes the bishop goes to I
don't know itsu probably maybe have won
somewhere around there I I'm very
cautious of blundering community too I'm
worried I will blunder something like
Quincy too uh and the equation three
Isis is going to make a Luft here yeah
which lift I am going to make G5 is very
very useful to to secure the Knight
let's say yeah and here
play becomes I think very much about the
question whether white can get the
Queens off the board because if you do
manage to get the Queens off the board
in particular if you don't lose the
control over the C file in the process I
am picking white because A5 is weak A5
is right and black will very soon start
to have dedicating a lot of resources to
protecting A5 but black obviously is
heavily incentive wise to keep the
Queens on and then the Knight on E5 is
much more active than the bishop needs
so there's always contemplate because
one thing F3 and D4 also does is that it
weakens the white King's side it creates
a little bit potential counter play
against the King on G1 so this could
actually be quite a Double H position
and we do have E3 E4 as you said Bishop
takes C4 almost instantly played yeah
yeah this feels like a a force Force
move
intriguing of a fight once again the
Eternal question what's better the night
or the bishop I think we've established
the bishop most of the time but not all
of the time not all of the time yeah and
I the more I look at this the more I
agree with you there's absolutely no
need to try and make some kind of forest
trust straight away go away five put the
Knight only five and just kind of chill
yeah and play from there and
particularly if we can get time enough
to play Rook C8 and control the C file
fully yeah yeah I'm not that worried
about black I feel so good that we
actually you know gave the attention
gave a little love to uh Shaq and to
linear and let me turn back for a moment
to because we have been focused a little
bit on the Richie game and then we kind
of disappeared we left it what happened
well after 97 and knight seven we did
guess what's going to be played uh there
was this idea that we were discussing uh
mainly the the movie A4 there which uh
Fabi after some reflection decided not
to engage with decided that the position
doesn't need to be
you know addressed in such forceful ways
and then and there was one kind of
situation where where white wanted to
see Black's King go away like you go
away then I start to go like for example
I believe it was exactly right here
where we were playing A4 without the
wind Bush B3 right right right but in
case we were to get here this was like
kind of a kind of our dream music and
the reason it is it is so important to
provoke castles is that you you do not
want to allow King 87 here because the
King on D7 fights for the C file very
very well because I say we would go King
D7 and Tempo the rook and then play a
challenge with Rook C8 so after the move
Bishop E3 Richie Richie played Rook A6
which is a yeah I'm not gonna Castle
I'll play real case I think cussing is
yeah probably precisely because of the
one you just showed Castle Fields uh
perhaps premature but I'm wondering why
F7 F6 is not being played uh I I still
feel like that is sort of the the
counter correct the counter play you
look forward to in these types of
positions right and he probably just
likes something very concrete because I
think in in general terms you yeah but
now we can Castle perhaps okay but then
uh somehow your F6 is obviously
motivated that you want to be able to
trade and leave me with a Wii E5 square
or something to that effect the
obviously thinking with the bishop here
you know maybe we can do something about
that ft xc5 is not really yeah you're
interested you know it you're no hurry
but Rook A6 I I understand the move it's
just it feels to me that maybe it's a
bit slow but since we were discussing a
number of positions by this point where
white wants to play C5 C6 right Rook A6
does a decent job of containing at least
that particular plan right you but there
was a line that I really liked that
Alejandra was showing us where we play
In This Moment A4 you play here we play
here you play here and we play check
and then it was like this we've got the
a file and why aren't we winning
Alejandro asked and uh maybe rookie five
of six it becomes it becomes very very
concrete it becomes incredibly move by
move because if F takes E5 and Rooker 5
is is going to happen and the white will
start dealing with uh actual actual
counter play although you can play
Bishop D4 and claim it's nothing yeah
that that's precisely what I wanted to
say I just protected the F4 Square G3 is
a very very nice move and uh again on a
good day this Rook looks a little bit
wow yeah stupid yes sorry I mean that
that's brutal I mean no you don't like
these types of you're absolutely right
you need a harsh harsh words I don't
know
um okay uh I still looks lost to me yeah
yeah okay Alejandro's only like oh come
on guys this is this is just very very
bad for uh Richie
um yes okay again for those of you who
are joining this light I mean do make an
effort to check the archives track down
that interview yeah the interviews with
Shaq these last few days
where he hit us with a oh come on that
was that was man in the meantime the
game between Wesley and others will be
over over 90 seconds yeah uh oh this is
really is uh an alert I think we're
gonna see 434 and uh yeah they'll find a
way of making a three-time repetition
very shortly after the move Rook D4 yeah
not not necessary but the easiest way to
do it just get all the pieces off the
board I thought the King was already
neat too and I was wondering what your
plan against Rook B3
no no
I'm curious because I was actually you
know I'm so paranoid about these things
with black if I get this position with
black I was I was legit trying to figure
out how to make a forest draw after f2f3
on 26. we actually spent precisely zero
seconds on that choice I think F2 yeah
instead of Rook D5 I play F3
the bottom D3 could very very like you
can very easily imagine uh a scenario in
which it just gets encircled and
captured yeah and yeah I mean if the
Rooks come off if the Rooks come off
it's a draw but if the Rooks stay on the
board that four against three is kind of
annoying people have lost them it starts
giving me Vibes of Shaq versus other as
a yeah yeah like you can you can torture
your opponent for quite a bit here but
yeah Wesley Wesley not not very excited
about those prospects clearly and yeah
stuff is disappearing off the board and
yeah
yeah okay this game and doubtlessly it
will May will end in the handshake
what's the over and under on this one
I'm going to give it a 100 100 seconds
fewer fewer than 100 I think they're
going to be very clarified where's our
egg beater when we need one he'll play
Bishop F6 Bishop F6 is the professional
move ah 2800. great understanding
because I know what they're doing yeah
um
boy my Hundred was generous yeah yeah
like it's all about writing downloads
like moves themselves don't don't take
any time at all it's just the question
of how fast their handwriting is
um and yeah some of the uneventful game
and I mean we've seen Wesley do it time
and time again he is in a very good
sport tournament wise even better spot
actually because Levon is struggling
today big time and let's just jump to
the game and in fact uh Alejandro you're
about to show us something well we're in
this end game between Lavon aronian and
Jana pomyachi Levon with the black
pieces is trying to survive the sending
him Rook against two minor pieces the
material is technically equal if you
count them five plus yeah it doesn't
work that way the two minor pieces are
better than the rook and especially with
this pressure on the B7 Pawn I was
trying to make progress and the areas
are not happy with how nepo handled this
position uh perhaps they were a little
optimistic at the beginning but they did
think that at this point on D1 trying to
capture the pawns on the king side that
this King actually needs to come this
way it's done its job on the queen side
it's paralyzed the queen side but you
need to start defending these guys over
here now you can't reach the king side
that easily because right now there is a
rook on the way and it's pretty far
right so you have to start with the move
F4 the idea is that the bishop controls
the rook and the only way to defend or
attack sorry the spawn on G4 is this way
and if you do it this way you can play
moves like 90 94 Knight F2 and then
maneuver your King around move it to F3
or F5 depending on the situation return
your knight either to D6 or C5 the
king's not gonna go anywhere because the
threat of 96 or C5 is always lethal so
you take the time to move your king all
the way here maybe play the move G5 and
secure your structure that way but
instead uh nepo has played this way
allow The Rook to give a little bit too
many checks and it's not so clear how
you continue here because I'll continue
giving checks now that you're Bishops on
G3 instead of E3 this Knight needs
support if the Knight loses its support
like if for example your king E3 or
something dumb like this I want to kick
out the Knight and even though white is
still technical a little bit better in
this position once I start getting C5 in
a certain source of counter play I mean
Black's not that much worse I'm gonna
start trying to pick up the V6 Pawn or
at least tie one of your pieces down to
the B6 Pawn not so easy anymore so King
D4 I expect to move Rook D1 check if
Knight D3 you can still play C5 you can
also bring out your king the engines do
not think this is a decisive Advantage
anymore wow they're only giving a clear
advantage to why it's still some chances
for Nepal but they're not as excited for
the position as they were let's say half
an hour ago gotcha if you could play the
current position out for just second
case E4 once more King E4 Rook D5 I was
dropping the Knight into E6 oh 96 yeah
then there's a little bit of tactics
here King D7 now you want to take on G7
I sure did and then I'll trade your
pawns okay I always got whoa whoa whoa
wasn't Knight h no no that's a check
right yeah yeah yeah yeah no I was
wondering about Knight H5 Rook G4
no I can't do that
uh yeah but you already feel something
before yeah it's also okay yeah I've
traded I've traded the pawns on the king
side which is I wanted to win them and
this thing is coming right this thing is
coming out of its shell the pawn of B6
is falling you're not playing for a win
in this position anymore you can see how
easily the advantages dissipates in this
position so self-evidently yes yeah
I I mean wow Nepal has an hour and 21
because he got his extra 30 minutes
right but we've already been playing for
like two hours of Chess right he could
at some point have sat down and thought
okay
what do I do here how do I calculate it
out it's a very reduced amount of
material how do I do this and I think a
lot of players would have done that five
would have calculated it till the end
um I think Magnus would have just sat
down and be like what's the most precise
way but net was not that type of player
and apple just kind of goes with the
inertia he did spend some time the 121
on his clock is with the 30 30 minutes
added already so he did go down to 50
minutes so which considering you know
how much of the opening got completely
blitzed out is he actually made an
effort it's he's just not playing very
cleanly in this tournament yeah today
today I don't really want to blame him
for taking it very easy because I think
he did invest uh quite a bit of time in
trying to figure out exactly what to do
it's not such an easy uh end game uh as
we were as we were saying ourselves like
it looks very beautiful but once the
king gets to C8 it's not immediately and
intuitively clear how you win that
position and uh yeah today I think we'll
less less blame attaches to uh to to
Napa for giving enough thought I I
thought that we were thinking that while
the black king can and does get to the
square C8 the White Knight was going to
get to the square D6 and because uh
Sirius well with the Rook issues with
the Rook you know uh disturbing as well
yeah with the Rook on the on the G5
whenever you play Knight E4 I have King
D7 so organizing those things is not is
not as easy and not as intuitive as as
all that yeah so here we go down to five
and this is the point that you're
discussing any time
yeah anytime I I think I'm ready to drop
in and say hello on the D6 where you get
to play King D7 and and cut me off at
the path yeah it seems like Livonia is
is likely to get away with it somewhat
even though it would be a bit unfair to
say that uh you know he escaped
tremendous danger because the end game
started off being pretty much completely
equal exactly yeah and only only after
he has a 100 complete correctly
described he definitely kind of fell
asleep at the wheel there for a bit
because he just just as we did assumed
that like the game is borderline
finished like there's no more work to be
done they're just waiting for a way to
trade off the entire Queen side and then
c6b5 happened and he had to very clearly
he sat down and thought for quite a bit
there just to refocus and uh yeah get
back to the task at hand because he's
clearly now in danger again
yeah again I'm just kind of Slip Sliding
Away on this kind of a situation I was
trying to mostly five King C6 now as
well right
I got to play I get to play F3 just jump
on and Rook G1
um King G5 I got this uh King D5 move uh
yeah that is that is fair although Rook
F1 yeah The Rook F1 I start I start kind
of creating those
[Music]
the counter play just inside with one
game uh in the history books and that
game of course is with Wesley so he's in
the uh
I'm not going to say dog house I'm going
to say the 19th position the ball
position and very uh the very opposite
often yeah he's waiting to see the
result of the levana running game
certainly he's uh cheering Ian and let's
jump to Google
his question is ready to interview our
leader Wesley's hope
thank you Yasser yes we are indeed here
with Wesley so one of the leaders at
least until levaronian finishes his game
Wesley welcome back to the studio now
quite an interesting approach by your
opponent were you surprised by this
aggressive King's Indian style that he
employed or were you expecting something
else how do you did you approach the
opening phase of this game sure I was
quite surprised that he played the
king's Indian fire call the database he
I mean he played against of course but
if you look at the database he often
plays it only in Blitz and Rapid online
and offline events so I was definitely
very surprising with the king's Indian I
mean this tournament he plays a
different opening every single game with
either color I thought he would go for
the grunfeld do you feel like this is a
way for him to mask his intentions for
the candidates
ah
yeah I don't know it's it's a bit weird
to me that he hasn't played for almost
half a year or four five six months uh
he's hasn't played online hasn't played
over the board so
he must be doing something good for the
candidates well he hasn't played online
uh with his usual accounts who knows no
I meant include affecting us yeah maybe
that's for me even tournament tournament
yeah
he hasn't played in any of those but for
sure he has alternative accounts but uh
I I think he's also trying to lessen
playing Blitz online and I think he's
trying to focus on classical of course
big congratulations him for qualifying
for the candidates
um excited to see how he will do this
ceremony he hasn't been particularly
impressive but he's only 18 years old so
yeah a kid of course you went into this
game as the co-leader and obviously a
conservative approach wouldn't hurt you
at all so you you yeah I didn't
yeah wasn't exactly sure what to play
against the king's India and that's the
problem when there's so many good lines
to choose from
I mean there are so many good lines to
play against the Kings Union but I
thought it'd play E5 and I thought it
would go for the castle Knight C6 and
then last night I thought about
different variations to play against the
king's Indian but uh the computer always
gives a large Advantage for white but
then you get to the board it's much more
difficult to to play and uh
yeah and then I wanted to play an end
game so in any case I took on E5 and you
can see in his face I was very
frustrated
and I did so do you feel like he got
surprised the frustrated and perhaps
wanting to get a big fight and not
getting that was that also part of your
strategy yeah I mean he definitely
wanted to
get a big fight I mean he's one point
behind and uh
and yeah the kingfish Indian is not the
best opening but you it's very risky for
black but white is also risking and
there are many good lines but today I
simply wanted to play an end game and
see what happens any other critical
moments or was it just straightforward
you didn't get anything he didn't get
anything how would you assess it
um
yeah I think after when I went for the
end game I think he just wasn't
expecting it and he just played strictly
for equality I mean lack of other
interesting lines uh he played
Knight A6 here and move nine before a
few months ago in the world
the world Blitz a world rapid
but it was worse so in this one of the
best lines
uh
let's see here I thought
the after 96 we'll see will be one
rupees five
I guess I could play Bishop D2 but
Knight B3 Bishop C3 then there will be
one well first I mean seems to be very
still very close to equality yeah also
very equal you should be 2D there's an
accurate move otherwise but again the
slight problems because 60 takes an E4
baby B4 I guess
and now you get past the past eight Pawn
Yeah Yeah and then now the 4B Pawn
yeah now this is very difficult for
black because of that idea good
afternoon it may be happening in Poland
in Warsaw but uh yeah I mean today just
want to play End Game and I didn't
really have any deep
variation prepared against the king's
Indians and one more question now of
course uh I assume you had some eyes on
the other game the very important
matchup between Jan and 11 because Levon
was the co-leader going into this round
what do you think I want to gauge your
opinion on this one what do you think
about this position
I guess it's uh theoretical term but
black has to be accurate you might can
play Forever
Black Ops 2 will be just careful but yes
it's uh I guess your prediction official
prediction yeah of course I mean that
theoretical there I think uh with iron
Ian missed a big opportunity and move 39
so Bishop F4 I guess I play the move F4
yeah F4 I guess it's just winning for
for white Urban group do you want 94
Bishop D4 is coming so I guess uh
Ian
played a bit too quickly
yeah I think F4 probably just winning
for white
uh Bishop F4 I guess it's a theoretical
though that one found all this rookie
one of two one ideas but I think
yesterday was a very weird day also for
everybody I mean uh Richard reported
under the roof also Ian missile
completely win and
I ended up losing so it's just
unpredictable now Shaq was mentioning
yesterday when he was in the studio that
when he saw Richie gave up a piece like
he got flabbergasted are you generally
said by this type of situations when you
see one of your peer do such a big
mistake
yeah I was watching acre before and he
always mentions why his opponent never
does such blunders to him
then
I I've asked myself do you think to play
very cold against me and then they blend
their Rook but uh yeah it it I mean it
shouldn't happen but it sometimes
happened even top players make a make
huge uh blunders like that that just
goes to show you that there's a lot of
nerves in playing chess but I think
everyone was very shocked
of course but in that moment yeah that
happens
very rarely I guess I mean I have done
it also myself so I don't really want to
judge now Wesley tomorrow a big game
against Lanier with most likely the
title on the line preface that match up
for us yeah I mean when you're very good
very solid uh I I think I said a couple
I said a few months ago that when he's
informed he plays like a 2800 level
player so he's very strong very
incredibly prepared I think this sermon
he doesn't seem to be in 100 he's a bit
tired from playing every day in the
American Cup
basically
and uh
uh this the tournament could have gone
better for him
we'll see how he does today but
yeah in any case it will be a very big
fight on the black pieces have to come
well prepared excellent thank you very
much Wesley for joining us and we'll see
you tomorrow thank you thanks for having
me guys back to you thank you Christian
well done Wesley as he is currently our
leader with a half a point let's jump
right into this game we've kind of left
it alone a bit between Daniel and mvl
mvl uh when we left it uh was he gonna
sacrifice his H2 pawn and it sure he
chose he chose not to and I think the
biggest the biggest issue there is that
you just don't consider it for very long
you like living the Polish Don peries
with Czech is not something that comes
very nice the line that the line that
the engine uh gave and just caused us to
kind of like drop our Jaws like really
yeah you just give her the H2 Pawn this
Knight is badly placed and the engine
wins its Pawn back with the move a2a4
mvl understandably dropped his Bishop
all the way back and 95 blade Bishop B6
was actually I think one of the uh the
top engine moves in that position uh
avoiding avoiding some double double
attacks like Queen of three might be
otherwise uh or like if you play in the
potentially let's say if you go Knight
E6 here which looks natural you allow
queen of three and you might have to
face some unfortunately like unpleasant
decisions because you you you you will
have to change the structure in uh ways
that you perhaps don't want to change it
Loose pieces drop off absolutely yeah
well I did yeah because I I did that one
too many times here uh yeah and now it's
actually quite sharp because uh mvl I
think made a conscious effort to avoid
like like D5 is a very commit almost
because move because structurally
black I think is doing very well that's
what I wanted to say I mean isn't this
kind of like a dream open Spanish for
black I mean he's got positioned E5 Pawn
which isn't very useful unless you're
going to Checkmate me yeah and weirdly
for some reason in my mind this
particular structure this constellation
on the queen side is associated with a
with a kind of a nobody believes it
Evans Gambit
which ends with with this exact
structure respect yeah it's Gambit yeah
nobody cares okay a good show but nobody
cares but this is an Evans Gambit
structure yeah but MPL is clearly saying
that you know he would like to launch
some kind of an attack on the king side
but with the Bishops on E7 and E6
controlling so many squares and the g
file already open I I struggle to to
believe there will be an attack on the
king side me too I just I just don't see
it I just don't don't see it happening
he's not running too many strategic
risks no but it still looks kind of
pleasant for black I I do right I
wouldn't mind this with black at all I
mean the only issue
yeah yeah exactly but the only issue I
have is black is that I'd really like my
queen to be on some marvelous Square I
don't care B3 B2 you know in the thick
of things C5 it's very hard to get this
queen into some Super Active but I like
what you're saying just play Rook D7
Rook D yeah
4 might be a bit awkward actually my
bigger issue for for black here is that
I sorry for white is that I don't
understand how I'm supposed to improve
my my pressure on the king side like
what what is the plan here page 4h5
normally is the answer to everything
right but I get the feeling you can take
I'm not sure but I get the feeling you
can take right not to mention of course
that uh this excuse me I meant to say
that this bishop on D3 is not protected
I mean I was boldly stating obvious by
the way you're you're supposed to give
me credit for these astute observations
uh but no seriously because the bishop
is undefended no Queen h5s for you you
know H4 things I could drop off like you
say Bishop takes H4 I think Daniel
assault his opening issues at least it
seems comfortable yeah strikes me that
way uh let's once again jump in on the
game of Fabby my pick by the way I mean
come on Fabi then me make me look good
here yeah and he he found a clever way
to kind of uh drag Richard into
different directions there he played A3
with a clear intention of playing before
for a second there I was wondering if
a3a4 here might be a threat right but it
isn't because I think uh eight days
before like unfortunately for white Apex
before cannot be replied to with 8xp5
because the 283 is happening it's
hanging so you have to take with the
Knight and then Black Goes 95 Rook h8 A8
yeah you don't sport you don't you don't
make me a happy camper by ever allowing
me A4 takes B5 this is not this is not
not what we signed the structure that we
wanted no but fruity one is very clever
here I was still expecting Rickard to
spend the tempo on Rook d8 I thought
Rook d8 follow it up with King E8 and
try to play Rook D A8 before you open
the a file exactly you want to play
claim to the 85 but he clearly just
liked something about it I'm not
entirely sure what maybe there was some
tactical issue with it I couldn't really
work out what tactics could even be in
this position it seems very quiet so I'm
reasonably comfortable spending a number
of them be here on just kind of
improving my position slowly but the way
he played it uh which is he immediately
took one before to to offload some
pressure instead of Rook d8 now he will
have probably he will have to give up
control over the a file I don't see him
you know I don't think we can afford to
give up the pawn on D7 no uh in some
positions you can for activity but there
will be no activity and it's a kind of
an integral pawn and if you go to K1
Rook A1 here that is not fun I mean
you're not losing just yet but I'm
enjoying just yet
I'm definitely the one you know like
honestly honestly eight days before kind
of shocked me a little bit because I
thought this is maybe you can go Rook d8
though but
something like this exactly taking only
one feels you know very completely wrong
yes
he's played Rook B8 here and the the
idea here of course is that Rook D7
currently is impossible because the Rook
on A1 is hanging and if you start by
taking on A6
uh well impossible is actually strong we
can't actually
adjusting but well uh
yeah
I don't fully believe it but yes it's a
very serious option but it might not
work out Dr exactly and the other point
is yeah if you take on A6 uh after a ba
yeah then the opponent before is hanging
giving black uh count to play rookie
seven Knight before doesn't look very
clear at all well even again I mean you
definitely take a you take a moment
right yeah no you have to you have to
evaluate this but it doesn't look
horrible to my eyes I will get King E8 I
will probably get to position
we look nicely on uh we just we just
pause and we just kind of like
flabbergasted with ourselves this had to
be calculated very precisely because
Rook C7 C6 is a very real idea here yeah
that's but I but I have night eye you
have rookie 6 B6 there yeah yes I
thought I used to go Knight A6 night
before back
straight up loses to rugby six yeah that
that that looks like a like this uh that
that works out nicely for white but that
isn't playable you you you you do stop
here and you go wait a minute I mean I'm
the one having the fun if I can get my
Pawn to C6 uh prep Rook takes E7 Bishop
C5 I'm a hero c56 will will create a
number of very very strong threats
indeed indeed uh funnily enough there I
was actually looking at the immediate C6
just right here because sometimes these
uh how do you say
Eternal pins sometimes uh they just win
the games by themselves uh players are
not alone yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that that's the annoying one right yeah
you just you you you don't get to
squiggle away yeah you don't
and uh well there is a wonderful way for
you to join our conversation as well as
to ask any of our panel any questions
that you might have
how do the people do that people yeah uh
you can tweet at us by using the hashtag
grantchester as we we see um
uh do there or you could tweet at the
ground chest or a Twitter account your
predictions on who is going to win the
candidates uh I am I've been coping out
on that on that question for the past
couple of months I'm like I'm picking
three I'm not picking one I'm picking
three my three are uh in in no
particular order earlier as a uh Fabi
and and Yan if if I absolutely have to
pick one I'm picking Fabe I'll pick two
in that case Hikaru Fabi
show my nationalism Jump Right In I mean
if I can get three the Three's a lot but
I'm gonna go with Fabio is a ding I
think ding being the number two in the
world
you get some well actually not spoken
about it now these are your eight
choices yeah those are my eight choices
for the candidates
is also somebody doesn't you know nobody
really mentions teamwork as one of the
favorites for the candidates
there are no bad players in this
tournament yeah I think actually my my
my kind of a default answer I just
haven't updated it to to the current
situation because I think when I started
giving that answer thing wasn't them
again
good point
so I just I just kind of need to need to
adjust my adjust my uh defaults there a
little bit
um
nice
it's a
it's such a field that is very very
difficult to uh even three I think is
not that easy to pick as as we've seen
like it's it's
you don't exclude anyone there right and
again going to be very fun to watch
because uh Lavon aronian uh he's got a
chance that he could seize and they
there is a possibility that he could
seize clear first and with the draw he
would tie with Wesley we currently think
he's on the worst side of uh yeah I
don't quite says yeah I I think no we're
going to need some help
we can't do it by ourselves yeah we're
gonna need a bigger Rook yes exactly
right uh Bishop a bit Bishop to D6 was
the last move but it's Fabby that could
really improve things uh well again this
is before I think Wesley actually has
five yeah let's say he's on five now so
probably catch up to uh to Wesley but if
he wins he can get within striking this
of the podium that's exactly what I'm
saying yeah here we go this is the
updated uh one game the one one game
done right yeah the rest still in play
yeah with Lavon trying to hold the draw
he's definitely not going to win
I think and well I mean if Bobby wins
plus one going into the last round who's
he facing in the last round
I have it somewhere we just yeah
by the way your H4 did appear in the
game of mvl did play it out there and
the reason I was curious about this I
couldn't really figure out exactly
what's happening after Bishop takes H4
but I think the plan is quite simply
thick on H7 play Queen H5 Queen H4 and
in general terms I think this is a trade
that favors black immensely but that's
what the H pawns on the board with rh7
Pawn gone I'm very worried I will get
mated on the dark squares like Bishop G5
F6 rookie 3 G3 yep if you do get method
in these positions you get made it kind
of
and by the way you're not resisting
either because of the Bishops of
opposite color you're pieced down on the
dark squares and uh h2a you said uh
because we were we were kind of saying
if if white is doing anything it's based
on leveraging this E5 pawn and H4 is
your default option except maybe we
don't have it and yeah then maybe again
but if we do have it we play it pretty
much uh automatically following up on
the viewer's question because I think
it's a it's a Salient as the question
itself is because of Magnus has made the
point and he's repeated himself I'm
going to disappoint my fans I may not be
playing yeah for the world championship
so the top two finishers we could we
could get into a situation where what
world championship match Sans Magnus
Carlson would you like to see that's a
question yeah
you're good you're good to go honestly
yeah I mean it would be I would be
unhappy with that with that outcome
honestly I feel like uh
I like watching Magnus play chess and I
think most of us most of us do and I
think it also feels like you're climbing
Mount Olympus right and you're you're
taking down the throne and this is the
way things work right and if you feel
like two different people but not about
halfway and they battled each other
that's not really what you're looking
for right but it's not the fault of the
candidate it's not the fault of the
candidates no you can't follow the
players at all right you can't follow
the players for the system you can't
fold the players for what ends up
happening you can't hold the players for
the world champion deciding not to
defend his title I mean they're going to
do their best right and they're going to
prepare hard for whoever they play it
just feels unsatisfying as a chess yeah
and also if you look at a chess history
right like okay not defending a title it
it it's happening it's happened and it
doesn't feel so good right and it's
totally carp off Bobby Fischer we didn't
defend his title yeah end up you know to
a certain degree the the the the
alaikins death death in 1946 vacating
vacating The Throne pardon me yeah but
yeah it will be it will be a very
unsatisfying end to to among this is
Rain Rain there at the top but and it
also creates a kind of this this weird
dynamic where uh it's probably best just
not to think about it at all for for the
candidates themselves but
uh there will be some sports where
second is actually you know you don't
know if second gives you the match
normally normally uh the candidates is
like one of the most straightforward
tournaments in the calendar because you
know that I mean there's plenty of money
at stake absolutely but none of these
like yes it feels weird to say that yeah
but the challenge but the prize really
is the match precisely so there's one
winner and seven losers pretty much yeah
but but this year this year because
there is this in introduced uncertainty
into the entire process thank you you
you you might have this weird spot where
uh there are there are two places in
play and that very much changes the
dynamic of the whole tournament I mean
think about the 2016 candidates match in
Moscow I think yes that Sergey karyakan
win one in the last round one in the
last round against Bobby but if I went
all out with black right yeah right uh
if if second got him a match spot or
maybe got him a match spot yeah
different game he doesn't play the the
rift arouser and by the way that was a
no tiebreaker situation which forced a
Fabby to go uh AWOL yeah but anyway an
intriguing question and uh just think
about who are the two players that you
might want to see in case of an absent
Magnus we're going to take a break and
we'll see you on the other side
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
United States the St Louis chess campus
in the heart of the vibrant Central West
End has established itself as a premier
Global destination for chess and is
comprised of two unique non-profit
institutions
the chess club and Scholastic Center of
St Louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world and plays hosts to
all major tournaments including the U.S
chess championships and the sinkfield
cup one of the strongest chess
tournaments globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries led by an expert
commentary team of grand Masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess with a specific focus on
bringing the benefits of Chess to
Children throughout the St Louis area
research shows children who play chess
exhibit improved analytical skills and
increased confidence the chess club is
highly engaged with the local community
bringing Scholastic chess programs to
more than 100 Schools providing hundreds
of classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club is the World Chess Hall of
Fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the U.S and World Chess Halls
of Fame
Cutting Edge exhibitions feature rare
historic chess artifacts paired with
world-class art Innovative programming
explores the intersection of Chess art
and culture
visitors can enjoy interactive programs
designed around the exhibitions and
monthly music in the galleries the World
Chess Hall of Fame is nothing you expect
and everything you love three different
Galleries and a premier gift shop
highlight the culture history and
creativity Behind The Game come visit
play chess leave enriched to learn more
about the St Louis chess campus visit
stlchesscampus.org
[Music]
St Louis University celebrating its
200th anniversary offering world-class
education in the heart of St Louis SLU
attracts students and professors from
around the globe
in 2015 slew partnered with the St Louis
chess club to start a top-tiered
Collegiate chess team on the very first
year of the team's Inception slew
obtained second best university at the
Pan-American Intercollegiate chess
championships
higher purpose greater good
St Louis University
[Music]
Welcome to our show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you guys gonna see this
that's our show now go start yours
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
uh welcome back to round eight of the
Superbad chess classic in in Bucharest
only one game has finished so far it's a
game in which Wesley uh took a safe
approach to his uh battle with Elyria as
a ferocia and it was a draw uh all the
other four games are in very very uh
balanced
uh balanced state right now we'll plenty
to play for
and arguably the sharpest one we have is
the one we I think we've only looked at
it for the first time during today's
broadcast maybe one hour in it's our
Queen's Gambit Queen's Gambit accepted
between uh and Lanier Dominguez in which
they blowed up on us actually yeah it's
uh
when we left it we left it more or less
in what we kind of thought was a little
bit of a quiet position and uh funnily
enough he played not G5 but they should
follow budget yeah it's a much more
professional approach and how did it
blow up we did see F4 and then F5 here
and take States out to four it's a very
confusing position because uh both kings
are now seemingly somewhat unsafe and
also the Knight on the fork as opposed
to the Knight on E5 does give the white
the white Bishop this fantastic Square
on C4 that's the dream and my first big
question for this position is how do we
meet Bishop C4 because Bishop Bishop C4
also creates a very strong thread of
Rook F1 which I would suggest borderline
wins the game for white if it's allowed
right because it drives the way the
Knight away to poor squares and the idea
after Queen C5 is King F2
uh we're being told King H7 is the best
move after Bishop C4 Queen C5 I I looked
at but I'm not that sure about those end
games I mean I thought it was all about
the Kings right and uh the question yeah
check can I lever the night too yeah but
still can I play rookie Rook of fun here
anyway whoa really room G8 I want to
play King H1 and I have Queen six queen
of three right
Bishop C4 play and bishop's people on
the board and also something that we
always have to keep an eye on how much
time does the year have then you have
plenty of time for a standard he's got a
solid solid 15 minutes whoa that's a
luxury unfair yeah yeah I think Shakira
feels very very hard done by here how is
he how is he still in 15 minutes do you
ever feel like sometimes during a
tournament especially round Robins you
feel like one of your future opponents
is making a mistake over and over again
time pressure time pressure everything
time pressure
and the moment you face him blitzes out
every move you're down 30 minutes on him
and you're like wait what happened
aren't you the one supposed to be in
time pressure terrible terrible yeah no
it was something uh like that I remember
um King Luke uh Luke Van Valley was
playing in bike on Zay and it just
seemed like there was a lineup of people
who wanted to get Luke's night or like
everybody everybody everybody and then
Luke of course you know around 14 or
something he deviates
the frustration of his opponent is
poppable you know I remember I played I
played Sasha grishock in one of the
Grand Prix I think it was in Moscow in
2017 I want to say okay and he he played
the English against me and I've been
doing some really kind of sub-optimal
stuff against English for a while by
that point against everybody and against
him I just thought okay I'm sick and
tired of this crap I'm just gonna play
the main line I have actually at some
point looked at the main line I'm not
entirely cordless and he like tanked for
55 minutes
as is his want he's like tank for 55
minutes and move from nine or whatever
in a very well-known theoretical
position and I actually knew the
solution to what he did and uh it was a
draw and then as usual we we go to stand
in front of the you know the sponsor
wall and leave the interview I think it
was possibly we were talking to to
Nastia there who our co-host
and Sasha got asked some question he
said basically I think he was asked what
was he thinking in those 55 minutes and
he said I was just sitting there
thinking how unfair it is that is me
that Peter accuses to actually not play
the usual the usual random crap
why is he cheating against me of all
people exactly this is not fair
five minutes
I could feel his pain
people are expecting me not to know
anything in the opening and you know
frustrating yeah also very funny in the
candidates uh tournament Bobby Fischer
uh I think it was uh
Petrosian played a Karo Khan against
Bobby Fisher who was like what the heck
and Bobby is having real trouble so Paul
Cara starts again as well it's like what
I mean everybody deviated Bishop C ford
it's a serious uh it's a serious
question I I I'm having trouble at this
moment uh finding a good move uh I I
came to a a dead end after King H7 yeah
I think that end game is actually fine
for black I I came to the conclusion
that yeah after checking G1 I'm sorry
King H1 Queen six check uh I also have
the immediate maybe the immediate but
here let's say we take take yeah we play
Rook G4 allowed
didn't uh spot yeah and whether we go
King G7 King F6 and I get the feeling
black isn't really that much worse at
all with the very very active pieces on
the on F4 and G4 but yeah this is uh
this is touch and go okay
um Alejandra weigh in on this one
because this one confuses me confuses me
a bit too Yasser because let's take a
look at this position my first instinct
was to go Queen C5 go ahead into these
kind of end games I know what you guys
were saying that the end games might not
be so good but I was high in this F5
Pawn I thought it was sure perhaps some
kind of Target the edges are saying nope
F6 clamp down on F7 Rook D7 will come at
some point also Rook D6 through k6
Bishop B5 will eventually win the pawn
it takes a long time but the thing is
the Knight can't really rejoined the
party so easily while holding on to the
F7 Pawn so there's more than one way to
get into a good end game in the
variations that you guys were showing
after King H7 Rook F1 actually after
Rook G8 check King H1 Queen C6 Queen F3
is winning for white I'll just straight
up straight up winning you actually just
lose the knight uh the Knight doesn't
know where to go you could go to H5 but
what movie is this what's everything The
Rook G4 and Rook G4 as you guys were
mentioning H3 right King H2 King H2 you
just have no coordination and remember
F7 is hanging gotcha so you can't really
do that you do the same variation
without exchanging the Queens you go
Rook G4 and if you uh play the move H3
in this position Rook H4 hits the pawn
so that's an important Tempo you don't
have time to go and queen of three just
H5 I guess right and we support the
rokanji father on Queen F3 here in this
position H5 is playable the engine says
Rook H4 is also okay but that H5 is very
strong and actually better for black so
wow King H7 only move in the position uh
needs to be found by linear it is a bit
counterintuitive until you start
calculating because you are hanging upon
with F7 but then you calculate it okay
uh B3 is actually counter hanging let me
put it on the board takes takes you
could throw in a check if you felt like
it and the point is that you have enough
counter play here if I go to uh this way
I get made it the way the nipple almost
I made it oh sorry I made it and here
Queen takes B3 check your osm Rook G7
you can also go Rook G5 and start
pressuring this Pawn there's more more
than one way to draw this position so
the important thing for linear Dominguez
here in this position
find King H7 everything else is going to
lead to an incredible amount of
suffering in an end game and I I wanted
to ask you uh I I had the feeling that
at some point the engines actually
preferred the linear's position a bit
earlier so what was the the misstep what
was the they didn't really prefer his
position that much
uh after F5 they preferred playing the
move Knight F4 here instead of taking
taking a knight F4 and you kind of
understand that because this Pawn here
stifles yes the bishop and on Bishop C4
I have the extra resources yeah E5 and
just Clinging On to this Knight on F4
forever exactly the Knight gets anchored
that was a key point that G6 takes F5
another more than more than I say the
more Curious I am and why you would take
an F5 yeah exactly five is such
attempting now lengthening lengthening
the diagonal for the bishop on C4 and
you you do expect Bishops it's just yeah
it's a strange Choice by by linear
absolutely nine minutes for linear uh we
could give this a question mark in fact
potentially yeah and he needs to find
good moves now because if he doesn't
find King H7 and just hate this position
wow uh intriguing point that you were
making there about Queen C5 because I
was thinking I was coming to a dead end
on King 87. so I was thinking Queen C5
and you have to calculate the
consequences of F6
and you and it's not the only way
there's a there's a couple of pretty
ways to get into the end game and they
all they're all kind of bad for what for
black
like uh go ahead get for example Queen
C5 Rook da Chuck
yeah you kind of have to go to G7
because if you go to H7 in many
variations you're hanging the pawn and
here Queen D4 is super annoying
right you don't have King H7 because
quick h8 yeah that is very good that's
nasty that is a very cute and that will
cost me my queen because now I have to
take the Rope which means I have to
trade Queens after yeah
that my knight is really uh no yeah Rook
D7 will defy all kinds of things yeah
yeah well this is the ending that you're
dreaming uh to achieve
that's terrible yeah it's terrible so
you spot Queen c500 there's more than
one way to get something really
advantageous for white right and then
you start trying to spot different
things King h8 is just a bad move
compared to King H7 so I think you land
on King H7 yeah I think if you choose
between those two squares yeah
very good well we'll leave it here as
Lanier has Oodles of time uh uh jumping
back to the game of uh family has been
tanking for quite a bit there Richie we
just saw this move Rook B8
uh clever I mean we've got to give
Richie points uh for being clever but it
does feel like
whites got something and yeah probably
spend a significant amount of time
there's a half an hour by this yes wow
30 uh 31 minutes and 40 seconds you
spend a lot of time here in disbelief
that the variation after Rook A6 Knight
A6 Rook D7
actually hold for black 94 Rook C7 I
know everything we were looking at
actually holds for black remarkable and
oddly enough do we trade on A6 we crash
through with our Rook with Rook takes D7
we first we start with the trade we
accept this trade we see this move works
and the thing is black only has one move
in this position that doesn't lose we
didn't get to it but black has one move
to not to lose and that's it everything
else loses
I have good eyesight yes yes so we're
asking yes I'm thinking it's King E8 but
I'm not sure why the problem with King 8
is that it doesn't defend the G7 upon
so yeah I'm gonna have to play King fa
right which is weird because
right the move is Bishop we yeah we need
to have Bishop G8 in this position this
is that point yeah yeah and even though
you can play Bishop C5 check attacking
both pieces but now I've got King G8
yeah and Incredibly
we don't yeah for a second there I was
very worried about the position of the
bishop takes no this is 1966 this is a
draw I thought Bishop before
uh Bishop seven Bishop D6 but I guess
Rook C8 Knight B5 Bishop B6 holds I
would assume otherwise this would be
quite interesting because Bishop b686 I
think you lose because yeah Rook 6 D7
actually wins the d-pawn very very
important line which you I mean it's an
easy line but it's an important line for
the entire code it's a girl yeah yeah
this is the yeah this is a queen but you
do play Bishop B6 white gets to put the
pawn on C7 but now you've got your
defense yeah the way the pieces are
positioned you you don't get to play
Knight A7 you don't need to play 96 the
king comes to D7 I don't know if white
is worse but white is definitely not bad
I think that white is worse myself yeah
but wow yeah but the whole line is it's
it's a tough move to find and when we
might be running straight towards it
because he has to think after a long
time after a long time and I don't think
you take on A6 with the idea of going
Rook B1 no or Knight A2 for that matter
either that doesn't doesn't feel doesn't
feel very inviting so Rook takes D7
Knight takes B4 Rook to C7 and the I
think Richard gets there by once again
by excluding all the wrong moves there
and in the meantime by the way did play
kingish that we don't need to switch but
I just wanted to say thank you for that
linear as usual uh is very on point when
he gets to calculate you know it's
really tough when you play this
counter-intuitive moves like King f8 and
it's only because you calculate so well
that you get to these I think that
that's extraordinary uh that these great
players they calculate these things and
as you say it's a process of elimination
everything else loses therefore I have
to find the only move that draws the
interesting thing about this position is
that I am not entirely sure what we play
let's say against h2h3 waiting room yes
yeah because Bishop d8 Bishop Rook D7
you would like to play bishop j8 and
Knight C6 but that allows Rook D6 and
your position starts crumbling
so
quickly yeah quite quickly so you could
perhaps go Bishop d8 Rook D7 Bishop B7
and suggest that
white already once chosen Rook C7 in
this type of a position so maybe you
choose it again but yeah I want to play
G4 here and perhaps the intrusion of G4
perhaps the inclusion of G4 G6 actually
improves our chances a little bit for
why because H7 will be hanging but
definitely an improvement because that's
the main problem let's go back to this
position after I just wanted to make a
point that after C6 Bishop d8 Chuck
yes yeah take a look at the analysis
board you just need a good square right
on the seventh like if Rook F7 was
defended if if the Rook somewhere
attacked something exactly you
immediately win right but none of them
none of them do anything because it's
extraordinary yeah Rook B7 Knight takes
C6 defends The Rook right this is
important yeah this is crucial
yeah otherwise rugby seven would have
won on this on the spot but as is it's a
draw yeah yeah
only one move here for Richard so I so
uh just the current position
yeah but along the court along the uh
uh but uh if we if I played H3 right
away
and um
are you playing King E8 that was my
question
because if you are playing King Y8 and I
play Rook C7 again I keep on coming back
to the idea of going 1969 before but it
never works because rugby six is a thing
the year I will go night before oh I'm
sorry of course
yeah that that's your problem
and I'm looking at it with the engine a
little bit deeper okay yeah after Knight
takes before well you guys are playing
yes I was going H3 I because Rook C7 was
coming up short after King f8 I was
wondering what black is going to do for
a move from following H3 uh Alejandro
yeah it starts counter play just ask H3
King E8 King E King and apparently King
8 also playable in the other position
we'll take a look at it later it's crazy
to give up now yeah King d8 now is
pretty decent right you can I don't know
about King yeah King g896 King U7 we've
actually gotten the absolute ideal so
you've got the Knight back on C6 yeah
which is why I think if we want to play
H3 we want to start with Rook C7 Force
King f8 okay so I was looking at here at
Rook C7 the engine after some thought
King E8 also playable here C6 and it
just gives up the entire King side
Bishop d8
takes on G7 Knight takes C6 Rook takes
H7 and it's my turn although
I'm terrified like I see this H spawn
it's fast it's very fast I already have
a block getting Knight on B1 if I felt
like it
but yeah this is not an easy decision
this is not a this is not an easy
decision I would assume Black's just
lost here
but apparently this is uh playable they
don't think it equalizes fully wow okay
uh the games are heating up I have to
say because across uh the board we also
have another game mvl and uh Daniel uh
when we left it I was kind of going in
Daniel's favor frankly I thought that
his Queen on E6 made such a marvelous
impression on my mind that but perhaps
somewhat influenced by his uh habitual
very short short uh very low time left
he chose to simplify he should be
completely fine here because the the
pollen six is somewhat weak but so is
the Pawn on H5 we can take on H5
straight away which is what he does and
after Rook takes C6 the white pieces are
somewhat more active but you don't
really expect a crook hf5 here or
something and yeah black is not well I
see some coordination too Peter I mean
black is not really worse we are
yeah but yeah you don't you don't see uh
you don't see much of anything here for
white and I wouldn't be surprised if uh
mvl just went C4 here and then they
found some kind of a threefold uh
against 30 seconds you're maybe somewhat
tempted to to continue playing
Daniel dick has a minute yeah thrives in
this ocean of time yeah first of all
it's a minute and secondly yeah it's
just very difficult to imagine how
you're going to be better here even if
let's say black goes Rook F7 Bishop 8
King H7 everything is protected uh and
uh there's so little material left on
the board I agree wholeheartedly with
that that looks like a very balanced
even position uh jumping back to dare I
say it our tournament leader uh and
things are getting more and more
confused in the game between Levon and
uh Ian I'm beginning to think that Lavon
is like is still not playing for a win
but I'm also sure I'm also a bit a bit
curious why he chose to play f605 there
because I I would be interested with
white in the idea of creating a weakness
on G6 and trying to combine the weakness
on B7 with a weakness on GC so you want
to go G5 I don't want to I wonder I
don't want to play G4 G5 here and then
after F4 I also have this idea of going
King B3 here and maybe taking on C it
never works out right rook and go
anywhere okay one because 96 King D5 is
always a very
it's always a very comfortable reply
there's also BCM check exists yeah but
King D5 is um
systemic failure for failure to defy
will always be available nicely put
Peter a systemic failure indeed but also
after Rook A1 why don't you think this
is a three result game because there are
weaknesses uh yeah I mean G5 G5 plus G5
is a very committal move and uh yeah I
mean it could be that you're absolutely
right and I'm sure this is on the board
if I prefer for played right
uh I still don't think what this is very
much seven is such a vulnerable Pawn but
uh
I still I still think it's very
difficult for white to be worse like I
can play Bishop D4 in the current
position instead of King B3 King B3 is
kind of I mean you can make a draw
whenever you want is why the problem is
that if you try to win then we're gonna
have to try to calculate something out
Jump Right In Alejandra there's not that
much the engines just say this is a draw
just that's it that's it you The Rook is
too active you can make whatever move
you want to make but the Rook is going
to keep attacking the pawns on the king
side and you're gonna have to keep
defending them with pieces and you just
don't have the time to counter attack on
B7
and remember that in many variations
even if unc6 congratulations right you
on C6 but so what it doesn't mean that
you got to pass it so you don't get it
out of the blue Bishop D4 on them about
the clocks yeah it's a very funny
situation where it's the second time
control and they both have about an hour
this is not the game don't worry about
this what they both have about an hour
yeah this is kind of silly it's more 58.
this is the kind of stuff I'm talking
about like you're killing me go ahead
like in this position right yep
we go this is the position that we have
Bishop D4 King F5 yes that's the idea
hit the pawn okay that's how you
defended okay and you're not gonna make
progress after go King E6 so instead of
Defending it why don't you just try to
go forward say
whatever with the Pawns in the king side
I want to win I greedily I greedily try
if I take you can take on C6 and this is
the kind of positions where things start
you know sharpening up a little bit I
cannot take because in this position B7
does win okay Rook 8 according to the
engine is a draw but why take on on G5
in this position when you know that your
opponent wants to take exactly so you
could go something like this but then
you take anywhere you take you go V7 and
now we start have to calculating you
know what's going on in the second game
it ends up being a draw after Rook B3
King 66 Rook takes B6 uh yeah
everything's B7 you don't want to allow
Bishops of course blocking The Rook out
so it's still a draw uh almost no matter
where I look but there are a couple of
variations where you have to calculate
and if you don't like it that's white if
you want to try for more you gotta bail
out you you will have to bail out before
the white black starts taking your king
size pawns right exactly nice thank you
for that Alejandro and uh by the way
Fabi did play the move Rook C1 that it
had captured our attention for so long
we will see if Richie finds the
counter-intuitive King f8 I've got to
admit that King E8 was my first
impression and then you guys quickly
taught me we really don't know how easy
it is to just give up on G7 and H7 and
believe that you're completely fine and
in particular I think it's it's a it's a
move of a man either who failed to spot
king of f8 or a move of a man who is
doing well in the tournament and trusts
his own calculations on his own
assessments he's going to go with the
latter obviously yeah and and and
Rickard really isn't having that kind of
a tournament at all he's uh
it's yeah I was speaking only for myself
yeah if he's if he sees king of fight
he'll blinking effect but he's breaking
it yet
what a guy what a guy he's ready to
sacrifice his King side and once again
just let's take a look at that because
it's rather forcing after after
uh Fabi uh kaplunks yeah the C6 you just
have to go for it right this thread of
rookie seven and Bishop C5 is killer
there's no choice you've got to
sacrifice your king side and
my goodness uh you went Knight B1 uh
there's other options yeah there are
other options you can go Knight A4 9b2 I
don't know why that would be better than
I'd be one you could go Knight A4 Knight
B2 yeah I'm guessing B3 you're going
line B2 Bishop C1 I don't particularly
like I think Bishop C1 is a kind of a
strange move so B3
okay you have to play 9v2 here okay and
I think I would much rather block it on
the light Square rather than the dark
Square because
uh it's
I don't know maybe this is also not that
bad
going straight into it we're gonna have
to see because okay Bishop d8 you have
to play forced Force there it is and
there it is and there goes the king side
and the sequence is forced I mean what
else can white do right right you can
play Ruby seven enough for a drop but 5B
is not that kind of a player no I mean
no that's true Rook B7 is a possibility
yeah has uh linear blundered
King H7
no he has Knight G is he actually
planning to go Knight G2 there what just
a second he did Play the movie yeah King
H7 happened and then uh shark found a
very cute little idea of blink queen of
three before any of those moves happened
and now H3 linear played Rook G5 but now
after Rook F1 you cannot take on F5
because Bishop D3 wins the entire house
that is clear and this is not something
you can blunder either it's just like
it's the most obvious move in the
position so after Rook F1 the Knight is
attacked and it only has the G2 squares
he actually like is he playing to play
Knight G2 here yes
this is quite remarkable is he fine
slightly better no slightly better
Knight G2 it has threats I guess
there's something landing on G3 could be
uh yeah yeah white still within birdie I
I hate to say but White's still with an
equality range but it's white that's
actually the one under pressure here
remarkable because yeah Knight G2 Knight
H4 is a bit of a threat and you know you
have two pieces on the f file hitting
the F5 phone so unless you actually
capture this Knight this construction
looks ridiculous a little bit Yeah so
Knight G2 is force but good enough uh
not only that but shock only has the
move Rook F1 otherwise the moves Queen
F3 and H3 they're only weakening uh
towards his position
I'm
you know this is very unusual my mind is
my mind is resisting everything
except accept your new overlords so the
engine say something you accept it so
can we go I refuse to be assimilated
here tell me what tell me what's going
on here oh you're going Knight H I was
thinking you were playing Rook G3 sorry
index H5 is a Bit Stronger Yeah but
Knight H5 H4
uh Queen g3's company yeah you have to
play Queen of four but 26 might be
amazed disturbing yeah I feel a
disturbance in the well in the force
well Shaq didn't see it yesterday
perhaps he won't see it today uh uh no
wow can you play Rook D4 after that oh
come on come on come on Knight G2 it's
it's interesting about the 64 Square
chessboard there are certain squares
they're absolutely Prime squares for
Knights yeah
and G2 strangely enough
there's no one of them no no four is set
a four is but you do really where you're
fighting against two Bishops then the
fianchetto squares actually make sense
for the knights but Knight G2 and black
is for choice no I mean he's a choice
according to the engine it's zero zero
but I'll give you I'll give you the 10
gas game and you'll never get it really
actually you might eventually afternoon
yes afternoon
is the best move here for white okay and
now after 92 what do you play Queen not
only I can't do that no uh you were
about to say I wanted to go Queen G5 and
then I realized Knight E3 is a bit of a
problem
although Queen did no you can't do that
no
um
so we can chase the Knight to H5 and
then go Queen D5 right now
I looked at that yeah see the problem is
that you're trying to win no no no I'm
trying to make it
you're doing active moves you got to
prevent black from mating you on the
diagonal so the only move here is Bishop
D5
yeah I can I can see why that would be
yeah a moment ago I got mated on the
diet yeah and that's uh and that's I can
see that yeah
that yeah that's actually very sensible
thank God you know like yeah once you
see it struggling once you see it it's
kind of obvious but actually coming to
the move takes some you know
understanding a couple variations seeing
how dangerous this is actually for the
white king and that Bishop D5 is a good
defensive group and if I can ask you
Alejandro how is the time oh that these
two Flyers uh 29 minutes for shop five
minutes for oh sorry three minutes and
25 seconds this is move 35 though so
it's not as uh as horrible as all that
yeah and Shaq is I think uh coming to
some very unhappy conclusions because if
you that you know his previous moves
leading up to Bishop C4 and the rest he
was probably thinking you know I'm
pressing I'm pressing I you know I mean
I'm going to push and I my good luck
from yesterday and win my second game in
a row and he gets to this position he
says I I don't want to point out by the
way that uh this is the the I do this
looking shirt that Shah one won the game
in yesterday on our previous
conversation Friday the 13th yeah we can
only assume that he has 13 different
yeah he probably has a bunch of them
like you you do buy them in Balkans
I prefer thinking about that about chess
players than seeing them wearing the
same shirt
or possibly a walk of shame implications
here also also very possible yeah yeah I
love it uh the the the the chess player
is a Shopping Guide always buying both
Peterson
maybe principles and uh hoping to join
our conversation or is somebody in our
audience uh Peter let's go
we're from pranav uh favorite world
championship moment
s
good question favorite I don't I don't
really know how to answer this well
there was a couple of months from me
one uh was really really shocking the
Seville uh it is a Seville uh a couple
of things happened in Seville the first
thing that happened was the match was
eleven and a half
it was 11 11 with two games to go
and not too much had been going on and
then suddenly and uh very very
shockingly for the Chess World Gary
Kasparov has lost game 23. yeah and uh
he has to win game two in a very
dramatic fashion as well yeah because we
he uh in a very rare case for him he
basically I think straight up forgot
what what he and his second analyze
after the adjournment I think the entire
thing with Rooker 3 being refuted by
Bishop H6 he knew about and then at the
board somehow it just kind of
disappeared from his right from his mind
and I remember uh from 1992 sweaty stuff
Stefan uh speaking with Bobby Fischer
Bobby Fischer says you know every game
of every move every game of their
matches between Kasparov they were fixed
these guys were criminals it was
terrible terrible terrible so really
Bobby yeah yeah yeah I said well explain
to me about Seville he says what what is
there to explain
so you know the it's scripted right yeah
so I said to Bobby you you got to give
the guy the script
and uh you know there's a knock on the
door but karpov opens it up I win I win
this is brilliant this is really I'm so
happy because why do I have to lose you
know and then they have to play you know
the script and then comes game 24 and
you know carp off why do I have to lose
you think that's the way it happened I
was wondering whether you were going to
go there but you just kind of went went
there without a single moments get
stationed so let's talk about it let's
talk about this now that we're here uh
any of uh the the conspiracy theories
about Seville have existed for I mean
not everybody when the whole the whole
hog is in like every single match
was was fixed but uh Seville conspiracy
theory theories definitely exist but for
me they always break down with exactly
this
someone has to lose a game first right
and Trust his opponents to lose the next
one and
their relationship in 87. wasn't that
hard no it really wasn't that great I
know if I just get to that point and I
think to myself you know even if I were
willing to you know you know subscribe
to this view of the world right it just
completely breaks down there because
like there's just no trust no chance
there's there's no trust and like why
why would you subject yourself to that
situation it doesn't work for me the
other one that was for me was very very
funny was their very first match of the
2ks because power of karpov 1984 this
match went indefinitely that was the
aborted match and that the 48 games no
result and they were playing in I
believe it was the Hall of columns
and uh Soviet leaders kept dying
so they had to postpone games so that
people could get married in this
beautiful place and there was something
I just found hilariously ridiculous
about that I just couldn't stop laughing
at my friend
um Jonathan Tisdale
he went to Moscow for Reuters and he
ended up being in Moscow for six months
I said six months I said Jonathan what
happened he said well I lost my
girlfriend I lost my apartment and I
learned Russian
because these were the Great Moments of
world championship match history yeah I
don't know jumping Alejandro if you have
something that really kind of tickled
your funny bone about world championship
matches I didn't know we were going for
funny I was going for something that
impacted me but
I think I'm going to decide to like not
share that story considering considering
our panel okay
because it was like I was very inspired
by what happened the events that
happened I was a kid I was watching with
some of the other top players it was a
2004 World Championship we're all very
excited we're huddled around a computer
together Shaka Madras forget kariakin
we're all like watching in the on the
computer before our round because we
were playing The Olympian at the same
time yeah
but I think we're gonna stop the story
thing because I know we're I think we
don't know Peter knows where this is
going I mean I mean this is not Disney
Channel yeah I mean I've been I've been
teased about this for for so long that I
I am but I I would like to think I've
become impervious to it but but not
really it was such an inspiring story
right like the engine and the Seconds
come up with this an idea for kramnik
and it's a super sharp Marshall and like
it just sits down and he sits down and
he calculates out of it and he
calculates better than the seconds and
the engines and everything and wins a
brilliant game with the black pieces and
for me to take the leader so impactful
like wow this guy really trusts himself
and how how diligent he was at the board
and we're trying to calculate I was
trying to calculate this with shock and
Sergey uh we're actually watching that
live and we were like what is he doing
what is he doing and then we're like is
it mate is it actually mate and it was
and for me it was a spectacular moment
and and then for a personal like roller
coaster of emotions for me
I was watching the game between Favi and
Magnus
and it was the game
if I was an extra piece trying to win
trying to win trying to win it's not
getting there it's not getting there and
at some point I'm just like I'm so tired
I've been you know working as a second
and I'm just like offhand watching the
game and watching TV at the same time
this is my break time supposedly right
I'm not supposed to watch the game but I
mean let's be real everybody does uh and
at some point it's just as made on 34.
right and I'm like
that was a sad moment for me but I mean
that was a full of emotions I remember
that moment yeah we're calling it here
in uh Saint Louis and I was saying
I think the extra piece I think fabby's
going to win and Maurice is saying no no
zero zero zeros and there was this chess
engine super engine from Norway what was
I think the table basis did it but sassy
is
well I remember specifically CeCe
Maurice had it the Ceci engine and then
like you say CeCe says Maiden 34 and
whatever it was yeah and I couldn't even
get close I think that requires I think
maybe I do I did that match with Gusty
from uh from Hamburg offices and I was
also doing game of the day Recaps and I
think that that end game
with the extra piece yeah I I I I think
I did a very decent job of trying to
explain why was we winning for black
and
as as a sort of a joke goes you know a
professor says to his students
why are you so stupid like I've already
explained it three times I even
understood it myself by this point I
came close to understanding it myself by
the by the end of the recording of the
video and I still missed some details
and I remember I woke up next morning
and I thought Hmm this line was not
included in the video and now I don't
understand why it's reading yet again
okay it's just that was just such a
selfie such a confusing game yeah and I
loved the comment that was made by vishi
Anand he said they asked him would you
have won this game Vichy because Fabi
didn't he said no
I would not I I that would have been a
draw however
if at the moment that the wind was
possible if you would tap me on the
shoulder and said right now now you have
to calculate
he said then I think I could force
myself to do yeah but if but it required
that even then yeah but that is that is
a very common theme where basically uh
the conversation about people you know
engine assistance in general uh you
always feel like what is required is for
somebody to actually tell you what the
best move is when in fact for strong
chess players exactly what you're
describing what visha was describing
there is
plenty enough just being informed of
what the critical moment is no further
hints right just somebody stops you and
says now please don't autopilot right
just dig deep because now there is
something here that is much better than
everything else and that's enough yeah
that in most cases that will be enough
for for strong chess players uh
continuing with the viewers question and
greatest uh world championship match
games ever for me the Moscow match with
Knight D3 Kasparov is that definitely is
very high on the list
that's like just off the chart Bobby
Fischer although although some of the
sites have played in the same match I I
very very much like because like the no
that's actually not the same that's the
next match yeah right because it also
like the best of them is also weirdly
game 16. yeah the the the octopus on D3
is game 16 fantastic and I think in the
in their next match
arguably the best the best sites of
Kasparov ever ever won against was also
game 16 where he's sacrifice yeah well
he gave him back in the house great uh
one of the well let's get Romania uh to
jump in on this conversation too uh
unless they have something else to share
over to you Christian
thank you uh Yasser yeah you guys were
mentioning a lot of very interesting and
funny uh stories from the world
championship match and I have some
experience Anastasia has also some
experience as well so we wanted to uh
jump right into it so I let Anastasia
say what was your favorite moment from a
world championship match
um I'm not sure it was my favorite one
but I think it was very the moment which
many people remember the press
conference which never happened and when
Marcus Carlson world champion ran away
after he lost the game against Sergey
correct in the New York I mean that was
really an interesting moment and I
remember myself thinking that okay now
he's running from the press conference
what will happen now and we'll know what
happened after but I still have
sometimes dreams about it I can tell you
so and there were of course many other
moments but Christian I know that you've
been to 2018 World Championship Match I
remember that you were at that time a
manager and the coach of Fabiano right I
was so I was indeed in the coaching
staff of Fabiano in London I was there
with kasim qasim janov and the biggest
story of course outside of the games
being played the match was about the
leak the famous League of the opening
preparation of Fabiano and I remember it
was 7 A.M in the morning and we saw that
and we got that information and I was
with qasim Journal waiting for Fabiano
to come and get ready for the game and
we were pondering this question what are
we going to do are we going to tell him
about it are we going to just let it go
uh in the end he came we decided not to
tell him before the game just so that we
don't uh disrupt anything we decided
that we're going to continue playing
whatever we were planning on uh playing
and Fabiano came and he seemed
unaffected by anything that was a huge
surprise because I thought that he will
check his Twitter he will check his
Instagram and everybody will bombard him
with those questions and and he went on
he played the game very easy draw
absolutely no problem
um but the thing is that once he
finished we knew that he's going to be
asked about that in the conference so I
had to run immediately as he finished
from the hotel to I sprinted all the way
to the plane hole to catch him right
before he entered
um at the conference to tell him that
there was something that happened I had
to explain him very quickly he was
completely uh distorted by uh by by this
news but he went on very professionally
he answered questions and uh that was it
it was a very intense day for us I have
to say and funny moment is from the game
of Magnus versus Vichy when Vichy had
this winning moment and then Magnus knew
that Vichy has this winning moment and
immediately as Vision played uh the move
that wasn't the best move and left
Magnus off the hook Magnus just
collapsed completely he was like oh
thank God that was uh that was one of
the most intense at least from a
Watcher's perspective yeah and actually
Peter Fiddler was talking about this
moment he wasn't such at that time he
was one of the commentators and they
missed this moment and I remember myself
also that everybody was talking about it
and we asked them of course about it
after the the games during the press
conference yes of course I think it was
the most important moment of the whole
match which of course which she missed
at that time yeah and of course I
remember 2013 World Championship Match
in India when everybody was crying that
if she was losing that match and some
funny questions during the press
conference as well I mean and it was so
intense there were so many people there
were there was police you know stopping
people from jumping to the stage trying
to touch Rishi who is the of course a
hero in the country and many many other
moments as well I mean World
Championships world championship match
matches are so great events and I'm sure
that many people really like to follow
them always intense always filled with a
lot of stories but we do have a lot of
games still pending so let's jump right
into it with you guys in the studio and
saying this well thank you so much first
of all beautiful additions to all of our
comments and it does go to show that we
that there's a wonderful culture this
tradition uh the enjoyment of world
championship matches is elevated chess
to that art form that we really really
do love and that's why Magnus
potentially not playing the match would
be such a sorrowful uh um thing for uh
chess lovers I just wanted to I just
wanted to just briefly say that is my
favorite addition to to to do any kind
of a conversation like this is you know
for a given definition off and uh
Anastasia there mentioned funny
questions to division during press
conferences yeah for for a given
definition of funny yeah
very important yeah
[Laughter]
what's going on in our tournament
co-leaders games uh Alejandro things are
going wrong for Livonia I haven't been
able to check it or enthralled in the
conversation but I was just going down
the list and the engine is hating what
he's done so far not many moves yet King
F5 is what we were all expecting I
thought okay King F5 you try to take
this Pawn yes I understand that C6 is
going to be hanging many positions but
for the moment this is a pin that's not
that's how chess works and we've noticed
variations where you give up The Rook
you pick up G5 and then you have you
force G5 G4 through and that is the end
of the pawns for white that's the end of
the winning chances but he went the
other way
he went to D6 wow and after Bishop G7 I
guess he didn't find the move the
engines are thinking you should go back
uh but after Bishop F6 it's obviously an
improved version right for white because
now you've already defended your pot on
G5 you said it was King D7 what yeah
nepo said okay Bishop E5 I'm committing
your Pawn give me that pawn the only
explanation I have because the problem
with Rook here is that simply Knight D3
Cuts your Rook from the attack of F3 you
would have to go check and you still
have survival chances here yeah yeah the
engines are not like super lost here but
perhaps he wants to place that C5 ticks
and Rook A3 and hit the pawn this way
but after Knight D5 Rook F3 Knight
attacks F4 you're hitting this Pawn on
um on G6 and if you go to Rook G3 Bishop
F6 anchors that pawn on F6 so the angels
are thinking this is dead loss you
actually have to find the move
shocking move Rook D3 so that you lose a
tempo
wow that's here and here you have Rook
at five remarkable finding this no is
boss chair hard very hard but the edges
are still are thinking it's coming down
to calculation for Levon they don't
think that he's played appropriately in
the last couple of moves and one more
misstep is all it will take for Napa to
take this wobbly game home
wow uh crazy and they're and see if I
played C5 played C5 played maybe a
Desperado but necessary it's a good move
right Rook A3 is definitely the only
idea
and now Knight D5 that's going to be the
tricky one right right
it's kind of an amazing Knight D5 Rook
D3 looks wrong or something I really
don't know I really don't understand why
we can't take one of three and I don't
know go Rook F1 there giving giving the
tempo that way I guess F3 is for some
reason the absolute best Square for The
Rook but I have no idea what that would
be the case like why is it so so much
better than F3 than it is on F1
but computers generally have reasons for
saying these outlandish things exactly
it might just be a king D5 and we're
eventually going to just uh snack on
this pond
yeah I can imagine that's the issue but
it is outlandish to me as well Rook D3
that would be
a remarkable movie I I don't know if you
can play this yeah it just it just feels
like something that
by the way it's completely inhuman I
mean I I have the engine in front of me
I'm asking the engine I still don't
understand it but the idea is
I mean if you call it an idea yeah that
if you take on F3 here yep
from the start right now and then you
take on F4 and you're you are let's go
Rook of one yeah yeah go Rook F1 and I
go King D5 right yes logical move
here you want to actually have
your Rook on F3 yeah but why
I don't know yeah
I don't know man I was trying I'm trying
you know that he was going to give us
the answer to the mysteries of the
universe and then he just stopped and
said I don't know yeah you you this is a
mutual I mean I have I have no idea why
at the moment but this position the
angels are considering a mutualism plus
three with black to move plus one with
white to move so
Peter well sorry with the Rook on F1 I
had the wrong position yeah yeah uh but
it's saying here white doesn't have a
good way of making progress
but with the Rook on F3 I guess you have
King E4 attacks so yeah so we don't we
don't actually have a good Tempo here
with Blacklist Rook F3 loses to King E4
Rook F2 loses to King E4 as well I guess
because we don't have we don't have Ruby
too yeah if you go Rook F2
then I can't play Bishop you get the
point if you get this position you don't
have a rugby two hitting the pawn the
bishop is controlling yeah we just lost
the G6 Pawn for nothing
yeah it will cost the game that I got
that part I got and it's it's like
really far from the end yeah Knight D5
play D5 and now Vaughn will be tested
severely right here really because I I
think I think I think on F3
and then you know the other question the
other question that you do have to
address is why not Rook A5 check and I
think this one I worked out because it
looks for a second there The Rook A5
check uh trying to drive the the king
away from the light pieces and then go
King E6 is very strong but white goes
King D4
white goes King D3 and specifically in
this setup after King E6 there is Knight
C3 and then everybody's and then every
yeah everything gets stabilized the
bishop goes to C7 or C7 pardon me yeah
b67 C7 I shouldn't D4 is not not bad at
all yeah for 90 seconds yeah yeah that
plays itself that is nice C6 Pawn just
got extracted what I want to say is iFly
what is thinking about something here
it's to choose between Rook F3 and Rook
A5 check not really I I I don't think
Rook D3 comes into the conversation at
all like I just don't believe that that
is that is a study-like move yeah wow I
mean lots of developments and and some
of the other games as well specifically
in the mvl game somehow mvl after lots
of Adventures have gotten themselves
into a rook and partner end game where
he's a pawn up and yeah just go G5 here
I I like G5
that is a fine move of course and that
would that I think G5 only ends the game
everything else allows MBL to pretend
for another I don't know 20 more exactly
not really yeah not really the moment he
moved the Rook from G4 I'll go G5 then
yeah yeah that as well good point but G5
immediately there it is yeah yeah and we
have it on the board and so that game
will be drawn
um again uh another game
where Richie pardon me where
Fabi I wanted to say has made some very
very serious progress Richie sacrificed
his kingside in order to get a pass Pawn
to B3 but guess what it's nicely
blockaded any ideas by black to play
Move for example like Bishop A3 you're
about to be met with Rook check which is
why Richie played the move this uh
stutter step with Rook B6 rugby seven so
that he can play Bishop A3 but now after
Bishop yeah and very cleverly king of
fate trying to drive the Rook away it
went to H3 and now we have Knight takes
F4
which is very important and this I guess
is what holds the game for Richard here
we have another photo before check yeah
exactly I just I I blanked out I thought
and this one is expected
yeah so MBA mvl fails to win a very
important game and Daniel uh continues
to impress yeah continuously very very
impressive yeah you made it look easy
yeah very solid performance continued
very very solid performance from the
from the Romania yeah yeah okay Bishop
takes F4 pardon me I wanted to say and
the whole idea is that after takes we do
have a skew you can go King C3 King B3
but once this structure gets broken up
you you get the feeling black holds very
very comfortably it's so clear for
instance you're just not worse really
exactly and it's not even worse
wow okay let's go to the shotgun because
they have one move left and that's all
they have this game should end in a
drawing but shock has one move to make
Lanier didn't find the absolute best
continuation but did continue like a
human being would and now you see the
Rooks are off how did that happen yeah
and that was a very cute idea there I I
noticed yeah and this specifically in
this position instead of Rogue G3 uh
there is a very cute tactical energy I
don't know how much time it hit I if we
if we are to trust the clocks on leeches
head four minutes so I would say it was
maybe on four minutes for linear I think
it's a findable tactic yeah which does
give him a bit of a nature I don't know
if it's a winning Advantage but you can
play Knight H4 in this position a move
which Queen E4 seems to have been aimed
specifically at stopping right but yeah
uh not really stopping it at all because
of Queen 6 check here which just uh
delivers made on a long diagonal exactly
and yeah white would have to play
accurately here and not to uh not to run
into a lot of trouble I kind of missed
it with Rook G3 because now Rook F3 he's
still completely fine but he's no longer
really better because Bishop takes F7
exists I think mainly for the reason the
bishop takes himself he doesn't play it
he played Queen E4 wow that's only worse
yeah
he's playing to play F6 check and queen
E7 or something that's that's absurd
well I'm sorry that's a way of putting
yeah absurdism maybe a bit strong but
sir absurd why don't you take here
I mean it's just a draw I think he wants
to play for a win yeah he wants to play
for a win yeah he could because I think
after Bishop of seven I saw the engine
just blinking H6 and and saying nothing
much is happening yeah but you can take
off yeah in human in human terms you
just take on F7 take on B3 right yeah
and the game ends yeah gotcha the
Queenie before it might be as we say
playing for a loss oh he's definitely
playing for a loss after Knight takes H3
he is lost he's in deep trouble deep
trouble let's see what he missed
I think he probably wanted I mean F6 has
to be the idea right I think the only
the only explanation is of six King H6
and then something maybe he missed I
mean you don't miss Knight G5 after 23
check also neither four exists like all
moves there are very strong so maybe
Queen is seven here
but it just doesn't look right I mean
yeah I like it yeah it looks what was
the word absurd yeah
which doesn't look right at all and uh I
I get the feeling it might lose by force
to Queen 27 Queen G3 I was trying to
calculate it it gets to a very curious
enemy you don't see very often but sorry
yeah sure should be in the position
there's three F6 King H6 Queen E7 I go
Queen G3
and you're threatening not the only move
but yeah you you give a check from a
fate I go King G5 you're threatening
mate in one which means that white has
to make G5 if you give a check from a G7
H4 annoyingly here white still has a
bishop yeah you you take take
you take take on G3 you take on F7 I go
Knight F2 Knight G4 take on F6 I'm not
sure you're making a draw there maybe
you are but it's kind of scary well are
you sure you're making a draw I don't
think you are because it's a Tempo on
the bishop I know but like I go Bishop
D1 sadly for black black doesn't have uh
doesn't have popped up on my screen to
suggest we're in a table base yeah and
and what does it say Peter I can't
figure it out yeah
I will go with this is good for uh for
for linear let's jump over to uh uh
Bucharest uh with Christian and our
local hero Daniel
thank you uh Yasser I am here with the
number one Romanian player Bogdan Daniel
deck after a very solid performers in
his game against mvl uh Bogdan welcome
back to the studio uh tell us a bit
about this game you played him last year
with the black pieces and you actually
won uh that game how did you approach
today's game okay first of all think for
the Edition
uh this year I try to pay a bit more
solid I play Petros
you switch things up a little bit yes
was he surprised did you feel like he
was surprised at all or he was expecting
no he he expected this line
he come with Bishop E3
it took on C4 and he was playing Ultra
fast up to this point one hour and 35
minutes did you feel at all uh insecure
at this point about your preparation
about the position or were you still
feeling very confident
okay I don't remember exactly what I
need to pay but I try to pay normal
moves okay I can't wait right not more
move not the best button or more move
95 Queen C7
okay
here 93 is a normal move at all
just developing the pieces makes perfect
sense
I took on C3 take into B5
here I can play Knight C5 first okay 21
and come back with Bishop probably
something around equal this position so
it's very balanced as well but you
decided to go with B5 B5 is not a bad
move at all okay Bishop D3 is not a
normal movement because I take take and
take a check give up the pawn and I
guess the computer wants to say that
after this you have some compensation of
the array for maybe even more than
compensation but still not very human
yes
so he played this move Bishop to F1 did
he played fast or
it did seem like he thinks
were you surprised that he did not take
the uh very adventurous round after
Bishop D3 but decided to play the
conservative okay here I expected Bishop
F1
and coming Knight yes
Queen D1 and
here if I play 1987 Queen F3
okay and you were concerned about this
it's something a bit unpleasant for me
after Bishop to H2 King H1 now you have
to lose some more time and D5 is coming
here I calculate something like this
bishop G5 Bishop D5 BTC is what I want
but doesn't work check
and take that's a deep calculation and
after you take
here I can take GIF gf3 or King H2 here
white is better equal points for the
moment but a big imbalance in the
structure as well as the two Bishops it
does seem like what is better at this
yes so let's go back to the games
continuation you played Bishop E6 and
now you guys started exchanging
something interesting for me is to play
Rook deep first
coming queen in G6
okay probably
queen of three or queen H6 yes and take
you know if it takes back with what if
he takes with the bishop
here we can take and Rook D5 in some
good move because here white can treat
Rook H5 okay so for example if you just
make a let's say a random move a rook H5
might be problematic of course black
still has some defense with the queen
but obviously if you take that's a
Checkmate in one that's the only pattern
aggressive pattern that white can employ
so you guys started exchanging uh pawns
uh did you at all have any problems
after that or it was just pretty
straightforward okay probably in the
game I can play good but he can try
to take first the first Bishop E4 keep
more pieces on the board yes
and what was uh your planned response
after this
okay here I can play many moves I don't
probably to come with bishop and Bitcoin
okay Bishop B7 but I need to be careful
here you need to be a bit careful but
still the position quite balanced uh
Bogdan a very good result up to this
point for you in the tournament 50
that's not bad you're going to finish up
with a big match against Fabiano caruana
how are you going to approach that match
to play a good game play a good game
with the white pieces Bogdan thank you
very much for joining us we're looking
forward to see your game tomorrow thank
you for the invitation guys back to you
thank you Christian thank you Daniel for
joining us uh we have got the the the
game between Ian and levana's got our
complete attention as Lavon uh in big
trouble at this moment and you can sense
it just by his body posture as he's
realizing he's a as Tom said I'm really
shocked a big big shout out to Tom you
know
yeah and I shall actually a mutual which
is even rare and it's a second one in
this tournament there was there was one
earlier in the game between uh livon and
alireza at some point in that pawn
ending
it was actually a position of a mutual
sexual and for those of you who perhaps
have not heard the term it's a Tucson is
normally a situation where a side does
not have a good move but a much much
rarer situation of a mutual is a
situation where nobody wants to move
right yeah like it's uh whoever you give
the move to would like to pass it back
right right it's funny that you say that
about a zuk Swang it's a situation where
a side doesn't have a good move because
that's not the way I I've always thought
of zuk Swang I've always thought of zuk
Swang as a position where a side has to
make yeah exactly that deteriorates
their position like their pieces are
their their their Apex and now you don't
want to move because any move makes it
worse yeah yeah and this is it would be
true for for both white and black in
this position but yeah it's completely
unrecognizable from a distance maybe
levonne realizes it now but it's also
it's also really not a question you ask
yourself you in a practice game you
don't really concern yourself with the
question of what will happen if it was
wide to move here because white is not
to move here right but yeah apparently
this is the conclusion we come to from
analyzing this with with the engines is
that was extremely important fully one
to give up a Tempo there by not taking
one of three straight away but it's just
you you can't do that I don't think and
here the point is if that it was white
to move white wants to take this 36 here
because but that is going to be answered
by the move Rook F5 so as Alejandro was
explaining the situation to me he's
saying that Black's Rook wants to be
able to play Rook F5 the problem if we
can play Rook F2 or Rook F3 sorry Peter
go ahead yeah but it also needs needs a
check from behind you need to be able to
give a check to the King on e4 exactly
you also and that's why you want your
Rook ideally on the F1 Square which the
computer is now suggesting that since
the Rook can't move
and the King can't move to to yeah this
is another good Square because 96 is a
check with the check and if you go King
E8 you allow King E6 and then white you
will have to give up the B6 spawn after
let's say Rook C1 but it doesn't matter
because the G Pawn becomes well it costs
like a rook C1 here or a B1 it doesn't
really matter I guess I could take on G6
even this is completely winning I'm
pretty sure I take on G6
Knight goes to some squares I mean the
the engine likes Knight H4 Knight F5 the
most but I don't think it matters a
great deal and then the g-pawn just
costs like a full Rogue and then you get
to demonstrate your technique of giving
mate with the Knight and Bishop but have
you ever had to do it over the board no
I don't think I think people Blitz yes
but never uh I don't I don't think even
in Blitz anybody checked honestly really
yeah I think I've been checked online
but only online only online I've not
yeah and I know that we have had one
famous example where it was not done
properly over the board but online I've
seen it botched up
more than once yeah yeah and then I
think
I wasn't naming any names yeah the the
interesting bit about this uh this end
game is uh you know there are some
records potentially uh and I think Ralph
was at one point and wow thank you uh
Ralph at one point was kind of doing
doing prop bets that he will do it in 10
seconds
yeah I actually was very impressed with
how easy it is it's something I learned
as a kid and I never retouched and I was
thinking okay practically maybe this is
not so easy and then I was having a
conversation with Mark Arnold
Grandmaster Mark Arnold and he said what
are you talking about I can do this
inside 30 seconds every single time and
I don't think he checked with me using
more than 15. starting from the middle
of the board like he just boom boom boom
boom like checkmated me every single
time night ambition versus alone King
apparently it's pretty easy if you just
spend enough time doing pattern yeah you
just have to get the pattern down right
but you know sometimes it's been you
know 25 years since you saw the pattern
and you don't remember very well but
yeah it's pretty it won't be checked
it's just that yeah I don't think I
don't think any game between between uh
Jan and Levitt gets checked honestly I
think I think they just kind of uh left
you know the moment the G6 Pawn
disappears off the board like the game
the game and and it's clear that why it
actually wins yeah uh Queens the Jeep on
the game the game just stops he played
something he played Rook G4 but now King
E4 uh saruka three but not King E4 hits
uh hits that rook and the pawn on G6 is
uh is gone
and for Wesley I mean Wesley's back at
his hotel rooting Yan on like you know
this is great for me uh that uh janev
you know providing a great contribution
to Wesley's campaign by First losing to
him with black and then beating his
director
exactly and there we have uh two games
uh from this around a championship round
in the books
uh we have two draws and this is uh with
three games remaining
of course with free games remaining but
for Lavon Lavon loses this game yeah he
will be tied with Mexi yeah he will be
talking with maximum in second and third
and Wesley will be once again very
comfortably and clear first on plus two
uh playing
uh black against linear yes possibly
white again
yeah yeah speaking of Lanier he is no
longer better what but
I think practically he's better
but the engines don't think he's better
after the move Queen D4 check he was
supposed to looking good he had to
repeat according to the end and then
take on H3 again if it's three and again
if it's presented to him take on H3
don't play the move King G7
what are these Grand Masters doing so
but it was kind of curious that he
doesn't repeat and say I have more time
now I can now analyze this position more
thoroughly so Shaq does not take a pawn
like okay I refer first of all you know
I'm tasered and I'm trying to get over
that you know uh then Lanier doesn't
take a pawn okay this is this is move
forward and he did not have that much
time and he thought okay I'm still
better at thinking G7 let's not get
involved with any kind of calculations
even though it's difficult to understand
there's no exactly exactly like on a
terrible day there's no sequel right
like you get an end game in which we're
not really sure white survives right I
barely maybe yeah maybe not but he must
have thought his Knight is really good
and goes into this position Queen D4 and
here you have to go King H7 and I'm kind
of curious that he didn't go King H7 and
like recheck some lines because Bishop
F7 is clearly impossible here you just
made it and since you have this mate
thread I can only imagine shock would
play them if we need for but let's sit
down now that you have 30 minutes
because you cross time control and now
you can you know start start new because
you know King G7 he'll play Queen D4
yeah and maybe have something better I
think that the reasoning here is that I
don't think it's obvious why he's not
better here like I I I'm still alive I
mean F7 F6 yeah I know the engine is
kind of silly
um I actually completely miss queen you
want yeah Queen G1 is important it needs
black black is very active you need to
tie him down Queen C6 Queen G2 is also
such a big deal in the position that you
need to do something yeah and after King
H6 it goes uh
three and yeah this is kind of an
awkward 25
and there's a mate down here downstairs
Queen E5 yeah Queen E5 and
it solidifies somehow
uh can I weirdly I get the feeling you
just play Bishop B6 yeah and honestly
optically this looks lost for white
because they don't take the bishop yeah
but you can't make I'm guessing you
can't make progress because you can get
the queen with the with the sort of the
ladder checks you go A1 B2 C1 D2 and so
on you can get the queen to E2 but you
still but you still don't create any
threads because you don't have time yeah
because your King on H6 is compromised
enough that like you get all the way
here and you still don't win I assume
right yeah that's the line that's what
the engine say Bishop B6 when they move
at the end of that variation and you can
never touch the bishop because Queen G6
I guess you can also kind of understand
that and we have Queen G1 Queen G1 King
H6 he has to play Queen anymore that's
the only move but that one I think is
pretty clear yep because you'd want to
pin the Knight you don't want this
Knight hopping around I understand that
there's mate currently on G6 so the
knight's gonna be popping around soon
but you are worried that Queen c624 Is
Gonna Come the move Queen G3 just
tethers the Knight forever so I think
that's a very logical one the difficult
thing is understanding you're totally
fine after Vision yes I'd be I'd be so
scared here with why like my first
impression here would be something yeah
you know Queen and Knight left
completely sort of uh uh unchallenged
you know the bishop only six is uh which
which which kind of brings up the
question everybody I mean let's say we
get to this position we can get through
between two moves instead of five
exactly 24 seconds all right I was just
gonna say okay I go Queen D2 and don't I
you force your Bishop to move or
something uh any anything to be said for
this
definitely a decent try yeah just that's
a good question yeah if you do go Bishop
E6
and then I
I would probably yeah if the f500 the
only thing you're doing is challenging
me to find a move right precisely yeah
something like Queen G8
Queen G8 you're giving away Fearless see
it's seriously Fearless
absolutely giving away well I go check I
don't have that many choices yeah I
don't check now if you go here don't I
win I think I think which one H3 was
checks yeah
that's was we win H3 was checks and I
mean how happy are you about this is
remains to be seen right yeah but
yeah because you have actually cringey
far at the end just once again yeah yeah
that doesn't work so yeah there's a
question actually yeah just trying to uh
and if you play h3h4 here which was my
first idea I'm kind of worried Queen G4
exactly I'm kind of worried about let's
say queen D1 Queen into Queen G4 and
once again how happy am I trading Queens
in this position maybe not yeah but I
guess Queen G4 we can go I don't know
kingy two one king H2 and sort of pass
for now really well now that I not now
that there's no Checkmate I feel that my
knight could go on hopping uh go on an
adventure
both sides that are going on an
adventure because if you go 92 it takes
takes Bishop C4
it
I don't see why White's losing 94. King
g3u are in some trouble I don't know if
you make a draw or not but you're in
some trouble there because 93 checks
yeah 93 exists yeah exists as a problem
yeah I thought king of four but then
9605 I don't think you should do this no
uh so there are issues still to be a
question still to be answered I
apologize but I did want to go back to
the the game of Lavon because it's so
crucial something's really weird
happened there standing uh yeah and
engine approved because the variations
that we were thinking with King E4 take
on G6 win straight up win and the I just
are saying you know what
this was easier
this one's easy this was easier uh you
don't give up the B6 Pawn with the move
King E4 if we can go back to that
position on your board yeah this is
exactly the moment that we thought that
uh
yeah and if you're looking for Rook B3
somehow it picks up the B6 Pawn because
if you go Bishop C7 I have Rook B5 I
think and then how do you defend G5
while winning G6 right well we don't
like I wanted to say and you don't and
it's winning I agree with everything
you're saying Rook B3 you just take on
G6 and you're happy enough in that
position that is winning but if you
calculate it out the way that Napo seems
to have done you actually win G6 without
giving up B6
well that's even a better deal that's a
better deal yeah so engine approved they
think that this is great uh it takes
longer to get to the pawn but Rook G1
uh Rook G1
I'm just I think I go check on Bishop F4
you go check and Bishop F4 oh that's it
from ah but you have uh I have King E8
yeah the Fabi game will be will be drawn
in the number game is being drawn I've
got a handshake alert okay we'll take on
that five come on yeah don't don't be
don't be checking this yeah
and there we go and a draw between a
fighting oh it's yeah that's the thing
about the decisive number of games when
you were opening the show Alejandro and
you're saying 34 yes but what fighting
content uh on those 66 that we had
another example going on right there
between those two competitors uh this is
marvelous marvelous for yeah
for nepo this is
no he's clearly made progress but I'm
still very confused why you would like
the position often it takes G6 domain
King E4 and 96 seemed so winning to my
eyes that I'm I'm really unsure why
we're subjecting ourselves to this why
we have to fancy play yeah why is fancy
play necessary this is this is the it's
a different uh different uh you know
fake chess quote this is kind of greed
is good type approach right to you you
really don't want to give up any of your
stuff like you're preserving the B6 Pawn
we haven't won the G6 spawn yet but at
this point one to C6 Pawn we we we had
the same ending we just extracted a
black pawn from the C6 Square
so it's true so let's see five King C8
played is he intending to go Knight C5
Kings 194 like a knight E4 King G7 uh
check is even more annoying right well
no I think I'm making a b line to the F6
Square I think he missed King E6 right I
thought King E6 was clever there on the
previous move
King E6 was clever because Rook G5
Knight E4 actually give mate which is
useful in chess in general
that is a good idea well I'm sorry what
was the line afterwards we we expected
King E6 or pardon me p24 he played 94
yeah yes and we were wondering why why
we didn't play King E6
what about check on
yeah I just keep checking Marucci one
here I guess right
because yeah checking I mean I go king
of 16 G6 I'm very happy I'm sorry but
why are you happy like rookie one
working F6 Rook F1 I don't get it pardon
me are there stalemist thing oh okay
sorry I missed it completely rookie one
Desperado Rook happens at some point
yeah
six check although I don't know
the crazy Rook yeah the desperate yeah
more more terms for football for Tom to
put on it actually doesn't work here I
don't think it works actually can you
run you run to F5 it doesn't work yeah
King H5 here Rook H6 check King G4
checking of three and then I will either
take on a four with the Bishops yeah
yeah and when you take importantly when
you give a check on F4 Bishop takes I'm
being told that shock has blunder let's
go check out this game between linear
this car's been
up and down Queen G8 played immediately
and the engines hated let me try to
figure out why well Queen E5 there's no
threat to begin you've created no
threats on after Queen E5 you will no
longer be able to protect the opponent
F5 I would assume yeah this point isn't
defensible but can I start checking you
but are you just driving me towards H4
I'm just going to give mate with all of
my pieces like on H4 there are no no
that's a pretty safe king that's a
pretty good King on H4 you're still
dropping this you're dropping Queen you
want I really really don't understand
what's happening no I despise that
because yeah this is just like yeah
Queen E5 is that yeah I mean five your
king is weak as we as we explained like
the understanding that the position with
Queen G3 and Bishop B6 is holdable it
might take might take a bit right but
you you do have to understand that this
one is completely lost in about three
seconds flat because you're not really
creating a single threat and after Queen
E5 black will have threats immediately
so yeah absolutely very very confusing
misplay by uh the the king the black
king will be ultra safe on H4 and Lanier
recognize his opportunities just pounced
I just read Queen E5 I don't know how to
explain this and instantly she just
resigns yeah instantly handshake he
resigned he just resigned yeah Shaq just
said ugh
my bad
okay then
as a chess competitor he sort of had
this look that said oh my dick my job is
easy
and what here is lost because he
resigned immediately
Alejandro had really prepared a great
speech there thank you I had Oracle of
wisdom no in all seriousness this is
just such a confusing end of the game
is confusing I I haven't figured out how
Nick was winning uh oh yeah yeah I I
don't get it like 90 95 94 when your
night was directly directly attacking
the phone on G6 that was beautiful right
right like your night was on F4
attacking this guy and we have King f4
on the board now okay let's go check I
really really I'm very excited many
things
assuming King I mean if you go this way
but
okay let's say okay let me put it on my
board for just a second so we go Rook F1
okay all we really need to do now all we
really need is to bring our Knight to E5
excellent very good so or three-time POA
so I'll go King G4 very good I like this
move
I don't know what it does I'm not
exactly sure myself but okay I'm
assuming that one day I'll get my knight
to F4 and then we could shake hands
I did not give a check he went Rook E1
no D7 okay sorry The Rook is on E1 and
he played King D7
did Lavon
let's break our uh
analysis and jump to a Bucharest as
Christian is with Richie
I give up thank you Yasser yes we are
indeed here with Richard report one of
uh the more creative Geniuses on the
circuit Richard welcome back to the
studio a difficult tournament for you so
far and today quite a difficult game as
well what was your approach going in
today's round yeah this was actually my
only difficult game because
um you know I yeah I feel a little bit
uh sorry for Fabia because I didn't hang
anything alone in this game so
yeah I didn't really have any
initial approach I mean I just thought
okay um try it we'll play the same as I
played previously I changed a little bit
because that Bishop B7 but I figured
okay I will just try to you know
to mine the which copyright which is
clearly covered by his pieces and I
think I did that so anyway you did that
perfectly now quite uh you you were
blitzing out a lot of moves and putting
a lot of pressure on your opponent's uh
preparation now were you surprised that
he was up to this point spending almost
half an hour
um a little bit I mean there I think
there was some games with this queen V8
and visual Basics yeah this cream B5 is
this position is very awkward yeah
because first it's already recorded you
know he has a C5 and E5 and I found this
out but then it even makes it weird that
I take cb5 so for instance probably um
it's a it's very hard to you know find
anything similar to this you know
playing Theory or any classical games I
don't know holy structure so yeah I
thought it was reasonable for him to to
think a lot and he came up with a very
logical plan
um I think with uh yeah and the critical
moment was of course um after nicest
grave and I think I made a mistake I
will let you do
yeah here nicely was a good move and I
think I could just take it here of
course
and I didn't like this altogethers as
much but probably I have some Fortress
ideas with bringing the king to C6
yeah I didn't like Ruby three of course
that I'm losing a poem but before it's
working system is fine
or I don't know if it can be called fine
but then you know something like this
and you are getting some assets yeah I
have some company I mean I think I think
it should be fine so I went for 97 which
was you know great choice and then
Bishop B3 okay is reasonable
yeah and serum high original ideas
Queen side
um yeah and to play King B7 King C6 but
you know just A4
um yeah and and before and 95 years can
be seven and here um I don't know even
something like a C6 track but also if he
just prepares to sacrifice on D5 I
didn't like it that much with item B5
like you know just double up and then if
it takes Rook D1 yeah or something but
also like C6 ideas 1946 or something
like that got it looks unpleasant so
yeah this was also kind of
and it does seem like according to the
engine at least it's quite unpleasant I
mean it's always unpleasant this hole
and it's unpleasant but not the thing is
that he's able to open up the position
plus I have additional weaknesses on
if I went before compared to you know
the usual unpleasantness which is just
at one week and 77. also it doesn't feel
like you're getting any sort of counting
yeah yeah so I think this was also like
okay that's why I played 2K6 and now of
course he could have gone for this line
with A5 A4 b495 Knight D5 sorry forcing
96 check take six but on the other hand
okay you never know is this a fortress
or not right so I mean I don't blame him
for not entering this because it's I I
have only one KD7 is clearly protected
by the king and maybe you can go
somewhere yeah something like that or
and just the king of the 18c8 next and I
don't and if it takes you finally yeah
and everything maybe it's just a
fortress I mean my knight is existing
useful on D5 right so
yes so yeah this was one of the critical
continuations he didn't go for this but
the whole line is a bit tricky yeah
because I'm not really having high hopes
but also for him I mean how to break
through he doesn't just want to go for
96 track cd6 and then she has a fortress
so yeah he went for history and here I
played F5 which is again uh maybe a
little bit you know not too ambitious
because my ambition is to make a draw
but like two ambitious Innovative I
wanted everything at once like either
equalized fast yeah exactly like because
okay after let's say A4 which was of
course logical move in my original I
don't know for black to play High Five
here yeah here he has knighted two ideas
right and that the game will go on for
every reason like before so like uh it's
nothing deadly but established upon
strong but you're gonna he will after 95
he will try to sacrifice on D5 there's
Rook D1 let's say and so not night
before yeah before I think is fine I
just take and breaking d8 or something
so I wanted to go for F5 just you know
to be able to um
with King F7 bring the other room and
then it's way for saying no I believe
before uh what he played uh I put some
F7 right did you feel at any point that
he was building up some sort of I think
the critical I mean there was many
critical months but there was one
critical moment of the Ruby eight
um
here yes because here the route 67 was I
think what he was operating a lot it's
very concrete look takes Rook Rook C7
and now you know okay for instance I was
thinking to playing uh E8 C6
and now you're knocking on mobile didn't
see anything else
and this is like almost 70 for him like
foreign
because after 196 okay I mean after okay
696 obviously he's putting the pressure
but if he doesn't take on D7 I kind of
achieved something a traded Rooks I have
King E8 I am so absolutely and then you
have something to attack yeah exactly
and what he did was very forcing I mean
the line but I felt like I was not in
too much trouble afterwards because the
people on just gives me counter play and
I saw you I came to the plane hole and I
saw you quite looking quite confident at
this point you were playing King EA
Bishop to Da quite quickly also putting
a lot of pressure on his time did you
dream about maybe even winning this game
well if I was right I would be very
optimistic as black but this is probably
being right I was not having to have
hopes I mean I thought something could
go wrong for him as well especially
because the line is very forcing for
what he went for I mean this 96 or K7
stuff and I will get my Pawn to B3 and
you know okay it's close to promoting
and also like I didn't feel too much at
risk because my E6 F5 phone structure
wise is holding very well his his
majority yes so even if something goes
extremely extremely wrong and he
captures a Pawn on B3 probably I still
have time to to Target even if you get
at least one of them yeah yeah it still
would be very comfortable draw so I
wasn't too much at the you know worried
here but um yeah I also thought to try
to play for some tricks so I went for
this night before Bishop E7 stuff but I
think he played precisely and I think
from here on drove was a normal outcome
yeah and you will be playing tomorrow
Shaq is that camera I think yeah you're
playing yarn uh with the white pieces
how are you going to uh approach that
game if anything special at all right I
try to go all it all out yeah that's
right I I had three games so far and in
two PMS I hang a piece and it runs more
than just a piece so I I don't know I
mean I I don't think I I should be the
one uh
going all out I will play normal and
hope for the best I've been doing that
actually the whole tournament but
somehow you know
didn't just seems like I was doing that
but I I tried to play as soon as
possible so I will just do the same
tomorrow
um I don't really play for prices okay
on minus two so
we'll see while I have you here uh tell
us what do you think about this position
okay a lot of things change since we're
here yeah we this is the King on C8 I
started our interview somewhere around
here with the kids yeah yeah yeah okay
yeah yeah I mean I don't know because
Kingdom c69 it's a 95 check game so it
might just uh it might just be over as
this because I'm a hill I think he will
take a pawn right or perhaps yeah yeah
and then 25 and night yeah he'll take a
pawn and then it's very concrete so I I
I'm not I don't feel like I'm able to
tell you but I think okay so it's
extremely concrete position so it might
not be meaningful White Diamond Temple
or something but yeah I I would think
that white made an improvement compared
to you know pronunciation well we're
going to uh leave the guys uh in the
studio analyze this at length thank you
very much Richie for joining us and
we'll see you tomorrow guys back to you
thank you very much and for Richie I
mean again you you want his courage you
want his created really to be rewarded
just not his tournament Peter sometimes
you just have those bad nothing nothing
clicked and also yeah for for a player
of his stature to have two of those
blackouts in one tournament is is
obviously very very painful the
standings with only one game running are
Wesley is on top there mvl uh Drew so he
did not catch up what an important game
it is uh Lavon aronian we think is lost
or losing uh to Yan and if Jan were to
win this game Wesley uh will be in clear
first but we have an additional
interview so let's uh go go back to
Bucharest and hang on in a bit Yeah but
we're getting linear mic'd up as they
say yeah linear might join uh the uh the
Bucharest Studio because he just won
that game against I'm waiting for that
I'm waiting for more more of the uh all
commands there yeah you know if if you
tell in the air that one move before the
game ended in a resignation it is just
dead equal according to according to the
heartless engines I wonder if he
suspects will hit us with a command
Lester
thank you thank you Yasser uh we do have
linear after another topsy-turvy game
with the black pieces a huge Victory
against Shakira mamidiarov uh what's
happening for decisive results in eight
games uh for a stable player like you
what's happening in this tournament yeah
somehow a lot of action in my games and
and the results as well but yeah I mean
it's a tough tournament obviously you
have to play every game with the fully
focused and just whatever happens and
somehow today was
what's going well let's see what
happened take us through the critical
moments of today's game yeah it's
usually very solid line I don't know why
it's slightly better but not not nothing
special uh after
uh Knight 95
I guess black has a choice I can also
keep the tension and play castle short
here but I thought that CD4 was uh was a
good way to play
um and then we get some simplifications
and after
um okay this position
um I felt that uh
it's more or less okay for black because
I always have this bishop F6 and white
has some squares like the C4 square and
some pressure against the queen side but
usually it's uh it's supposed to be okay
and okay the real the real action
started uh later it is really like the
game was going towards a draw yeah but
at this point after he played this move
G3 it did feel like his King is getting
a bit weak did you feel the same yeah I
mean I felt that of course it's very
equal but uh I felt that uh if he goes
G3 F4 then it can it can it can be at
some point uh also tricky for white but
okay
um charcoal was plays for uh just for a
win so it's uh normal I guess and then
uh yeah I think he takes a five uh so in
this moment I felt that taking on F5 was
dubious because just opening the
position for the bishop doesn't feel
right so I saw Knight to four here which
was more safe perhaps but somehow I
underestimated this whole idea with
Queen F3 and King H1 and then my knight
is in trouble so I had to fight for my
life later but I think I found this H5 I
didn't see much else it was indeed the
best way to continue this H5 maybe MJ
because the thing is yeah it's of course
very dangerous for for black but uh but
on the other hand if black is okay then
there there is certain danger for for
white as well which is what happened in
the game so
um Rook F1 is critical because it seems
like uh the Knight on G2 is not great
yeah of course absolutely and here of
course uh yeah Queen E4 maybe it's not
the best move but I was I didn't see a
way for white at least to win I mean F6
I have Knight H4 and then Knight back to
G6 so after Queen E4 I I I saw this Rook
D3 already from a few moves before and
uh I mean basically I I saw that I'm out
of out of danger here but I felt that it
should be a draw with Bishop takes of
Simon after Knight F4 I thought it's uh
uh White has to do this because
otherwise it's just a really really
thorough Line Game and he played after
Knight to afford this move Queen to E4
did you understand that at this point
you're starting to have real chances of
taking the full point home I mean after
already after I play Rook G3 that I
realized that um he has to play look at
free and then takes a knight of four
it's obviously only black can win this
position so I was of course thinking
about Victory but I I was expecting the
move Bishop takes F7 I thought it's what
I was considering uh queen of seven
queen of four Queen B3 this is the line
that uh Chuck Weir didn't like and um I
mean understandably so because if Queen
C7 King E8 it looks like the checks are
getting to an end after 28 or king of
seven and king of six
yeah and uh you'll have the E6 square
foot right six and then the king just
goes forward so it's it's a tricky end
game as well but I felt that somehow
this was the best practical chance for
white and he did play this move uh in
the game Queen to E4 and then you guys
got to this position
and no it's a draw here it does seem
like it's still because it looks so bad
with this move but only move Queen to G3
did you spot this I mean I saw something
but I mean I thought that I would play
Queen E5 anyway Queen to E5 and now
Bishop to E6 once again and only oh
and he can hold like this
I mean yeah it's just it looks so bad
because all the end games are are losing
somehow but there's no way to also some
checkmating threats and or or trade a
queen so
uh yeah I guess then uh uh my my king G7
F6 was probably a mistake but uh from a
human's point of view it's extremely
difficult to find all these perfect
moves and he did play the move Queen to
G8 Queen to E5 and I resigned a big
victory for you you're going to finish
uh this tournament with a clash with a
player that you know quite well Wesley
so with uh the black pieces though how
are you going to approach that game
actually you do have the white pieces in
that game yeah I have white yeah it's
obviously of course a tough game I mean
are you going to go all out well I mean
I I'll I think uh with a winning Force
attack I think I have chances to to tie
for first which is I mean it's always
nice to to reach the last round with
that sort of situation so I think it's
it's more than I was expecting yesterday
anyway so I'm very happy and yeah the
strategy is just to oh the same that I
was doing before just try to
play my best and and see what happens
then you here thank you very much for
joining us and good luck in tomorrow's
big Clash against Wesley thank you and
we're going to take a break right now
stay with us we're going to come shortly
with the final game between Jan and
Levon
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
and we and we're back with the the one
remaining game of round eight of the uh
Bucharest Superbad chess classic and
what a tremendously oh yeah there he is
that's the face I I had to I had to stop
myself Midway there because yeah this is
the shot this is a shot of a man who now
realizes that this is a study and this
is not a study of white to win it is a
study for of black black to make a draw
and uh yeah Levon Levon gets away with
yet another one it's shocking I mean it
is really shocking Levon getting away
not once but twice in this tournament
with totally lost positions and this one
guys what I mean it was difficult for us
to understand during the break which we
spent half munching on food and half
trying to understand why the engine
thought this was finally a draw yeah and
I mean a major major concern there for
white in many a line is uh the the the
the at the ending that was uh
immortalized in the game between
anishagiri and Sam Shanklin right now
that is a very very important mechanism
in in many in many variations but Jan
was very aware of that if we can go back
uh to the shot with the with the
analysis board right uh yeah move 70 uh
move 78 for instance uh Jan here instead
of 96 has the option of playing Knight
d8
but he very very carefully played 96
instead of 98 because 98 allows the
immediate drop with Rook takes d8 and
then King E6 and once the king gets to
ca this is the construction that you
need to know you need to know you need
to be aware of despite the fact that
your whole piece down the King on C8 can
only be stalemated it cannot be driven
away from the B7 points in any kind of a
proactive proactive manner or you can
drive it into the corner and stalemate
it there right that's an additional
option you have here which explains that
why you can also block the checks
because then as soon as you end up
taking this Knight your king gets back
but hean obviously was aware of that he
played 96 and then he brought the king
back to B3 and now you can no longer
continue getting checks very happily
capturing the pawn and and this is where
you miss Roxy won and uh because King G7
I thought King D7 was holding the draw
and in fact it only loses to a very very
specific idea here Knight C5 check is a
draw King B2 is a draw but King B3 B4
uh wins the game here for white because
after Rook C1 we will always have access
to the idea of 95 check if we need it
and we can also probably publish before
here and protect the protect the pawn
from A5 but the major idea is that if
you continue giving me checks from uh
from below after King before the King
goes to A5 then it goes to B5 and then
it goes to A6
and once it lands on A6 and once it
lands on A6 we have Knight A5 it's an
incredibly important resource the checks
run out the pawn on B6 is now uh very
very safely protected and it will cause
black the rook and then the game but by
starting with Rook C1 uh Levon wins this
all-important Tempo because the threat
now is not King D7 in the current
position the threat is Rook takes C7 and
then King this out that is nasty and
this means that King before is no longer
fast enough you actually need to address
the fact that black is threatening to
make an immediate draw with Rook C7 and
whichever move you make really really
worsens the position of your pieces if
you play uh Knight D6 here for instance
rugby one B6 I guess is the cleanest
solution we go Ruby one check we go Rook
takes B6 it's an immediate draw and you
just cannot stop it you can play an Ida
check but after King D7 once again your
pieces are completely tied down and
black will be able to uh sacrifice it
sacrifice The Rook for something
and yeah there is a shot of a man who
recognizes yeah what is I mean I'm wrong
in this tournament for Ian I just
uh it it it feels like a waterfall like
a Cascade of just yeah he's sitting
there yeah well
yeah he is a very very expressive player
one of the one of the more expressive
players
Hikaru and obviously Gary himself was
yeah very the the the OG of facial
expressions but yeah young young where
is it very much you know openly on his
sleeve and he's just sitting there
thinking I think how am I not winning
here yeah I think he's just so dazed by
what uh
and where did it uh where did it go yeah
and and the the way he was winning in
the position which I thought was already
completely winning is quite shocking to
me uh the mistake was I thought the
mistake was later but the mistake after
Knight E5 King G5 it's already I mean uh
yeah here 95 he already no longer win
you have to play Knight H4 Check Yes as
it turns out you have to play Knight you
have to lure the king further into the
into your position King G4 you cannot
capture the pawn yeah you have to play
King G4 and now we play 9g2
we play King E5 and this is this is the
all-important yeah and we we don't yes
we shoulder yeah we shoulder the king
away from the C8 Square we go King E6
and eventually eventually we will win
this position because the Knight will
come in yeah King will get the C8 and
and this that will be quite enough yeah
but Knight is for check and 92
specifically like I mean at this point
he just felt that he was winning almost
anything I mean all you got to do is go
and round up the the B Pawn which is
what he uh and he was very aware of the
the necessity of keeping the king away
from the ca Square s96 as his witnessed
by him playing 96 very accurately and
not 98. but yeah even if you don't see
Rook C1 you do have this inner sense
that you're cutting it close here
exactly you're definitely cutting it
close but you still coming back yourself
like you're you're two minor pieces and
the pawn Against The Rook it should be
easy your king is not really on H1 here
you know it's pretty it's pretty close
to where the action is right and
yeah I mean you missed Rook C1 and your
initial feeling is that yes it's kind of
tricky now because the the remaining
material is so limited but you've
calculated everything cleanly you know
the king comes back to b3y I'd be five
A4 B3 GX run now B7 Pawn Falls King D7
losers yeah and then yeah then your
opponent plays Rook C1 and you're just
set there you know screaming in early
right at the unfairness of it all yeah
and here we go King B4 I think it's on
yeah the board whatever you choose to
play and uh Knight C5 is the threat so
you instantly play Rook take C7 as Lavon
has done and you save the game and tie
for first
yeah incredible
wow man has infinite lives wow no I'm
sure he's used seven of those and you
know through Friday
to make things worse he's not even a cat
person he's a dog person yeah that's
right yeah shout out shout out to pawn
chick yeah yeah but I'm telling you this
was a ghoulish this Friday the 13th and
even though I'm not superstitious I mean
whatever it is uh levant's cologne uh
something I mean
it's working for him wow that's crazy
yeah that is a very crazy conclusion to
this game uh Houdini like this gaming
well with that draw remarkably enough we
only have one win for the round yeah
back to our usual
that is true and blessings
that we didn't expect the victory yeah
either like right what black is now
seven six ahead as well it's a kind of a
sub line which is uh it's a you know sub
story that is not that important but
still uh black is about 50 in the
tournament with uh linear being the only
Victor with the black pieces today I'm
gonna write a new book it's not black is
okay black is better
I mean I'm going to use this tournament
this uh my primary example of of what
I'm talking about uh guys we just
witnessed uh
what can I say houdini-like escape and
uh congratulations to uh Lavon as he is
he he keeps it at the time yeah the
shirt first and everything to play for
tomorrow absolutely yeah we can take at
some point the look of the pairings for
tomorrow because that's going to be
hugely important remember we have
playoffs tomorrow if we have two or more
players tied for first place currently
we have two players tied it's Wesley and
Levon but there's a couple of people
looking in that can say all right you
guys draw your games I can win mine
right take a look at the pairings if we
have them for uh tomorrow's round
he just had some you know brief respite
Yesterday by winning that game against
uh uh Yan but yeah back back to having
uh problems in this tournament in
general this year Richard before
problems in the sermon Richard report
against yeah Richard apologizing to his
opponent baby today we're not blundering
a piece yeah uh nepo will uh feel the
same and yeah and this is how our day
wound up one Victory only that was for
linear Dominguez he said okay guys that
that's a good prize fund I'd like to be
on the top half of that price
is he has four and again only Max even
Shirley Grove at plus one hoping that uh
Wesley and Lavon will stumble
what
yeah we didn't quite get that but uh
yeah
but nope
but yeah the people who died for first
did not lose to GameStop yeah
it's just about wow
guys I mean it's great calling the these
games but sometimes uh we're just so
confused let's go to Bucharest and uh
Christian
with an amazed levonne aronian
thank you uh Yasser yes we are here with
Levon aronian one of the co-leaders
going into the championship around Levon
first of all uh welcome back and
congratulations another who really like
Escape take us through the emotions of
this roller coaster of the game well the
typical emotions I get a good position
and then I relax and I think
I can do anything and then I completely
forgot this B5 V6 when I saw B5 and then
B6 is coming I started panicking it was
like
terrible emotions the first well let's
start with the opening it felt like you
guys were going for this Force line and
it felt like the game is going to Peter
out into uh
this idea I didn't remember exactly I
thought Bishop B6 is also possible but I
thought Bishop is selling should be fine
as well
and uh
so
I looked at it I thought night before is
the most practical it should be the one
equalizing
uh I didn't really see anything for him
yeah I saw this bishop B3 Bishop before
Bishop G5 I just wrote the six and I
think one moment that Peter was
mentioning here was that white had to
play this move to preserve any sort of
chances for a victory because you also
get yes I thought then A5
A5
yes A3 yeah this should be a draw
Somalia Bishop 24 Bishop type B6 I mean
of course it's uh maybe Knight before is
uh
we just mentioned this as in the only
way in which he could press or try for
anything but then we were proven wrong
because you did allow this idea oh yeah
I mean I have a totally fine position I
just should uh play carefully some
some accuracy needed but still and then
B5 came and then I thought okay I'm
toast and I have to say that I came into
the plane home and Annie your fiance
your wife sent to be was uh there and
she asked me uh is Levon in trouble and
I said well he probably is in trouble
but I give him good chances to save it
and then well it was of course a
difficult end game uh of course there
were probably mistakes from both sides
but
yes so here somehow I I went wrong of
the bishop before yeah I felt that there
has to be something I was a bit afraid
of this King F5 something maybe this was
the way yeah Jenga five Bishop F6 and
now you have to go back
yeah somehow it's kind of difficult to
play very precisely in this type of
thing no I was more afraid of uh uh King
F5 for King C5 oh honestly I felt that
yeah
to try to go for for the B7 Pawn right
yeah yeah I did take and now Rook to A8
seems to be one of the uh yeah no no
I've been too passive here of course
yeah and here yeah well now I'm I'm
definitely lost
and uh
and of course here well I mean there are
no real chances because I have to try
this king before like in game with uh
Felicia I have to take the phone same
here I have to try it you have to try
for the Practical approach and you play
this move came to B5 I know it's easily
winning I knew that well the most uh I
think uh the easiest way was King D5
here of course but also here I think
after King E6
uh even Knight G6 in the Knight H4 I
thought was finishing it because with
Knight on G2 you know my Rook has to
let his king enter and then King goes to
E6 right and then and yes when you play
95 I thought oh my God if I'm losing
like this then it will be some kind of a
puzzle yes because it's uh it's so close
so risky right and then uh yeah I found
this uh Rook C1 yeah but are there any
other ways to draw no no it seems like
this one is the only way yeah yeah
okay I got pretty lucky this is the only
way that I'm pretty lucky pretty lucky
but you found the last resource and
that's what's important tomorrow you're
playing Shaq with the white pieces
Wesley has to defend with the black
pieces against Lane near how are you
going to approach this game what's the
strategy are you going to take extra
risks if necessary
oh I'm not sure I think
so far I survived survived and got there
so I'll try to play solid perfect thank
you very much we'll see you tomorrow
live on guys back to you in the studio
thank you Christian and once again what
can we say uh amazing saved by ronian
and uh who's prepared for the
championship round sorry yeah reasonable
I mean a lot of clarity there for for
Formula One in terms of where he thought
he was still in the game and where he
correctly assumed that something has
gone wrong and he's lost I was kind of
looking forward to you know the the
concept of that particular Mutual being
explained to him right that would have
been a lot of fun
yeah the losing of the temple 58 would
have been an interesting concept to try
to get across this one but uh but yeah
the round is over we have our standings
with one round to go uh as we've shown
you a moment ago with this game drawn uh
Title First are Wesley and levonne MBL
isn't clear third then there is four
people and fifty percent who would of
course like to to end on a high by
winning the last round absolutely and we
have the the championship side of the
round with uh livon White against shark
Wesley black against linear Dominguez
and VL on the black side against his uh
teammate and Countryman alireza feroza
and uh two more games Report with his
last chance of trying to win a game in
this tournament fight against Yan and
Bogdan deck hoping I guess to finish a
very solid tournament with a solid game
with the white pieces against 5A
absolutely and our predictions as we go
to our Championship Saturday uh
I was close I was still crushing
Barbara is doing well yeah no question
about it and uh I'm ignoring the
sacraments yeah this well
let's jump to uh Bucharest for some
final thoughts of uh yet another
eventful round uh Anastasia and
Christian
eventful indeed but I have to say today
I felt a bit more quiet only one
decisive result that was the game
between uh my mediarov and Dominguez
Dominguez going in to the final
championship round well he has a lot of
confidence because he won with the black
pieces now he gets to have the white
pieces against Wesley that's a huge
chance for him to try to strike and
potentially go into the tie breaks of
course Levon aronian also has the white
pieces against a struggling Mama diaro a
big big very unpleasant defeat for my
media of today with the white pieces
he's going to have to try to gather
himself in the championship round but we
have a lot of excitement lined up for
you tomorrow Anastasia what do you have
in store for us for tomorrow I actually
I'm wondering if uh said today that he
was lucky and you know I'm wondering if
he's like he's a winner or not we will
see it tomorrow item in the last round
will be the size one for the standings
in this grandchester I was actually
happy that Richard Robert played a very
decent game without giving pieces to
anyone especially to Fabiano and okay
Fabiano's chances maybe are not so great
after that game but still I mean it's
going to be a nice interesting round
tomorrow looking forward to it it's
going to be the final championship round
and we're going to Crown a Victor I'm
very excited from here in Bucharest to
see who's going to get the first
grandchild tour of the Year guys how
about yourselves well thank you
Christian thank you Anastasia we're
going to leave it to Alejandro to sum it
up because I got to tell you I'm still
he saved it today but I want to point
out there's a somebody that's on 50
throwing a lot of fighting Spirit coming
back from losses and that's a certainly
near Dominguez remember he bounced back
from a couple of defeats now it's on 50
but he shows that he's really strong in
certain positions he can just play with
the best and he doesn't get affected it
doesn't tilt after a loss he just comes
back plays his game and takes his
chances so kudos to domingue is still
doing amazing championing there the
Queen's Gambit accepted and an important
win for him
thank you Alejandro for me I've seen uh
Ian just shaking his head and it's
painful it is it is a very painful
situation to find and to find yourself
in yeah because I think he thought he
calculated everything out and uh exactly
wasn't sure but uh Jan definitely also
in here he calculated everything else
and uh like what has gone wrong what did
I do I have a bad karma you know yeah it
seems to have angered the gods yes
exactly yeah okay not that that's Rafia
well
but to remind everybody it's not the
same time in the same channel we're one
hour earlier just in case of playoffs we
want to accommodate the organizers and
the closing ceremony so one hour earlier
I'm sure you're looking forward to that
Peter from Joshua yeah
good morning all right thank you
everyone for sharing your day with us
we'll see you all tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited